SENATE BUDGET.
SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE ON PUBLIC
SAFETY AND THE JUDICIARY WILL
NOW.
BEGIN.
I'M WE HAVE PRIMARILY --
OVERSIGHT ITEMS WERE NOT
INTENDING TO TAKE ACTION TODAY --
BUT WE WILL HEAR FROM NUMBER OF
FOLKS.
AND OUR FIRST ISSUE THAT WE'RE
GOING TO DISCUSS.
IS THE JUDICIAL BRANCH WILL DO
ROLL CALL IN A MINUTE.
AND ON THE COLLABORATIVE COURTS
SO LET'S DO ROLL CALL.
TURNER SKINNER.
SIR MORLOCK [inaudible]
SIR ABOUT.
ALL RIGHT --
ARE -- FOR
FIRST SPEAKER IS --
HONORARY RICHARD LIVE JANOS THE
JUDGE OF THE SUPERIOR COURT OF
FROM -- TEN
JOAQUIN COUNTY.
JUST A SPORTS IS HE HERE YES
GREAT HI [inaudible]
WELCOME [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
I AM MR THEATER OVER Q. ARE ALSO
COME TEAM AT THE TABLE AND FOR
SINCE IT'S NOT LISTEN OUR AGENDA.
HE IS OUR DIRECTOR AND CHIEF
FINANCIAL OFFICER OF THE BUDGET
SERVICES FOR THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL.
SO [inaudible]
I JUDGE LOBBY ON US GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU ON A DAY TO GIVE ME
THE OPPORTUNITY --
TALK YOU BOOK ONE OF MY PASSIONS --
SOMETHING I'VE BEEN DOING FOR
ABOUT TEN YEARS IN THE IN THE
COLLABORATIVE COURTS --
AND FIRST COURT WAS IN NINETEEN
NINETY FOUR IN CAL IN CALIFORNIA
I'M SURE LITTLE WHILE WE WERE
STILL LEARNING --
WISHED WE'RE LEARNING ONE A NICE
THINGS ABOUT COLLABORATIVE
COURTS IS --
WE HAD WERE DATA DRIVEN REACHER
RIVEN -- SO
WE DO IT RIGHT WHERE WE HAVE
RESEARCH AND DATA TELLS US WHAT
WORKS WHAT DOESN'T WORK WHAT WE
KEEP WHAT WE SHOULDN'T.
SO WERE WERE INVOLVED.
EITHER TOTAL OF FOUR HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE AND THAT AS IN
ACROSS THE ENTIRE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
COM AND THEY RANGE FROM YOUR
TRADITIONAL DRUG COURT MODEL
WHICH THERE ARE THERE ARE A LOT
OF ALL THE WAY TO TRUANCY COURTS
IN COMMUNITY COURTS IN.
A HOMELESS COURTS AND IT'S
REALLY KIND OF A DESCRIPTION OF
HIM OF THE COURT.
KIND OF WORKING ON THE
SUPERVISION SIDE WORKING WITH
INDIVIDUALS TO TRY TO PREVENT
THEM FROM RETURNING BACK TO
COURT SO IT'S ALL ABOUT.
RECIDIVISM REDUCTION IT'S ALL
ABOUT REDUCING THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE TO COME BACK INTO COURT
THE GOING TO PRISON TO GO INTO
THE DEPARTMENT STATE HOSPITALS --
BY DOING THE EARLY IN
INTERVENTIONS SO --
WE'VE BEEN DOING IT FOR A WHILE
UNDER US KIND OF A TREND NOW. TO
GO BEYOND JUST THE WITH THE
TRADITIONAL INDIVIDUAL THAT
WOULD GO INTO YOUR TRADITIONAL
DRUM CORPS.
WHICH IS THE HIGH RISK KIND
NEEDS PERSON --
THE PROBLEM WITH THAT IS IT IS A
VERY SMALL PERCENT OF OUR OF OUR
POPULATION THAT COMES TO THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM THE
ACTUAL.
LARGER NUMBER OF THE PEOPLE WHO
COME THROUGH MULTIPLE TIMES ARE
HIGH RISK LOW NEEDS --
WHICH NEED A DIFFERENT TYPE OF
MODEL WHICH IS A KIND OF AN
ACCOUNTABILITY TYPE MODEL SO
WE'RE EXPANDING INTO THINGS LIKE
MULTIPLE TRACKS.
YOU TAKE ALL THE PEOPLE WHO --
WHO -- SCORE
IS A HIGH RISK ON ON AN
ASSESSMENT AND THEN BEING ABLE
TO DESIGN SOMETHING APPROPRIATE
TO MINIMIZE THEIR RETURN.
BACK -- SO
THE NEW THE NEW THE NEW TREND IS
TO USE VALIDATED RISK ASSESSMENT
ASSESSMENT TOOLS --
TO TELL US WHO IS AT HIGH RISK
RE OFFEND JULES BY HAVING THEM
SCREENED ASSESSED --
AND THEN REFERRED OUT TO
WHATEVER IT IS THAT THEY NEED
THEY'RE ALL DIFFERENT --
TO WHATEVER IT IS THAT THEY NEED
AND A MONITOR MAKE SURE THAT SO
I KIND OF REFER TO IT AS YOUR
TRIAGE.
YOU KNOW WHAT YOU'RE DOING ON
THAT SENTENCE SIDE YET YOU HAVE
ALL THESE PEOPLE WITH ALL THESE --
TRAUMAS AND DAMAGES INSIDE OF
THEM THAT HAVE DRIVEN THE
BEHAVIOR TO THIS POINT --
AND IF YOU WANT TO BE EFFECTIVE
IN HAVING THEM NOT COME BACK --
IT'S ABOUT ASSESSING THAT
SCREENING AND ASSESSMENT
FIGURING OUT WHAT THE ROOT OF
THE PROBLEM IS AND THEN
ADDRESSING THE ROOT OF THE
PROBLEM WHETHER THAT'S THINKING
WHETHER THAT'S DEPENDENCE.
ON WHATEVER GEARS YOU DESIGN THE
PROGRAM AROUND WHAT THE ROOT OF
THE PROBLEM.
AN OVERALL --
STOOD AT THE DELIVERY THE COURTS
ARE DOING IT AND DOING IT RIGHT
SHOWED DRAMATIC --
REDUCTION IN WRIST IS IN WHICH
WORKS FOR EVERYBODY IT'S IN
EVERYBODY WINSTON AREA.
I MIGHT JUST WANT TO KEEP MY
INTRODUCTORY COMMENTS QUICK AS I
CAN IT'S MORE ABOUT GETTING THE
PANEL THE INFORMATION YOU NEED
SO I WANT TO OPEN IT UP TO
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
DOES OUR DEPARTMENTS AND WANT TO
ADD ANYTHING OR JUST YOU HAVE TO
SUPPORT IT IS WORSE IS MY FIRST
TIME.
HI OKAY I'M I DO A FEW QUESTIONS
AND THEN OBVIOUSLY.
CALL MY COLLEAGUES ON SO.
I AM SOMEWHAT FAMILIAR WITH OUR
COLLABORATIVE COURTS HAVING --
SERVED ON THIS COMMITTEE FOR
SOME TIME --
AND I KNOW THAT WE HAVE.
A GOOD DEAL OF THEM ACROSS THE
STATE ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE BUT WHAT I'M INTERESTED IN
OUR WHAT JUDICIAL BRANCH FUNDS
ARE USED TO PAY FOR THE
COLLABORATIVE COURTS HOW MUCH OF
THIS IS.
THE I KIND OF ELECTIVE ON THE
PART OF THE INDIVIDUAL COURTS SO
DOES THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
DESIGNATE FOR EVERY --
JURISDICTION A CERTAIN AMOUNT
THAT THEY CAN UTILIZE FOR
COLLABORATIVE QUARTERS ARE
REALLY MUCH MORE THAT.
IT'S THE LOCAL AREA THAT DECIDES.
THERE IS THE OLD DRUG COURT --
FUNDING MODEL ON DISTRIBUTED OUT
AMONGST COURTS AND THAT HAS BEEN
DEVOLVED DOWN NOW TO THE
COUNTIES ON TO THAT MONEY
ACTUALLY GOES THROUGH THE
COUNTIES AND COMES TO THE COURT
THROUGH THE COUNTIES.
ON THE OTHER FUNDING SOURCES ARE
IT'S IT'S VERY MUCH A HODGEPODGE
EVERY ORDER IS DIFFERENT.
AND THERE IS NO ORGANIZED
THEMATIC FUNDING SOURCE TO THE
INNOVATIONS GRANT WHICH ON WHICH
PROVIDE US GREAT JOBS ALLOWED US
TO MOVE.
LEAPS FORWARD ON OUR ON OUR DIY
FOR IN OUR COMMUNITY SUPERVISION
CORE ORGANIZING THAT HIGHER E.
OUR SYSTEM.
I'M IT'S BEEN WONDERFUL FOR THAT
SO THERE'S THE INNOVATIONS GRANT
COMES THROUGH THERE AND THEN A
LOT OF COURTS ARE ACCESSING
OTHER GRANTS LIKE.
YOUR OBJECT FEDERAL MONEY LIKE
BUREAU OF JUSTICE ASSISTANCE --
SAM.
ABUSE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
ADMINISTRATION --
AND THEIR EVER AND THOSE TYPE OF
GRANTS -- IN
OUR COUNTY WE'RE ACTUALLY USING --
HOW MANY --
S. C. C. P. DOLLARS COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS PARTNERSHIP DOLLARS --
THEY HAVE SEEN THE DATA AND THEY
HAVE DECIDED TO INVEST IN SOME
OF OUR COURT.
FROM THAT.
AND WE HAVE A VERY GOOD
RELATIONSHIP WITH A RURAL HEALTH
AND OUR MENTAL HEALTH COURT IS
ACTUALLY FUNDED PROP SIXTY THREE
DOLLARS.
ON SO THERE'S NO ONE FORMULA
IT'S JUST TRYING.
TO GET --
MID TO MATCH --
RESOURCES THE NICE PART ABOUT
FOR US WOULD INNOVATION DONE OUT
LOUD US TO DO IS LEVERAGE OTHER
SOURCES IN COMBINATION WITH THAT.
AND THEN BE ABLE TO PUT TOGETHER
[inaudible]
AN OVERALL.
SO BUT IN THAT RESPECT WOULD YOU
CALL I MEAN OBVIOUSLY THERE ARE
RANT SOURCES AVAILABLE NOW.
BUT IF THOSE GRANTS SOURCES WERE
TO GO AWAY I MEAN IS THIS.
I ASK ABOUT --
FOR SURE YOU KNOW HOW IN A WAY
THE QUESTION I'M REALLY TRYING
TO GET IS IS THIS A PRIORITY OF
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL BECAUSE IF.
IF FROM MY POINT OF VIEW OF THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL ITSELF IS NOT
DIRECTING SOME PORTION OF ITS
FUNDS TOWARDS HIS PURPOSE.
AND IS JUST RELYING ON THE
CREATIVITY OF EACH INDIVIDUAL OR
TO GO AND PURSUE GRANTS.
THEN IT WOULD INDICATE THAT THE
MAN -- WAYS
WHAT LEVEL PRIORITY AND I'M.
I THINK THAT.
I'M SURE THERE'S A VARIATION
DEPENDING ON THE JURISDICTION
AND THE WHAT THE POPULATION IS
THEY'RE DEALING WITH WITH THE
AXE OR PARTICULAR CLLABORATIVE
COURT.
BUT OVERALL THE REPORTS I'VE
SEEN IS THAT.
THEY ARE A RATHER SUCCESSFUL ON
I MET THE DAD THE STATE IS
EMPLOYING.
TO APPROPRIATELY DEAL WITH A SET
OF FOR WHOM.
HOLDING INCARCERATION ALONE OR
EVEN COUNTY JAIL ALONE.
IS NOT GOING TO ADEQUATELY
ADDRESS.
AND SO SLOW BUT TALK A LITTLE
BIT MORE ABOUT THE JUDICIAL
COUNCILS PRIORITY ON THIS --
WELL FIRST. ONE THING THAT THAT
I WOULD SAY IS YOU ARE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT THAT CRAP
FUNDING CREATES THAT KIND OF AN
IN.
INSTABILITY IN MAY MAKES YOU
WANT RESCUE ALWAYS.
GO OUT THAT THAT IS ABSOLUTE.
ON THE OTHER SIDE THOUGH THE ONE
THING.
I SPEAKING.
OF JUDGES ENCOUNTER AND COUNTIES
ARE ALL INDIVIDUALLY
CONSTITUTIONALLY ELECTED.
NO PROGRAM.
YOU HAVE A JUDICIAL COMMITMENT --
AND AND NO JUDGE.
THE JUDGE WHAT YOU KNOW YOU HAVE
TO DO AND HOW YOU HAVE TO DO IT --
SO YOU DO THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
DOES DIRECT THE FUNDING TO OUR
COURT THE TO THE COURTS YES.
YES.
DID YOU HAVE TO IF YOU WANT TO
BE EFFECTIVE YOU HAVE TO GET BY
YOU HAVE TO GET THAT BUY IN FROM
FROM THE JUDGES --
AT LEAST IN MY OPINION I'M GONNA
I'M GONNA REFER THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL QUESTIONS TO THOSE LOCK
BECAUSE HE'S BEEN WORK MORE
CAPABLE OF ANSWERING THAT THE
MIND --
BELIEVED TO MY CONCEPT OF WHAT'S
HAPPENED WITH THE INNOVATIONS
GROUNDS.
ON THE GROUNDS HAS BEEN REALLY A
FACTOR THE COURTS WANT TO MOVE
FORWARD --
TO MOVE FORWARD --
YOU KNOW AND THEN KIND OF CAN
COULD KIND OF BE A MOP.
OTHER JUDGES WILL COME IN SO I
THINK THAT EXTENT --
WHAT'S HAPPENED HAPPENED RIGHT
NOW -- HAS
ALLOWED US THE COURTS TO MOVE
FORWARD --
I'LL WORKERS WELL I'LL LET YOU
CAN ANSWER THE QUESTION IN A
MINUTE BECAUSE I'M GONNA ASK A
DIFFERENT.
ONE AND THEN ARE YOU MAY --
OPINE ON BOTH BUT THE OTHER
THING I'M INTERESTED IN IS.
WHICH COLLABORATIVE COURTS HAVE
THE HIGHEST CASELOADS.
IT DEPENDS ON HOW YOU DO IT FOR
US.
OF THE D. Y. COURT I ESCAPE.
OKAY --
BECAUSE WE HAVE STRUCTURED IT AS
MAN.
EVERY REPEAT YOU I OFFENDER IN
IN MYCOUNTY IN OUR LARGEST.
IN STOCK AND HOUSE TO GO IN
UNDATED THEY CAN ASSESS THE GET
TRAILER GET COUNT ABILITY
MONITORING IN PLACE THEN WE EVEN
IF NEEDED AND WE ABOUT WHEN WE
EVALUATE THEM.
SO ALEX PEAK I HAD A THOUSAND
PEOPLE IN THERE WERE NOW DOWN TO
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED OR THREE
HUNDRED AS IT WORKS THE FINDINGS
AND EVERYTHING I'VE GONE
DRAMATIC DOWN ON YOU ARE SITE
BECAUSE WE BROUGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TO PLAY.
ON THE OTHER COURT DATE FOR MY
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE THAT I THAT
I IS GROWING IN IS THE COMING
WAVE OF THE FUTURE IS MENTAL
HEALTH BEHAVE.
ALMOST ALL THE THROUGH US HAVE
THESE TRAUMAS THAT ARE ON
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH BASED ROCK
KIND ALMONDS.
AND IF WE REALLY WANT.
TO BE A FACTOR WE NEED TO BRING
BEHAVIOR HALL IN.
BY THAT TREATMENT SO THOSE ARE
THE TWO THAT I SEE --
BIGGEST NEED.
A SEMI.
FINAL QUESTION GRASS OF MY
COLLEAGUES GOING IN.
IS HOW IS THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
AND YOU CAN ADDRESS THE OTHER
QUESTION I MENTION BUT HOUSE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL MEASURING OUR
COLLABORATIVE COURTS.
AND IN THE CASE OF FOR EXAMPLE
THE JUDGE JUST DESCRIBED THAT
THE DO YOU I CORD IS MANDATORY
SO WOULDN'T THAT BE SOMETHING
THAT WOULD BE FUNDED DIRECTLY BY
JUDICIAL COUNCIL VERSUS GRANTS.
IN TERMS OF THE THE MEASUREMENTS
AND KNOW THAT THE INNOVATIONS
GRANT FUNDING DOES HAVE A LOT OF
DATA NECESSARY TO DEMONSTRATE
ITS OF THE PROGRAM'S
EFFECTIVENESS AND WHETHER OR NOT
THERE'S VIABILITY GOING FORWARD --
UNDER TO WHAT EXTENT --
JUDGE CAN SPEAK TO THROUGH THE
INTERACTIONS OF THE OTHER
ADVISORY COMMITTEES WHAT KIND OF
DATA IS BEEN GATHERED AND WHAT
ARE YOU DOING AT YOUR CORD --
CPARS IF MEASURING THE FACT THAT
THE REASON I ASKED IF I WAS
ASKING WITH THE JUDICIAL.
AS WHEN I'M TRYING TO GET AT IS.
HOW MUCH ARE WE TREATING THIS IS
JUST SOMETHING THAT IN A WAY
EVEN IF IT'S IN FOUR HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE JURISDICTIONS HOW
MUCH ARE WE READING THIS IS JUST
SOMETHING THAT SELECTIVE?
AND HOW MUCH IS THAT A PRIORITY
NO I UNDERSTAND AND AT THIS
POINT --
AREN'T SPECIFIC ALLOCATIONS THE
EACH COUNTY DOES HAVE IT GETS
ITS ALLOCATION AND AND IS --
THE JUDGES DISCUSSED --
THEY ARE ORTIZ AND ALSO THE
NEEDS IN THE OF THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY --
AND ALSO THE AVAILABILITY OF THE
RESOURCES BY THE LOCAL JUSTICE
PARTNERS IT WAS A STATE ONES.
THAT WAS DONE AWHILE BACK ON ON
THE DRUG FORCE HIMSELF.
ON THERE HAS NOT REALLY BEEN
PART OF THE PROBLEM IS.
IS REALLY KIND ARE THERE'S
DIFFERENT WORDS ARE TARGETING.
PROBLEM.
SO IF YOU HAVE A HOME COURT
RECIDIVISM ISN'T NECESSARILY --
THE FACT THAT THEY'RE LOOKING
OUT THERE LOOKING AT CONNECTIONS
OF SERVICES ANOTHER KIND.
IF YOU HAVE A DEPENDENCY COURT
ON YOU'RE NOT LOOKING IN OR
STANDING AS AN ACTOR OUTCOME
YOU'RE LOOKING AT UT
REUNIFICATION AND THEN BEING
ABLE BECAUSE I IF YOU HAVE A
BROTHER OR OR DO YOU LIKE WORK
YOU'RE LOOKING AT RECIDIVIST
MEASURE OUTCOME. TO DIFFERENT
COURTS HAVE DIFFERENT GOALS AND
OUTCOMES SO IT'S NOT REAL EASY
DO THAT WHOLE THING.
ON THE DO YOU I CORPS --
THAT ONE THING IS I'VE BEEN
INVITED TO MENTION EARLIER THE
FUNDING WE GOT WE GOT.
STARTED INITIATE THE D. Y. COURT
WE USED NATIONAL HIGHWAY SAFETY
ADMINISTRATION ALL ARE. EIGHT
OPS -- THEY
STARTED IT AND THEY HAVE
CONTINUED TO FUNDED --
NATIONAL HIGHWAY TRAFFIC SAFETY
ADMINISTRATION.
IS SUPPORTIVE OF THE MONITORING
SIDE THE ACCOUNTABILITY SO.
I'M MY COLLEAGUES.
MANAGER THANK YOU JUDGE --
MY PRIOR.
LIFE CAREER I WAS SUPERVISOR
COUNTY OF ORANGE --
THE NO JUSTICE CORDONING
COMMITTEE SO I A LOT OF FUN
WORKING WITH THE PRESIDING JUDGE
IN THE JUVENILE.
JUDGE AND AND THEN IT WAS ALSO.
INVITED TO ATTEND TO YOUR WIFE
GRADUATIONS WHICH WERE REALLY
IMPRESSIVE [inaudible]
AND ALSO GOT TO WATCH --
JUDGE WINDY LINDLEY WHO DID A
WHATEVER IT TAKES COURT AND MY
ROLE MODELS CHOOSING WAS
INCREDIBLE I WHEN SHE RETIRED
TWENTY FOURTEEN I WAS REALLY
DISAPPOINTED BUT FOR HER IT
SEEMED LIKE IT WAS THE MATCH IT
WAS THAT WAS.
BUT SHE WAS BUILT FOR THIS.
TYPE OF COLLABORATIVE COURT AND
SHE JUST REALLY SET THE BAR
[inaudible]
I'M.
BUT I'M JUST SORT OF A CURIOUS
HE DECIDED TO WORKING IN A AND
I'VE OBSERVED IT AND I'VE BEEN
REAL IMPRESSED --
ONE OF THE THINGS I ALSO DID WAS.
RIGHT TO BRING IN LAURA'S LAW
INTO IN ORANGE COUNTY NOW IT'S
IN ABOUT TWENTY COUNTIES.
AND WOULD LAURA'S LAW FALL UNDER
THE ADULT MENTAL HEALTH COURTS.
ON IT WOULD BE I MEAN IT JUST
WOULDN'T BE PART OF THE MEMO.
OR BUT THE CONCEPT.
THE SOMETHING AWFUL FOR ME
[inaudible]
YEAH OKAY SO RIGHT NOW THEY'RE
GOING TO JUST A REGULAR COURT
ROOM [inaudible]
THEN I'M.
JUST KIND OF CURIOUS.
AS YOU LOOK AT THAT BECAUSE WE
JUST RECEIVED THE STUDY OUT OF
VIRGINIA THAT LOOK AT LARGE LAW
IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THE CRITICISM THEY HAD IS
THAT ONLY TWENTY CHINESE
COUNTIES OF SIGNED UP.
I THINK THAT THAT THE REST OF
THE STATE SHOULD BE DOING IT SO.
I'M JUST WONDERING HOW THE
COURTS MAYBE THE COLLABORATIVE
COURTS ARE THEY ENCOURAGE COUNTY
BOARDS OF SUPERVISORS TO ADOPT
LAURA'S LAW.
NOW WE'RE ONE OF THE COUNTIES
AND HAS -- A
SHOW AND YOU KNOW IT IS AS
THOUGH HAVE ETHICAL.
WE CAN'T GO OUT IN PUBLIC.
REPORTER MEETING LAW IN CASES
LIKE THAT AFTERNOON TEA AFTER --
BUYER YEAH I DO SEE THE ONE THAT --
US OF THE ANIMATED SERIES THAT
[inaudible]
YEAH.
HEY WAIT A MINUTE --
YOU SHALL.
CAREFUL ABOUT HOW HOW WE CAN DO
THAT WE CAN BRING PEOPLE ABLE
BUT ADVOCACY IS NOT BEING.
A BIG.
SO I'LL TRY TO TRADE THAT LITTLE
DIFFERENTLY BUT MAYBE YOU COULD.
CONSIDER NOT BEING OPPOSITIONAL.
WHEN THE IDEAS ARE DISCUSSED?
WITH YOUR SUPERVISORS.
HOW ELSE --
YES I WOULD YEAH INTO A I WOULD
LOVE TO WORK WITH THE
SUPERVISORS TO DESIGN A SYSTEM
THAT WORKS THAT WORKS AND THAT'S
WHAT CLUB OF COURTS ARE ALL
ABOUT.
ABOUT GETTING EVERYBODY AROUND A
TABLE AND DESIGN A SYSTEM THAT
WORKS AND THEN.
COLLABORATING EVERYBODY WORKING
WORKING TOGETHER MAKE THAT
SYSTEM WORK IN THE IN THE CLUB
RECORD SYSTEM THE JUDGE JUST
KIND OF BRINGS PEOPLE TO THE
TABLE.
AND I LIVE OVERSEAS.
YEAH BECAUSE THIS.
IMP REFERRING BACK TO JUDGE LEN
LEAVES IT SOME WITH A SPECIAL
SKILL SET THAT CAN REALLY.
BECAUSE I WATCH DASH I WATCH YOU
DO WHATEVER IT TAKES.
SESSION FOR HOMELESS AT THE
ORANGE COUNTY HOMELESS SHELTER
ARE.
ALMOST.
THE MISSION OR CAN.
AND I WAS AMAZED AT HOW WELL.
THE INDIVIDUALS RESPONDED TO HER
IN THE IN THAT MAKESHIFT
COURTROOM IT WAS IT WAS AMAZING
SO.
HOW DO HOW DO I AS A SENATOR
HELP YOU AND HOW TO HOW DO WE?
GIVE YOU MORE SUPPORT.
WE HAVE A WE JUST HAVE TO
ENCOURAGE AND ENABLE JUDGES WHO
WANT TO DO THAT.
SO THE WAY THE WAY I ENVISION IT
IS I DIVIDE THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM IN TWO PARK.
ARREST INTERCEPTS THAT PART
PRETTY MUCH THE TRADITIONAL
SYSTEM THAT'S WHAT IT WAS
DESIGNED.
FOR BUT THEN ONCE YOU GET THE
SENTENCE IMPOSED FOR NEEDS TO BE
ANOTHER PART OF THE JUDICIAL
SYSTEM THAT.
WHERE THE COURTS WORK WITH
PROBATION COMMUNITY SUPERVISION
TO MAKE THE SUPERVISION OF FACT
OF ON ON THE BATTERY --
AND THERE ARE JUDGES IN THE
JUDGE'S YOU'RE DISCREET YOU'RE
DESCRIBING LIKE THE JUDGE LINLEY --
LET THEM GO ON THAT --
LET THEM BE THERE LISTEN LET'S
LET THEM TAKE THAT AND LET THEM
GO WITH IT WILL BE EFFECTIVE AND
IT'LL HELP EVERYBODY OUT.
SO YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT
THOUGH ON THE KEY IS I ONCE
HEARD WHEN I WAS A JUVENILE
COURT JUDGE I WAS AT A
CONFERENCE IN.
THE SPEAKER WAS TALKING ABOUT
THE EDUCATION SYSTEM HE SAID WE
USED IN THE EDUCATION SYSTEM
DESCRIBED THE THREE EIGHTHS
ATTENDANT TO DOCUMENT ANY CHEAP.
WE'VE DONE ALL THE RESEARCH AND
YOU CAN GROW TO A CELL.
YOU CAN THROW TENANTS OUT YOU
CAN THROW CHEAP IF YOU GET
ATTACHMENT AT BOTH OF THOSE
OTHERS WILL.
YOU GO AND THE SAME IS TRUE ON
THE SUPERVISION SIDE IN THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
AND WHAT YOU'RE DESCRIBING WITH
JUDGE LINDLEY'S ABILITY TO GET
ATTACHMENT.
ON AND IF YOU HAVE A JUDGE YOU
CAN GET A CAT GET THAT
ATTACHMENT WITH CLIENTS THEY
WILLDO L. ALMOST ANYTHING FOR
YOU -- TYPE
OF THING SO --
THEY DO THEY COME UP TO YOU TO
RESPOND YOU THEY COME TO COURT
MY MENTAL HEALTH COURT RIGHT NOW.
I HAVE IT'S SO FULL.
I'VE GOT AND THESE ARE PEOPLE
WHO WERE.
ALL I HAVE TO BE SEVERELY
EMOTIONALLY DISTURBED.
BUT THE TRAUMA.
FOR AND IT'S ALL BECAUSE OF THE
WAY THE SYSTEM IS STRUCTURED ACE
MAN AND EVERYBODY THEY GET OUT
OF TOUCH.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MANAGER.
THANK YOU SENATOR ABOUT --
WELL [inaudible]
QUESTION ON THE WITH WITH THE
INNOVATIONS FUNDING THEY HAVE
THEY HAVE THE BEACH COUNCIL'S
BEEN VERY SUPPORTIVE OF US WITH
THAT.
HOW THAT WORKS [inaudible]
I RESPECT --
AND CENTER ABOUT THE THE FUNDING
FORMULA --
DOES NOT --
ENCOURAGE OR DISCOURAGE ANY
PARTICULAR PROGRAM TO BE
IMPLEMENTED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
THE FUNDING THAT'S ALLOCATED IS
THAT AVAILABLE FOR LOCAL
PRIORITIES.
AND LOCAL NEEDS. TO BE
DETERMINED BY EACH COURT AND SO
HISTORICALLY FOR COURT HAS BEEN
I'M USING THE FUNDS FOR THESE
COLLABORATIVE COURTS THEN THEY
WOULD CONTINUE TO AIR MARK THOSE
FUNDS ONCE RECEIVED.
THE THE ALLOCATION METHODOLOGY
TWO THERE ARE TWO THAT PROGRAM --
THE FUNDING FOR THERE IS
REFLECTIVE OF THE FILINGS THAT
THE COURTS RECEIVED --
AS THE METHOD TO DETERMINE THE
ALLOCATION AND SO.
YEAH BASED ON THE FILINGS
[inaudible]
MY RECORD.
RIGHT THERE THERE FOR THAT WOULD
BE A LOCAL DECISION TO INVEST
THOSE RESOURCES FOR THE NEEDS
[inaudible]
I ALSO.
FROM A FUNDING PERSPECTIVE.
OR NOT AND I AND I THINK WE WE
CAN TALK ABOUT THE SUPPORT THAT
THE COUNCIL PROVIDES.
I TAKE IT [inaudible]
OF RESEARCH.
IT SHOULD BE HERE OUR KIDS.
CORRECT FROM THE BASE RESOURCES
BUT ARE THE OTHERS.
CENTER IF IF I COULD JUMP IN I'M
SHELLEY CROWNED THE DIRECTOR OF
THE COUNCIL'S CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SERVICES OFFICE --
THROUGH THE CHAIR PLEASE.
MA'AM --
GOOD MORNING.
SO.
THE THAT WHAT THE COUNCIL THE SO
THE COUNCIL HAS A AN ADVISORY
COMMITTEE A STANDING ADVISORY
COMMITTEE --
THE COLLABORATIVE JUSTICE COURTS
ADVISORY COMMITTEE AND SELL --
IT CAN IT DOES A COLLABORATIVE
COURTS AND SUPPORTING COURTS AS
THEY ESTABLISH COLLABORATIVE
TOWARDS ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
THE ADVISORY COMMITTEE DOES IS --
LOOKS FOR FUNDING OPPORTUNITIES --
LOOKS FOR OPPORTUNITIES TO TO
REPLICATE BEST PRACTICES HAS A
LOT OF RELATIONSHIPS WITH --
NATIONAL EXPERTS AROUND
COLLABORATIVE COURTS AND
PRIORITIZE IS THAT SO THAT'S ONE
THING THAT THE AT THE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE DOES.
SOME OF IT IS BASED ON GRANTS
AND BUT NOT ON A FORMULA EXCEPT
THAT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT THE
COUNCIL DOES IS WORKS WITH THE
ADVISORY COMMITTEE --
DIFFERENT TO IDENTIFY FUNDING
OPPORTUNITIES SO FOR EXAMPLE.
WHEN THE LEGISLATURE WORKED WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION AND CREATED
THE RECIDIVISM REDUCTION FUND?
COURT GRANT PROGRAM THAT WOULD
THAT FUNDED SEVERAL
COLLABORATIVE COURTS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE AND THAT WAS A VARIETY
OF REENTRY COURTS IN MENTAL
HEALTH COURTS.
IT WAS A GRANT PROGRAM YES.
A READER FOR YOUR STILL THE
BOTTOM LINE IS THE BASE FOR
OTHERS.
DOESN'T REFLECT ANY KIND OF
PRAIRIE POOLS OR IT'S STRICTLY --
OUR PRIMARY.
IT IS.
IT IS ABOUT THE THE FILINGS THAT
ARE RECEIVED BY THE COURTS.
ALL RIGHT I'D LIKE TO SEE HOW
YOU DO YOUR FORMULA.
IN TERMS OF BY BY NOT
EMPHASIZING CLEVER MARGIN IN
YOUR YOU FOR SUCH A CLEVER.
OKAY SO THAT'S MY PROPOSITION TO
YOU THAT YOUR ONLY FINDING.
TOWARDS THE ANY KIND OF RANCID
YOU CAN PICK UP THE THEIR FIRST
STATEMENT.
I DON'T I MEAN I THINK THE
COUNCIL HAS A COMMITMENT IN
TERMS OF THE SUPPORT OF CLUB OF
COURTS AT THEIR CHOSEN AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL IS --
IS CURRENT AS AS DSCRIBED --
FROM A FUNDING PERSPECTIVE THE
GOAL IS TO PROVIDE FLEXIBILITY
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL FOR THE TRIAL
COURTS TO MAKE SOME DECISIONS ON
ONE OF THE LOCAL NEEDS FOR THE
LOCAL COMMUNITY.
YES THE JOB AND THE DATE THE
MAYBE THE COMMITTEE PROVIDES
SUPPORT TERMS OF EDUCATION AND
CONFERENCES.
NETWORKING THAT THAT KIND WORDS
DUMP UP THROUGH THE COUNCIL BUT
BY THE COMMITTEE.
I'M IN THE INDIVIDUAL CORDS --
PART OF IT IS.
COURTS ARE FIFTY EIGHT DIFFERENT --
KIND OF KIND OF STRUCTURES AND
THEN IT ONE THING IS IS YOU HAVE
TO BE ABLE TO CONVINCE THE COURT
STRUCTURE SO ONE THING I WOULD
KIND OF MAYBE DISAGREE WITH.
AND I HAD THIS CONVERSATION --
BOB THE COURTS ARE MORE COSTLY.
AT THE START.
THEY SAVE MONEY DOWN THE LINE SO
I HAD A CONVERSATION WITH THE
PRESIDING JUDGE SAID IT NO WE
JUST DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES
IT'S TIME TO DO IT NOW.
DON'T HAVE THE RESOURCES TAUGHT
NOT TO DO --
BECAUSE EVERYBODY WERE PREVENTED
FROM COMING BACK BUT IT'S A IF
THAT IS A LONG TERM VISION AND
WE AS GLOBS OF COURSE NEED TO
SHOW THE DATA --
WITH DRUG THROUGH THE RESEARCH
THROUGH OUR OUTCOMES WISH WE
COULD SHOW THE DATA ON MY DO YOU
I COURT WE'RE GETTING A COST
BENEFIT ANALYSIS --
AND SHOULD COME ABOUT A YEAR
FROM NOW THE RESEARCHERS DOING A
THREE YEAR PROJECT ABOUT A YEAR
FROM NOW WHILE THE COST BENEFIT
ANALYSIS ON THE D. ON THE DO YOU
I OR THEN WE CAN MAKE SOME
REALLY INTELLIGENT SO.
WE KIND OF HAVE TO TAKE A LOOK
AT THOSE.
EVALUATION AND AND DATA --
THAT THAT THERE SHOULD BE THE
INVESTMENT IN THOSE SOURCES.
THE JUDGE I HA ANOTHER QUESTION
FOR YOU I REALLY APPRECIATE YOU
COMING HERE FOR THE SEX I THINK
YOU'VE BEEN HERE A FEW TIMES.
WITH US AND YOU KNOW --
YOU KNOW YOU'RE A TREASURE TROVE.
INFORMATION FOR US.
OF I HEAR THAT OTHER STATES HAVE
A MODELS THAT.
HAVE -- OR
ADMINISTRATIVE COURTS ARE
PROCESSES. TO DEAL WITH SOME OF
THE LOWER LEVEL --
OFFENDERS OR PEOPLE THAT ARE IN
THE COURTS AND THEY THEY DO --
PRE ARREST VERSIONS OF SUCH AS
WE TALK TO BE OUT WITH MY SP
WANTS. TO FIFTEEN LAST YEAR WE
GOT.
SIGNED INTO LAW AND THOSE KINDS
OF PROCESSES THAT ARE LIKE --
IN MINISTRY OF LESS FORMAL --
PROCESSES --
WHICH CAN BE USED --
TO REMOVE PEOPLE FROM YOUR
CALENDAR IMPORTANT READ MORE
QUICKLY AND DIRECTLY INTO.
LIKE.
THREE OTHER KINDS OF THINGS DO
YOU HAVE ANY GERMANY MODELS THAT
YOU WOULD SUGGEST.
OR IN THAT AREA ABSOLUTELY --
THE LEAD MARKS THE LEAD PROGRAM
OUT OF SEATTLE.
IS PROBABLY PROBABLY THE DEFENSE
OF YOUR TALK ABOUT.
JAN I'M ACTUALLY FLEX PEOPLE OUT
OF THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
SO YOU NEVER EVEN HAD IT --
LEAD IN SEATTLE AND THERE'S A
SKIER ROSE PROGRAM YES THERE'S A
SPEAR PROGRAM IN.
YES YOUR PROGRAM IN MARYLAND
WHAT DATE DID PROGRAM IS IN THAT
PRIMARILY TOWARDS HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS OR NO.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THE
SEATTLE'S PROGRAM IS PRIMARILY
ORIENTED THAT NOW IT'S IT'S LOW
LEVELS LIKE SUBSTANCE ABUSE
OFFENSE WELL THEY THEY DON'T
THEY DON'T RESTRICTED TO JUST
THAT -- IF
THE OFFICER COMES ACROSS SOME
SOMEBODY THEY HAVE THE ABILITY
TO INSTEAD OF SIDING ARRESTING
THEM --
CONNECT WITH A COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION TURNING OVER THE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATION AND
THEN AT THE CBO IF GO IF THEY GO
THROUGH THE INTAKE WITH THE C.
B. L..
D. A DOZEN FILED A DOZEN FILED A
CHARGE ON DOES YOUR PROGRAM IN
MARYLAND IT IS THE SAME R. D. A.
IN OUR COUNTY IS STARTING TO PUT
THAT TOGETHER I'M A PILOT
PROJECT IN THERE WERE THE
OFFICERS SO THE REALLY FREQUENT
FLYERS WE JUST.
STEP TAKEN TO JAIL WE JUST TAKE
THE MARK JUST ELIVERED RIGHT TO
THIS RIGHT TO THE SERVICE GIVE
THEM A CHANCE TO STAY OUT OF THE
SYSTEM.
SO THOSE ARE THE TWO PROGRAMS
THAT I THAT I AM AWARE OF IN NOW
AND THEY'RE BOTH --
RESEARCH NATTEN NATIONALLY ON
AFTER A TEN RIGHT NOW AND I
THINK WOULD BE.
RIGHT WE COMPLETE GOT I WENT TO
SEATTLE WITH R. D. A. AND WE
COMPLETELY OR THE CONCEPT OF
BEING ABLE TO STIR CASES OUT OF
COURT.
I TRIED LIKE --
YOU TO ASSIST THE COMMITTEE AND
HELP US A RISK EXPLORER.
ANY ON ALL OPTIONS --
THAT WE CAN CONSIDER IN THAT
REGARD BECAUSE IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT -- OF
THOSE KINDS OPTIONS RENEWED IN
CALIFORNIA I HAVE A BIG EMPTY
HOLE WE NEED.
TO THE SET UP OF IN ADDITION TO
THE BARBER QUARTERS WHEN I'M NOT
LOOKING TO REPLACE.
BUT WHAT WE OF THE MORE --
IN ADDITION TO THE CLEVER COURTS
AND CALIFORNIA --
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE THAT I
THINK IT LEADS TO WAR
INCARCERATION --
IN AS A WAY WE CAN --
A SPECIALLY --
IS THEIR PROGRAMS FOR YOUNG
PEOPLE OR USE JUVENILES IN THIS
AREA YES SOME OF SOME OF THE
COURTS DID DID YOU'VE SEEN ARE
ON THE LIST ARE OUR JUVENILE
COURTS.
I'M EVEN GOLD EVEN GO ALL THE
WAY DOWN TO TURN TO COURT IS THE
INNER EARLIER YOU ANYTHING
BETTER I GETA TRUE.
ART WHEN I WAS A JUVENILE COURT
JUDGE THE REALLY WENT OUT TO A
SCHOOL WE HAVE THE LITTLE COURT
SESSION IN THE SCHOOL WITH.
THE VIGIL TRUANT SAY THEY HAD TO
COME BACK AND CHECK IN WITH THE
JUDGE -- IN
THIS VERY EFFECTIVE WE HAVE
TRUANCY COURTS IN THE STATE
THAT'S A NATIONAL PROCESS --
WE DO HAVE SOME CLOUDS.
THEY'RE ON THEIR ON THE LIST FOR
FOR JUVENILES BOTH ON THE MENTAL
SIDE AND ON SUBSTANCE YOU'RE
LOOKING --
FOR SURE THESE PRE ARREST TYPE
OF ADMINISTRATIVE THINGS --
FOR FOR FOR THE FRUIT I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU COULD SAY PRE ARREST
BUT PRE COURT FILING --
THERE IS THIS ENTIRE STRUCTURE
ON THE JUVENILE SIDE WERE
PROBATION DEPARTMENTS HAVE THE
ABILITY TO TO TAKE THE LOWER
LEVEL CASES AND DEAL WITH THEM
ON THEIR OWN WITHOUT EVEN WERE.
BURNING IT TO THE COURT --
SO THERE'S THIS WHOLE ARM.
ARM OF PROBATION AND IN THE JUNE
THAT I WAS HAPPY TOTALLY UNAWARE
OF UNTIL I WENT THERE OUT OUT AS
A JUDGE OH BABY SHOULD ACTUALLY
KEEPS MOST CASES OUT OF THE
SYSTEM.
LAST YEAR WE PASSED A LAW THAT
EXTENDED THE AGE FOR THE PEOPLE
AND CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL
INSTITUTION. TO AGE TWENTY FIVE
FOR THE JUVENILE CORRECTION
FACILITIES.
AND THERE ARE --
PEOPLE THAT WOULD LIKE TO EXTEND
THE AGE FOR COUNTY CORRECTIONAL
FACILITIES THE FIVE ALSO.
OF DO YOU HAVE AN OPINION ABOUT
THAT.
NOT WE HAVE BEEN OUT OF THE
JUVENILE UP WORLD FOR AWHILE FOR
A WHILE SO I'M I WOULD PROBABLY
WANT TO SIT DOWNS KIND GET A
GAUGE WHERE THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEM IS NOW --
BEFORE ANSWERED THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU --
SENATOR BELL PRECIADO THE
RAISING OF THE PRE ARREST A
DIVERSION WHICH OF COURSE AS THE
JUDGE DESCRIBED [inaudible]
DOESN'T NECESSARILY INVOLVE OUR
COURTS I SUPPOSE IT COULD BUT IN
THE MODELS THAT WERE REFERENCED
THERE MOSTLY A LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND DA TYPE OF
RELATIONSHIP.
I'M RETURNING FOR A MOMENT BACK
TO OUR DISCUSSION ON
COLLABORATIVE COURTS.
I APPRECIATE THAT THE JUDICIAL
BRANCH AS A SEPARATE BRANCH OF
GOVERNMENT AND THAT IN FACT THE
COLLABORATIVE COURTS WERE BEGUN
BY -- ONE OF
OUR CHIEF JUSTICE I BELIEVE WAS
RUN BUT IN SUBSEQUENT YEARS.
THE LEGISLATURE HAS NOT ONLY
THROUGH FINDING.
BUT THROUGH VARIOUS --
BILLS PASSED.
OF COMMUNICATED A PRETTY HIGH
LEVEL OF INTEREST AND PRIORITY
ME THAT WELL DIRECTION.
TOWARDS THE BENEFIT IN NEED FOR
THESE.
AND SO I AM PART OF MY INTEREST
IN HAVING THIS OVERSIGHT HEARING
WAS.
TO REALLY GET INTO SOME
DISCUSSION ABOUT THEIR
EFFECTIVENESS AND SUCH.
AND ALSO WHETHER THIS IS LEFT
JUST.
TO THE THE INDIVIDUAL COURTS
ABILITY TO GO GET GRANTS EVEN IF
WE ARE JUDICIAL COUNCILS FINDING
THEM AND HOW MUCH IT IS A
PRIORITY OF THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL.
SO I THINK YOU'RE GONNA HAVE CS
ACTION.
ON BUT I THINK THAT WELL IT'S
FAIR TO SAY EACH.
A JURISDICTION EACH CHORD IS
UNIQUE.
THE STATE DOES STILL HAVE AN
OVERRIDING OBJECTIVE AND STILL
APPROACH CAN APPROPRIATELY
DIRECT THAT SUCH THINGS HAPPEN
STATEWIDE.
SO -- WE WE
WILL OBVIOUSLY CONTINUE THIS
DISCUSSION.
BUT THANK YOU THANK YOU THANKS
SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE.
ALRIGHT WE'LL GO TO OUR ON ONE
SECOND A PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS
ITEM.
AND SINCE WE WILL BE REVISITING
THIS ISSUE AT THAT POINT ALL
OBVIOUSLY ES LA OVER
[inaudible]
YEAH.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF NAS YOUR HERNANDEZ ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS ARE
COLONEL JUSTICE.
STATEWIDE ASSOCIATION FROM
DEFENSE ATTORNEYS IN PRIVATE
PRACTICE AND WORK IN PUBLIC
DEFENDER OFFICES WE DO SUPPORT --
THE CONCEPT OF A COLLABORATIVE
COURTS WOULD YOU SUPPORT --
THE TONE OF THE DISCUSSION TO
MAKE IT MORE OF A PRIORITY
STATEWIDE --
WITH --
GREATER FUNDING AND MORE
DEDICATED FUNNY ESPECIALLY FROM
THE STATE --
AS OPPOSED TO RELYING ON FEDERAL
GRANTS SO WHAT CAN BE DONE IN
THIS COLLABORATIVE COURTS.
I WOULD OUR TERMS OF SEEN ON THE
GROUND IS SIX EXTREME
EFFECTIVENESS OF COLLABORATIVE
COURSE SPECIALLY IF THEY'RE DONE
A CERTAIN WAY --
I DO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE
OF THINGS ONE IS ESPECIALLY FOR
D. Y. COURTS --
WE HAVE FOUND SOME RESISTANCE IN
A NUMBER OF COUNTIES AND
IMPLEMENTING --
DO I COLLABORATIVE COURTS I'M
ALSO EVEN A LITTLE WHILE I THINK
YOU MIGHT REMEMBER THAT WE HAD
PROBLEMS WITH SOME.
VETERANS COURTS NOT WANTING TO
TAKE UP TO YOU I CASES --
BUT NOW IT SEEMS TO BE A LITTLE
BIT MORE WIDESPREAD LOVE IT MORE
OPEN SO THOSE ARE THINGS THAT
DEFINITELY NEED TO BE EXPANDED.
I'M A KEEP IN MIND THERE IS A
NETWORK OF SERVICES THEY NEED TO
BE AVAILABLE TO MAKE SURE THESE
COLLABORATIVE COURTS ARE
EFFECTIVE THE SAME WAY DRUG.
DIVERSION PROGRAMS --
RAN INTO PROBLEMS WHEN THERE WAS
ENOUGH FUNDING FOR FOR THOSE
PROGRAMS.
THE SAME CAN BE SAID OF DO YOU
WHY -- AND
ALSO KEEP IN MIND THAT IN
CALIFORNIA STATISTICS.
ARE JUST JUST AROUND 50% OF ALL
D. Y..
ARRESTS IN CALIFORNIA OR LATINO
DRIVERS AND THAT HAS BEEN
CONSISTENT FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS.
SO WE'RE TALKING ABOUT YOU I
COLLABORATIVE COURTS AND WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE SERVICES THAT
ARE AVAILABLE WE HAVE TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY'RE AVAILABLE IN
THOSE COUNTIES --
WITH HIGH POPULATION LATINO
COMMUNITY AND ALSO THERE AT THE
CULTURALLY SENSITIVE RELEVANT
AND ACCESSIBLE ON SO LOOK
FORWARD TO BEING PART OF THAT
DISCUSSION IN TRYING TO
STRENGTHEN ALL COLLABORATIVE
COURTS BUT IN PARTICULAR THAT
YOU LIKE WORDS.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT.
ALL RIGHT WILL MOVE TO OUR NEXT
ITEM WHICH IS OVERSIGHT OF THE
TRIAL COURT'S FINDING.
AND WE HAVE --
MR THEATER ROBIC OF COURSE AND
JOHN WORD LAW FROM THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL AS A CHIEF
ADMINISTRATIVE OFFICER AND WE I
BELIEVE ALSO MICHAEL RODDY.
THANK YOU WHO IS THE COURT
EXECUTIVE OFFICER FOR THE
SUPERIOR COURT OF SAN DIEGO
[inaudible]
I'M -- WHICH
OF YOURS GOING TO BE GOOD THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME
IS JOHN WERE LOW ON THE CHIEF
ADMINISTRATIVE OFFICER.
FOR THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL WELL AS
YOU SAID A CENTER --
I'M JOINED BY MICHAEL RODDY WHO
IS THE CORE EXECUTIVE FOR SAN
DIEGO AS WELL AS OUR REPRESENTS
THE STATEWIDE COURT EXECUTIVES
ON A COMMITTEE AND SO I I THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO TALK
TO YOU ABOUT --
THE FUNDING WE RECEIVED IN THE
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT BUDGET ACT WE
ARE TRULY GRATEFUL --
TO THE LEGISLATURE AND TO THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH --
FOUR THIS THESE FUNDS THEY
CERTAINLY ARE --
IMPROVE OUR ABILITY.
TO PROVIDE ACCESS TO JUSTICE TO
ALL CALIFORNIANS ON WE ASK THE
COURT INITIALLY --
FOR A ROAD MAP IF YOU HOW THEY
WOULD SPEND THE DOLLARS SHOULD.
WE GET THE MONEY WE THEY ARE
CALLED BUDGET SNAPSHOTS WE
PROVIDE A BINDER FOR YOU --
OF ALL FIFTY EIGHT COURT
SNAPSHOTS THEY ARE A BY A COURT --
IDENTIFICATION OF THE THINGS
THAT THEY WOULD BE DOING.
MADAM CHAIR YOUR AGENDA DOES A
VERY NICE JOB IN LAYING OUT.
THE VARIOUS BUCKETS OF THOSE
FUNDS AND WOULD WE CAN THANK OUR
BUDGET SUB STAFF MISTER FRANCIS
ABSOLUTELY --
AND AND ALL HOLD AND SEE IF
THERE ARE SPECIFIC QUESTIONS
THAT YOU HAVE CONCERNING THESE
FUNDS AND THEN ASK YOUR
PERMISSION. TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT SOME
ADDITIONAL NEEDS.
THOSE DISCUSSIONS VERY GOOD.
MR.
YOU'RE NOT OKAY SO WE WILL GO
NEXT THEN TO OUR OUR CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER FROM SAN DIEGO
COURT.
MISTER RIGHT.
I REALLY DO MADAM CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS I I DON'T HAVE TOO MUCH
TO ADD.
I'M REALLY MORE ANTICIPATING THE
QUESTIONS AND GETTING INTO THE
FIX BUT I CAN ASSURE YOU THAT --
THE TRIAL COURT'S.
REALLY DID APPRECIATE.
THE ADDITIONAL FUNDS THAT WERE
ADDED INTO THIS CURRENT FISCAL
YEAR --
ESPECIALLY GIVEN THAT THE YEAR
BEFORE THERE WAS VIRTUALLY NO
MONEY PROVIDED AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL FOR OPERATIONS SO --
YOUR WORDS WITH THIS MONEY
EXPECTING THT WE WILL BE
REPORTING BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE.
ON THE OUTCOMES --
THAT WERE ACHIEVED BY DECEMBER
OF SEVENTY FIVE MILLION --
AT A VERY BROAD LEVEL I TELL YOU
THAT --
FORTY THREE OF OUR PORCH I HAVE
USED THE FUNDS --
THIRTY OF OUR COURTS HAVE USED
THE MONEY FOR SALARY AND
COMPENSATION INCREASES --
THAT ARE OVERDUE.
A TWENTY THREE OF OUR COURTS
HAVE.
THE MONEY IN THE RECORDS
MANAGEMENT AND KATE.
BUT SOME UPGRADES. TWENTY TWO
COURTS HAVE EXTENDED SERVICE
HOURS AND PUBLIC ACCESS.
AND TWENTY ONE COURTS HAVE --
UNDER THE MISCELLANEOUS
TECHNOLOGICAL IMPROVEMENT AREA
THAT IS REPLACING EQUIPMENT.
AGED INFRASTRUCTURE --
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS IN ORDER
TO ENSURE THAT --
WE CAN ADEQUATELY PROVIDE
SERVICE TO THE PUBLIC SO --
AS EACH COURT IS IN A DIFFERENT
PLACE --
COMING OUT OF THE RECESSION
COMING OUT OF PRIOR REDUCTIONS.
ON THIS DISCRETIONARY MONEY IS
GIVING THEM THE ABILITY TO
RESTORE SERVICES THAT ARE
IMPORTANT IN THE COMMUNITY I CAN.
GET VERY SPECIFIC AS TO SAN
DIEGO BUT BUT I THINK THE BROAD
PICTURE IS WHAT'S MOST IMPORTANT
HERE SO.
AGAIN I'M VERY INTERESTED THE
QUESTION.
WOULD BE HAPPY TO RESPOND TO
THOSE AS WE GO THROUGH.
I'M SO BUT MAYBE --
FOR WELL THIS IS A QUESTION
BEFORE WE GET INTO THE OTHER
DETAIL QUESTIONS.
I'M.
MR WORD LIKE COULD YOU.
THIS IS AN OVERSIGHT AND SO WE
DON'T NECESSARILY HAVE ALL THE
BCP'S BEFORE US BUT COULD YOU
GIVE US A HEADS UP ON SOME OF
THE REQUESTS THAT --
DID YOU JUST --
COUNCIL BE MAKING FOR THE TRIAL
COURTS FOR US TO CONSIDER THIS
COMING YEAR ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I'M SO WE HAVE A
SERIES OF PROPOSALS.
THE FIRST OF WHICH IS FOR A CASE
MANAGEMENT SYSTEMS AS YOU KNOW
WE HAVE HAD A MULTI YEAR
DEPLOYMENT OF OUR CASE
MANAGEMENT SYSTEMS.
THE PURPOSE BEHIND THE CASE
MANAGEMENT SYSTEMS IS.
TO ENABLE FOR DATA COLLECTION AT
A STATE WIDE MACRO LEVEL AND
WITH THE THIS FINAL PUSH FOR TEN
ADDITIONAL CASE MANAGEMENT
SYSTEMS WE BELIEVE THAT THAT
WILL ENABLE ON THE BRANCH AS A
WHOLE. TO START REALIZING THE
VISION ADA A DATA ANALYTICS AND
SO CASE MANAGE VERY IMPORTANT TO
US.
THAT REQUEST IS FOR TWENTY THREE
MILLION.
UP WE'RE REQUESTING --
FOR ARE.
OUR OUR PHOENIX SYSTEM THAT'S A
AN INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY SYSTEM
USED BY THE TRIAL COURT --
FOR PERIL PURPOSES --
THAT SYSTEM IS COMING TO AN END
OF LIFE AND SO WE ARE ASKING --
FOR THE FUNDS TO BEGIN --
THE TRANSIENT TRANSITIONING AND
UPGRADING OF THAT SYSTEM TO
MAINTAIN THAT VITAL FUNCTION FOR
US.
WE'RE ASKING --
FOR RESOURCE IS RELATIVE TO
FACILITIES AND OPERATIONS OUGHT
TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THIS FACILITY
MODIFICATIONS NECESSARY IN THE
VARIOUS COURT HOUSES THAT WE ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR MAINTAINING THAT
REQUEST IS TWENTY POINT ONE
MILLION.
AS WELL AS A VARIETY OF SECURITY
SYSTEMS THROUGHOUT THE COURT OF
THAT NEED TO BE UPGRADED THAT
REQUEST IS FOUR SIX MILLION.
WERE ASKING FOR RESOURCES FOR
THE PURPOSES OF DIGITIZING
DOCUMENTS WE HAVE LITERALLY
WAREHOUSES OF COURT DOCUMENTS
AND RECORDS THAT --
WE WE IN IN THE DENTURE LAYS AGE
WE FEEL IS IMPORTANT TO TO HAVE
AN ELECTRONIC MEANS THAT WE CAN
SHARE INFORMATION --
BETWEEN COURTS.
WE'RE ASKING FOR RESOURCES
RELATIVE TO THE LITIGATION
MANAGEMENT PROGRAM TO THE TUNE
OF FIVE POINT SIX MILLION.
WE'RE REQUESTING RESOURCES
RELATIVE TO A DATA ANALYTICS --
THE DESIRE IS ONCE WE HAVE THE
CASE MANAGEMENT SYSTEMS ARE IN
PLACE THERE IS A NEED NOW TO
START TO BUILD THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THE DATA --
EXPERTISE WITHIN THAT THAT THE
BRANCH TO ACTUALLY EXTRACT THE
INFORMATION FOR POLICY MAKERS.
WITH RESPECT TO THE CANNABIS
CONVICTIONS WERE REQUESTING
THIRTEEN POINT NINE MILLION ARM
AS THE THE CHANGES IN LOG --
RELATIVE TO CANNABIS WE'RE
SEEING A HUGE A LARGE LARGE
WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH THAT
AND SO THE FUNDS TO SUPPORT OF
THAT WORK LOAD WHEN YOU SAY THAT
YOU MEAN FOR EXPUNGEMENT AROUND
THE CANNABIS CONVICTIONS CORRECT
SENATOR.
YES MA'AM MILLER FOR KAY AND NOW
HAS EXPUNGEMENT STATEWIDE OR
SPECIFIC COURTS --
IT THAT WOULD BE STATEWIDE
MANAGER.
YEAH GO AHEAD AND SO ON OUR OUR
OUR PRIMARY --
REQUESTS --
WE ALSO HAVE.
IT'S NOT REPRESENTED IN A BUDGET
CHANGE PROPOSAL BUT WE WOULD
ADVOCATE FOR ADDITIONAL
JUDGESHIPS.
STATEWIDE OUT MADAM CHAIR ON
DURING OUR HEIGHTS OF CLAIMS.
WE WERE IN NEED OF APPROXIMATELY
THREE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY JUDGES
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND TEN THAT
REPRESENTED A CASELOAD OF ABOUT.
ARMED. TO THE LEGISLATURE WE
WERE AUTHORIZED AND FUNDED FOR
FIFTY JUDGESHIPS IN.
TWO THOUSAND SIX IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN THE LEGISLATURE AUTHORIZED
AN ADDITIONAL FIFTY BUT DID NOT
FIND THOSE JUDGESHIPS.
AS YOU'LL RECALL --
IN THE BUDGET ACT OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THERE WAS AN
ADDITIONAL TWO JUDGES --
SO LEAVING FORTY EIGHT
JUDGESHIPS ON FUNDED AT THIS
POINT.
OUR LATEST PROJECTIONS BACK IN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN ALL FOR AN
OVERALL NEED OF A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY SEVEN JUDGESHIPS.
AT THESE ARE JUDGES.
JUDGESHIPS IN COURTS THAT HAVE
FILINGS THAT ARE ABOVE THE
CAPACITY OF THAT PARTICULAR
COURT'S ABILITY TO THE PROCESS
TIMELY --
REPRESENTING ABOUT FOUR IN
FILINGS ARE PRUDENT REQUEST THIS
POINT A MAN I'M SURE WOULD BE --
FOR TWENTY FIVE JUDGESHIPS.
AT A COST OF APPROXIMATELY THREE
SIX POINT FIVE MILLION.
THANK YOU SO [inaudible]
ON THE JUDGESHIP QUESTION.
YOU MENTIONED THAT IN. TWO
THOUSAND AND TWO THOUSAND AND
SIX I'M. FIFTY WERE AUTHORIZED
AND FUNDED.
OF THE FIFTY IN TWO THOUSAND SIX
WERE THEY ALL WOULD.
WERE FIFTEEN YOUR JUDGES
INSTALLED.
YES THE THE FIFTY JUDGES WERE
INSTALLED STATEWIDE MA'AM THERE
THEN IN TWO THOUSAND AND SEVEN
YOU DESCRIBED THAT THE
LEGISLATURE AUTHORIZED ANOTHER
FIFTY BUT DIDN'T FIND THEM.
CORRECT MADAM CHAIR OKAY SO.
SINCE THEN.
WERE ANY ANY OF THOSE FIFTY
FUNDED.
WE LIVE IN THE CURRENT YEAR'S
BUDGET TO A JUDGESHIP FOR
RIVERSIDE WERE FUNDED RIGHT SO
TOO WERE FUNDED OUT OF THAT --
NEED.
THAT WAS IT THE BY THE
LEGISLATURE OF A FIFTH OF FIFTY
BACK THEN AND OBVIOUSLY OUR
POPULATION GONE UP SUBSEQUENTLY
[inaudible]
I'M.
A. N. AND NOW.
THERE'S DISCUSSION BY JUDICIAL
COUNCIL FOR A REQUEST FOR AN ID.
FOR I WON'T CALL IT AN
ADDITIONAL TWENTY FIVE BUT
RATHER TO FIND. TWENTY FIVE
THAT'S CORRECT MADAM CHAIR YES
[inaudible]
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT NOW I HAVE A LOT OF
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE MONEY WE
GAVE YOU LAST YEAR AND FOR THE
COURT REPORTERS BUT BEFORE I GO
INTO ALL OF THOSE MAYBE ALLOW MY
COLLEAGUES TO SEE IF THEY HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS.
WERE ALSO OKAY IT'S BETTER MORE
LACK.
SURE GO AHEAD [inaudible]
I'M.
IT'S JUST BEEN MY OBSERVATION OF
THE PRIOR.
THE ADMINISTRATION WAS NOT VERY.
HELPFUL TO THE COURTS AND SO I'M
WONDERING.
WHAT YOU KIND OF?
SEE AS A CHANGE OF CLIMATE I
DON'T KNOW HOW TO ASK THE
QUESTION DELICATELY BUT JUST.
HOW ARE YOU IMPROVING
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THIS
ADMINISTRATION TO HELP MEET YOUR
BUDGET?
NEEDS.
THANK YOU CENTER AND AND MADAM
CHAIR OUT WITH RESPECT TO THAT
QUESTION.
YOU KNOW WE ARE AS I OPENED WITH
GRATEFUL TO THE PRIOR
ADMINISTRATION FOR CONSIDERATION
OF THE DISCRETIONARY FUNDING
THAT IS REALLY MAKING A
DIFFERENCE FOR OUR OUR
POPULATIONS ACCESS TO JUSTICE.
WE ARE ALSO ENJOYING A GOOD
CONVERSATION WITH THIS
ADMINISTRATION AS IT'S COMING IN
WE'RE VERY HOPEFUL THAT --
WITH RESPECT TO THE JUDICIAL
NEEDS THAT WE WILL BE IN A
POSITION OF OF HAVING MORE
CONVERSATIONS WITH YOU.
THROUGH --
THE GOVERNOR'S CONSIDERATION OF
OUR NEEDS.
THOSE ADDITIONAL FUNDS JUST CAME
LAST YEAR.
THAT WOULD BE CORRECT YOU YOU
HAVE IN A SENSE WHITTLE DOWN ALL
YOUR RESERVES. TO ZERO RIGHT YES
AND AND AND THERE THERE IS ONE
OTHER.
PIECE OF THE PUZZLE.
WE ARE RESTRICTED TO BEING 1% OF
OF CORE EXPENDITURES --
YEAR OVER YEAR --
DATA A PIECE OF STATUTE THAT WE
RESPECTFULLY WOULD ASK FOR A
CONVERSATION WITH YOU ABOUT
POTENTIALLY.
REMOVING THAT CAP TO ALLOW FOR
OUR COURTS TO PLAN FOR MULTI
YOUR SPENDING IT'S IT'S ACTUALLY
CRIPPLING TO THE COURTS NOT TO
BE ABLE TO PLAN.
ON A MULTI YEAR BASIS --
AND SO WE DO ASK THAT THAT WITH
RESPECT.
WELL THAT WOULD BE GREAT I'D
LIKE TO REMOVE THE APPS ON
SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
CLOSE TO WE CAN DO.
I'D BE SUPPORTIVE OF THAT THANK
YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
I'M SO BEFORE I GOING.
TO COURT REPORTERS AND OUR
ALLOCATION OF FUNDING TO LAST
YEAR WHEN WE DISTILL JUDGES FOR
A LITTLE BIT LONGER --
SO CLEARLY THE LEGISLATURE BACK
IN TWO THOUSAND AND SEVEN FELT
THAT FIFTY ADDITIONAL JUDGES
WERE NEEDED.
BUT DIDN'T FIND THEM AND
PROBABLY WE COULD SAY MAYBE THAT
WAS WHY IS.
BECAUSE GIVEN THAT THE RECESSION
WAS RIGHT AROUND THE CORNER
THEY'RE VERY WHAT A CUT THEM.
BUT AND IT'S PROBABLY WHY.
MORE HAVE NOT BEEN FUNDED SENSE
BECAUSE UP UNTIL YOU KNOW UNTIL.
TWENTY FOURTEEN A NEW
ALLOCATIONS TO MOST DEPARTMENTS
WERE REALLY BEING MADE.
I'M.
BUT THAT SAID THINGS HAVE
CHANGED A GREAT DEAL SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVEN OF THE FUNDS
ONE LET IN THE COURTS SOME MORE
RESPONSIBILITIES IN TERMS OF RE
SENTENCING IN VARIOUS THINGS ON
THE OTHER HAND WE'VE CHANGED.
A VARIETY OF LAWS WHERE PERHAPS
THERE ARE.
MORE OR LESS OF SET OF THINGS
THAT USED TO COME BEFORE THE
COURTS THAT AREN'T COMING BEFORE
THE COURTS.
SO I THINK CLEARLY AS REEVALUATE
WHAT IS THE APPROPRIATE NUMBER.
OF AND I'M NOT.
I'M NOT GOING TO EVEN TRY.
TO SPECULATE THAT WE COULD LAND
EXACTLY ON WHAT WE THINK IS THE
RIGHT NUMBER BUT AS WE TRY TO
EVALUATE.
WHAT IS?
THE APPROPRIATE NUMBER FOR US TO
AT THIS TIME FIND.
I'M.
IT MAY BE WORTH FACTORING IN
SOME OF THOSE THINGS NOW IT'S A
SHORT PERIOD OF TIME BETWEEN NOW
AND WHEN WE ADOPT THE BUDGET TO
REALLY UNDERSTAND.
THE VARIETY OF CHANGES SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVEN AND NOW BUT
I'M HOPING THAT THE LA --
RATHER THAN IN ASKING YOU.
TO DO.
FIND UPON THAT NOW.
THAT YOU MIGHT OBVIOUSLY WE'RE
GOING TO BE THE P. C. PEAS IN
THIS AREA.
SOMETIME IN THE FUTURE.
THAT WE MIGHT HAVE A BETTER
SENSE OF OF ON KNOW WHETHER AN
YOU KNOW WHAT KIND OF CHANGES
AND WHAT KIND OF NEW DEMANDS ARE
ON THE COURTS THAT MIGHT.
JUSTIFY EVEN ADDITIONAL JUDGES
THAN WHAT'S BEING PROPOSED HERE.
AND AGAIN NOT ASSERTING THAT WE
WOULDNECESSARILY HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO FUND THE ADDITIONAL
BUT OR OR WHETHER THERE'S A
SENSE THAT ADDITIONAL ARE NOT
NEEDED.
JUST SO WE CAN KIND OF GRAPPLE
WITH I MEAN ANY TIME WE ARE
GIVEN.
A PROPOSAL FOR YOU KNOW FIND EX
NUMBER WHY NUMBER.
IT'S GOOD FOR US TO TRY TO
UNDERSTAND YOU KNOW HOW WE
LANDED ON THOSE NUMBERS.
SO -- IF LA --
CAN NOW THINK ABOUT THAT IN TO
SPEAK THAT AS WE GO INTO THAT
DISCUSSION THE FUTURE
[inaudible]
I'M NOW [inaudible]
LAST YEAR.
WE PROVIDE IT.
THE OUR JUDICIAL COUNCIL TEN
MILLION.
EXPLICITLY FOR COURT REPORTERS.
AND MY UNDERSTANDING.
IS THAT --
LESS THAN TEN MILLION OF THAT
WENT. TO COURT REPORTERS.
AND I WANT TO GET A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF WHY.
WHY THE FULL TEN MILLION WAS NOT
DISTRIBUTED FOR IT WASN'T?
AND WHETHER IT WAS USED WHATEVER
WAS DISTRIBUTED WEATHER WAS USED
FOR COURT REPORTERS AS WAS OUR
INTENTION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR --
WITH RESPECT TO THE COURT
REPORTERS I CAN TELL YOU THAT
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL AND IT'S
DELIBERATION AND AND ARM
ALLOCATION OF THOSE THAT TEN
MILLION DOLLARS.
THAT WAS SPECIFICALLY EXPLICITLY
FOR THE PURPOSE OF COURT
REPORTERS.
THAT SAID TO THE EXTENT THAT
THAT COURT REPORTERS ARE NOT
AVAILABLE.
WITHIN A LOCALE THEN HAD THE
DISCRETION TO USE THOSE FUNDS
AND AND DIFFERENT WAYS --
TO TO ENSURE ACCESS TO JUSTICE
AGAIN I'LL STATE THAT THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL EXPLICITLY.
DIRECTED THAT THE MONEY IS FOR
THE PURPOSE OF OF COURT
REPORTERS.
ALL TEN MILLION OF THAT.
I WOULD LIKE.
OUR REQUEST PERMISSION.
FOR MICHAEL RODDY TO SHARE SOME
EXPERIENCES THAT HE AND SOME OF
THE OTHER COURTS ARE.
WITH RESPECT TO RECRUITMENT OF
THEIR COURT REPORTERS.
GO HEAD TO HEAD THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR -- I
CAN GIVE YOU OF MY COUNTY
SPECIFIC EXPERIENCE --
WE NEEDED TO HIRE WE NEED TO
HIRE TWENTY FIVE COURT REPORTERS.
TO FULLY STAFF ALL OF OUR FAMILY
ALL OPERATIONS AND TO FILL SOME
PRE EXISTING VACANCIES.
FROM RETIREMENTS OCCURRED IN
MARCH OF LAST OF MARCH OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WE HAVE HIRED NINETEEN
REPORTERS.
SO WE ARE WELL ON THE WAY.
HOWEVER WE'VE EXHAUSTED THE
HIRING LIST WE HAVE THREE NAMES
REMAINING THOSE JUST HAVE JUST
COME IN --
WE HAVE A SUBSEQUENTLY LOST
TWELVE REPORTERS DUE TO
RETIREMENTS AND RESIGNATION.
SO AFTER HIRING NINETEEN
REPORTERS I'M STILL EIGHTEEN
REPORTER SHORT.
WHAT I NEED TO BE?
TELL I CAN REPORT TO YOU THAT
WE'VE SPENT THE MONEY FOR THE
PURPOSE INTENDED BUT AT THE END
OF THE DAY.
OUR TOTAL COURT REPORTER
EXPENDITURES ARE BASICALLY GOING
TO BE A ZERO SUM GAME BECAUSE WE
HAVE LOST THROUGH ATTRITION ALL
OF THOSE POSITIONS.
WE ARE ENCOUNTERING A SERIOUS
SUPPLY DEMAND ISSUE --
SINCE JANUARY WE'VE HAD THREE
APPLICANTS --
ADD TO THOSE APPLICANTS MAY NOT
MAKE IT THROUGH THE FINAL AND
ONE IS FROM NEW JERSEY
[inaudible]
SO -- AS
FORECAST BY THE NATIONAL PARK
REPORTERS ASSOCIATION IN --
TWENTY THIRTEEN TWENTY FOURTEEN
WE ARE SEEING AT LEAST IN OUR
COUNTY AND AS I TALK WITH OTHER
COUNTIES THEY ARE ALSO HAVING
LOS ANGELES COUNTY'S HAVING
ISSUES.
WHICH COUNTIES LOSING REPORTERS.
CAMERA DINOS HAD RECRUITMENT
PROBLEMS ALL HAVE AN
UNDERSTANDING OF WHY YET.
FIND A MAN.
AN ARC IN OUR OPINION WE WERE
GETTING.
MEAN.
IT IS THAT WE HAVE A LOT OF
PEOPLE LEAVING THE WORK FORCE OR
AGING OUT --
WE HAVE FOLKS ARE GOING IN THE
PRIVATE SECTOR WHERE THEY CAN
MAKE FAR MORE MONEY --
THE DEMAND FOR LEGAL SERVICES
CONTINUES TO RISE ON THE PRIVATE
SIDE.
AND SO WE'RE JUST NOT GETTING
THE APPLICANTS --
THAT WE NEED TO REPLENISH THE
FOLKS THAT ARE LEAVING US.
I LOST A TWELVE REPORTERS LAST
YEAR TO RETIREMENT --
I WAS ABLE TO IMMEDIATELY GET
FOR FIVE OR SIX AND WE CONTINUE
TO HOLD THOSE BIG.
THIS MARCH I'M I THINK I'M
ALREADY UP TO ELEVEN OR TWELVE
REPORTER.
RETIRING.
RETIREMENT INCENTIVES AFTER.
EIGHT REACHING AGE SIXTY SIXTY
FIVE AND TWENTY YEARS OF SERVICE.
LEAVE THEM TO LEAVE THE COURT SO
WE'RE NOT SEEING APPLICANTS
COMING THROUGH --
FRANKLY IN REVIEWING --
INFORMATION.
GOT A COURT REPORTER BOARDS IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THERE WERE.
FORTY EIGHT FIRST TIME TEST
TAKERS.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA OVER
THE THREE EXAMS THAT WERE
ADMINISTERED. TWENTY EIGHT OF
THOSE.
IN MY COURT ALONE I'VE LOST
CLOSE TO TWENTY FIVE COURT
REPORTERS SO THEY'RE NOT BEING
REPLACED AS QUICKLY AS THEY WERE
LEAVING NOW LEAVING THE WORK
FORCE --
GIVEN THAT WE HAVE [inaudible]
WHAT?
ALL SHORTAGE.
I'M IS THERE.
HAS THERE BEEN A A LOOK AT ALL
ABOUT WHETHER ON WE SHOULD BE.
RE EXAMINE RE LOOKING AT WHAT
QUALIFICATIONS REAR REQUIRING OR
WHAT WE ARE EXPECTING UNDER THE
TEST.
DOES IT.
MEET OUR CURRENT NEEDS OR IS IT.
A IS IT OUTDATED.
I MEAN CLEARLY.
YOU KNOW WE COULD LOOK AT
SALARIES AND SUCH.
BUT I'M IT COULD BE IT MAY NOT
BE SALARIES ALONE THAT ARE THE
REASON THAT WE'RE NOT BEING ABLE
TO FILL THESE POSITIONS AND I
THINK GIVEN.
THAT OUR COURTS NEED COURT
REPORTERS TO FUNCTION ADEQUATELY
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT THAT
IS LOOKED AT I'M SURE I'M IN
FULL AGREEMENT ABOUT THE NEED TO
LOOK AT WHAT IS THE REASON IS
THAT THE COURT REPORTERS AT THE
CHALLENGES WERE FACING.
OFF ON IT AND WORKING WITH THE
COURT REPORTER BOARD.
YOU KNOW THAT ENTITY SEEMS LIKE
THE LIKELY PARTNER THAT WE WOULD
NEED TO HAVE THOSE CONVERSATIONS
WITH I'M IN FULL AGREEMENT WITH
YOU UNFORTUNATELY TODAY I'M NOT
IN A POSITION TO TELL YOU
SPECIFICALLY.
THE STATUS OF THOSE
CONVERSATIONS THAT YOU ARE
HAVING THEM.
I I I CANNOT SAY CONCLUSIVELY
THE WHEN AND HOW OFTEN WERE
HAVING THOSE CONVERSATIONS YEAH
I KNOW THAT IT IS A PIECE OF THE
DIALOGUE AMONGST THE CORE FAMILY
ABOUT THE CHALLENGES WERE FACING.
I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW FREQUENTLY
WE'VE MET WITH THE BOARD ON THIS
TOPIC THOUGH.
RIGHT AND I MIGHT ADD THAT.
FROM WHAT WE HAVE HEARD AND
RECENT REPORTS.
THERE ARE FEWER SCHOOLS.
THERE ARE FAR FEWER PEOPLE
COMING INTO THE PROFESSION.
AND STAYING WITH THE PROFESSION.
AND IT'S REACHED A POINT WHERE
THEY'RE NOT ATTRACTING NEW.
INTEREST AS QUICKLY AS PEOPLE
ARE AGING OUT OF THE SYSTEM.
AND AGAIN THIS WAS SOMETHING WAS
FORECAST BACK IN TWENTY THIRTEEN
TWENTY FOURTEEN AT THE NATIONAL
LEVEL ACROSS THE COUNTRY SO --
IT'S HAPPENING --
TODAY.
AND SO IF A HUNDRED PEOPLE EVEN
ONLY FORTY EIGHT PEOPLE STEP UP
TO TAKE THE TEST.
THAT DEFICITS GONNA CONTINUE TO
CLIMB OVER TIME THAT'S OUR
CONCERN.
BETTER MORE LUCK.
I COULD JUMP INTO THIS
DISCUSSION AND ASK YOUR STRANGE
QUESTION BUT THIS THIS SOUNDS
LIKE IT COULD BE REPLACED BY.
VIDEO TAPES AND ALL THE REST SO.
IS IT THAT WAY I WOULDN'T
INCENTIVIZE ME TO WANT TO GO
INTO A PROFESSION THAT COULD BE.
ELIMINATED IN IN ONE BROAD SWEEP
HOW DO YOU MOTIVATE PEOPLE TO
BECOME COURT REPORTERS AND WHY
DON'T WE TRANSITION OVER BUDGET
BECAUSE OF BOLD AS TO ASK --
WE CAN'T TRANSITION OVER BECAUSE
MY DECISION PERMITS US USE THEM
FOR ALL BUT LIMITED PURPOSES --
AND WHILE FORTY EIGHT FIVE
STATES INCLUDING SEVERAL
COMPLETE STATE SYSTEMS USE OTHER
TECHNOLOGICAL MEANS TO CAPTURE
THE RECORD.
WE ARE PROHIBITED HERE IN
CALIFORNIA FROM USING THEM ALL.
EXCEPT FOR MISDEMEANORS.
A SMALL CLAIMS.
TRAFFIC IN LIMITED CIVIL WHICH
IS A SUBSET OF THE COURT.
ALL JUVENILE FELONY FAMILY LAW
PROBATE.
REQUIRE AT THIS POINT OF THE
STENOGRAPHIC REPORTER.
SO JUST TO REPEAT WHAT YOU SAID
YOU SAID THERE FOR FORTY EIGHT
STATES THIRTY FIVE FORTY FIVE
STATES THAT DO NOT USE.
THAT.
USE --
TECHNOLOGICAL MEANS LIKE VIDEO
AND AUDIO OTHER THAN A COURT
REPORTER IN A DELUXE OR ANOTHER
THEN YES. FOR EXAMPLE THE STATE
OF UTAH.
TRANSITION COMPLETELY ELECTRONIC
REPORTING IN THE STATE OF ALASKA.
FOR DECADES HAS HAD THAT BECAUSE
OF THE INABILITY OR TRACK COURT
ORDERS.
OF THE STATE OF FLORIDA IS
LARGELY CONVERTED OVER TO THE
STATE OF KENTUCKY --
FOR SEVERAL DECADES NOW SO THERE
ARE EXAMPLES ACROSS THE COUNTRY
WHERE THE TRANSITIONS OCCURRING -
A COMPUTER CAN TRANSCRIBE.
ME IS RIGHT RIGHT WHERE YOU'RE
WATCHING IT ON ON THE SCREEN SO
I'M.
I'M WONDERING WHAT IS THAT
YOU'RE TRYING [inaudible]
TO PHIL.
EMPLOYEES POSITIONS WERE WHY ARE
WE LOOKING AT LEGISLATION TO
TRANSFER OVER ON A LIMITED BASIS
TO SEE HOW IT.
ACTUALLY WORKS I THINK WE WOULD
WELCOME THAT --
I KNOW THERE WAS A PILOT PROGRAM
IN THE NINETEEN NINETIES.
WITH A REPORT BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE --
THAT DIDN'T GO ANYWHERE --
AT FROM A POOR EXECUTIVE
STANDPOINT WE WOULD REALLY LOVE
TO REVISIT THAT ISSUE --
BUT IT'S GONNA REQUIRE BRINGING --
LOTS OF PARTIES TO THE TABLE AND
COMING UP WITH A WORKABLE
SOLUTION.
THANK YOU AND I AM JUST IF I MAY
ESTIMATES WERE OR WERE NOT
ADVOCATING THAT WE WOULD WANT TO
REPLACE THE COURT REPORTERS
NECESSARILY WE THINK THAT THAT'S
A DISCUSSION.
THAT.
TECHNOLOGY MAY BE VERY HELPFUL
WITH RESPECT TO THIS THIS
WORKLOAD ON BUT I DON'T I WANT
TO MAKE IT CLEAR ON BEHALF OF
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL WE ARE NOT
ADVOCATING ONE POLICY.
OVER THE OTHER AT THIS
PARTICULAR.
POINT OUR INTEREST IS IN LOOKING
AT ALL POSSIBLE OPTIONS TO
PRODUCE.
APPROPRIATE COURT RECORDS.
ARE INSTANCES WHERE A REPORTER
WITH -- THE
STENOGRAPHIC EQUIPMENT IS
PROBABLY THE THE BEST OPTION AND
THERE MAY BE OTHER TYPES
HEARINGS WHERE --
TECHNOLOGY MAY BE AN OPTION.
I WOULD ALSO POINT YOU TO THE
CHIEF A RECENT FUTURES
COMMISSION REPORT.
WHERE THERE WAS EXTENSIVE
CONVERSATION AND DISCUSSION AND
REVIEW OF OTHER TYPES OF?
MIGHT BE AVAILABLE TO HELP US
ADDRESS THE CURRENT SUPPLY AND
DEMAND ISSUE WITH RESPECT TO
STENOGRAPHIC REPORTERS.
THANK YOU MR ROBBIE I'M.
I'M NOT TRYING.
TO BE DIFFICULT BUT THESE ARE
THE KINDS OF QUESTIONS I WOULD
GET FROM MY CONSTITUENTS.
SO THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR EARLY.
ON THE FACT THAT WE MAY NOT BE
ABLE TO FILL POSITIONS WORKFORCE
QUESTIONS MAY NOT BE.
THEY MAY NOT --
NECESSARILY LEGITIMATELY JUMP TO
THAT WHICH YOU REPLACE IT WITH
THE TECHNOLOGY BUT RATHER WE
HAVE TO LOOK AT AND WHAT IS IT
THAT WE WHAT IS IT ROUND OUR
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE POSITION
THAT ARE SOMEHOW EXCLUDING US
FROM HAVING A WORK FORCE THAT IS.
AT IT ABLE TO FILL THESE
POSITIONS AND PERHAPS THEN THERE
CAN BE TECHNOLOGICAL ASSISTANCE
TO THAT.
BUT I THINK ANY OF US WHO HAVE
WATCHED FOR EXAMPLE THE CAL
CHANNEL.
WHEN THERE'S A WILL YOU KNOW
STILL WHEN WE VIDEO OUR OWN
PROCEEDINGS ME WATCH?
T. R..
THE COMPUTER TRANSCRIPTION OF
THAT YOU KNOW IF WE HAVE THE
SOUND ON WE KNOW THAT WHAT WE'RE
HEARING.
IS CAN BE VERY OFTEN DIFFERENT
THAN WHAT THOSE WORDS ARE ON THE
SCREEN AND SO CERTAINLY IF WE'RE
RELYING.
IN TERMS OF A COURT PROCEEDING.
FOR ACCURACY WE NEED THE YOU
KNOW WE PROBABLY.
WHATEVER THEIR NEEDS IT'S THE
THINK OF WE WANNA MAKE SURE
THERE'S ACCURACY.
AND SO THERE MAY BE.
TECHNOLOGIES THAT CAN ASSESS.
BUT THEY MAY NOT BE.
OPTIMAL FOR REPLACEMENT SO I I
THINK WE REALLY HAVE TO LOOK AT
WHAT THE OTHER ISSUES ARE.
THAT ARE AFFECTING OUR ABILITY
TO FILL THESE POSITIONS
[inaudible]
ON CENTRE BELL DO YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
I'M -- IN A
LEED EVER COMMENT BEFORE I GO TO
OKAY SO I'M GONNA GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENT BECAUSE I THINK WE HAVE
SOME ON THIS ITEM.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR NANCY
TRAVEL WITH CONSUMER ATTORNEYS
OF CALIFORNIA.
I PARTICULARLY WANT TO COMMENT
ON THE VERY CRITICAL NEED FOR
FINDING THE ADDITIONAL JUDGES.
AS AN ASSOCIATION THAT
REPRESENTS LAWYERS WHO PRACTICE
IN CIVIL CASES.
OVER THE LAST DECADE.
OUR LAWYERS HAVE EXPERIENCED THE
MOST SEVERE DELAYS BECAUSE KHAN
CONSTITUTIONALLY CRIMINAL CASES
TAKE A PRECEDENT CIVIL CASES
HAVE BEEN THIS POOR STEPCHILD IN
TERMS OF GETTING ACCESS TO
JUSTICE IN ACCESS TO COURT ROOMS.
SO WE THINK THAT IT'S LONG PAST
TIME TO FUND THE JUDGES THAT
WERE AUTHORIZED WAY BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVEN I IN OUR VIEW.
THE TWENTY FIVE THAT WERE JUST
REQUESTED BY THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL AT A MINIMUM SHOULD BE
FUNDED THIS YEAR.
AND THE REMAINING TWENTY THREE
SHOULD BE FUNDED NAPSTER SO AT
LEAST WE GET BACK UP. TO THE
AMOUNT THAT WAS AUTHORIZED ALL
THE WAY BACK IN TWO THOUSAND AND
SEVEN OUR MEMBERS REPRESENT
PEOPLE WHO HAVE SUFFERED FROM
ELDER ABUSE.
WHO HAVE SUFFERED FROM SEX
DISCRIMINATION WHO HAVE SUFFERED
FROM SEX ABUSE WHO ARE
CATASTROPHICALLY INJURED AND
THEY NEED TO HAVE THEIR MOTIONS
HEARD THEY NEED TO HAVE THOSE
COURT ROOMS?
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE AND SO WE
THINK NOW IS THE TIME TO FINALLY
FIND THOSE.
JUDGESHIPS THANKS.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS AND WAS GARY
NADLER I AM THE PRESIDING JUDGE
OF CINEMA COUNTY AND THE CHAIR
OF THE PRESIDING JUDGES OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
JUST A MINUTE I'VE BEEN TOLD TO
BE BRIEF DIFFICULT FOR ME BUT I
WILL TRY TO DO THAT.
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE
ADDITIONAL JUDGESHIPS FUNDING.
IT HAS BEEN A VERY VERY BIG
TOPIC WITH THE TRIAL JUDGES AND
THE PRESIDING JUDGES OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND ON THAT'LL SAY WITH THAT
SUPPORT EXPRESSED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MICHAEL
OUT ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEFENSE COUNSEL WE ARE AN
ASSOCIATION OF CIVIL
PRACTITIONERS DEFENDING IN CIVIL
LITIGATION.
LIKE TO ASSOCIATE MYSELF WITH MS
TRAVELS COMMENTS ABOUT
ADDITIONAL JUDGESHIPS AND
SUPPLEMENT WHAT SHE SAID IN THIS
WAY.
YOU YOU RAISE SOME INTERESTING
COMPARISONS WHAT ABOUT TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN NOW AND SO ON
AND WHAT IS CHANGE.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT DID
CHANGE BACK THEN IS --
FEES FOR CIVIL LITIGANTS WENT UP
DRAMATICALLY.
AND YOU YET WHAT WE'RE NOT.
BEING HOWDY HERE BUT WHAT WAS AS
WE WERE PAYING MORE WHILE CIVIL
TRIALS WERE TAKING A BACKSEAT TO
CONSTITUTIONAL SPEEDY TRIAL
REQUIREMENTS ON CRIMINAL.
SO WE WERE LITERALLY PAYING MORE
AND GETTING LESS.
AND THAT'S BEEN TRUE NOW FOR A
DOZEN YEARS AND THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BEGIN TO WRITE
THAT.
JUST AS MS DRABBLE.
MEMBERS RELY ON THE SPEEDY AND
EFFICIENT.
ADMINISTRATION OF CASES SO DOES
THE DEFENSE.
AND IN SOME COUNTIES IT CAN BE
EIGHT AND TWELVE MONTHS TO GET A
SUMMARY JUDGMENT MOTION CALENDAR
AND HEARD FOR EXAMPLE SO THIS IS
AN OPPORTUNITY AND SO WE WOULD
ASSOCIATE OURSELVES WITH THE
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS.
AND ASK AT A MINIMUM FOR THAT TO
HAPPEN THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS IGNITES YOUR
HERNANDEZ ACTUALLY HER BEHALF TO
CLIENTS AND TWO RELATED BUT
ISSUES. ONE IS THE CALIFORNIA
COURT REPORTER ASSOCIATION AND
WHILE THERE IS A LOT TO SAY --
I'M HOPING THAT THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WILL TAKE ADVANTAGE AND
ASK SOME QUESTIONS IN ADDITION
TO HAVING PUBLIC COME ASK
QUESTIONS OF SOME OF THE
INDIVIDUALS HERE ONLINE WE HAVE
A NUMBER OF OUR REPRESENTATIVES
IN LINE THAT WILL TRY TO RESPOND.
TO SOME OF THE COMMENTS THAT
WERE MADE AND SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT WERE MADE BUT I
DON'T KNOW IF THE CHAIR OF THE
MEMBERS WOULD INDULGE IN ASK
SOME OF THE MEN --
PUBLIC MEMBERS SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS HOW --
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION MORE
ACCURATE INFORMATION --
AS THE AS THEY MAKE THEIR PUBLIC
COMMENT FEEL FREE TO ADDRESS
THOSE ISSUES --
I WILL NOT WHILE I OF COURSE
APPRECIATE BREVITY L. NOT CUT
YOU OFF IF YOU ARE ADDRESSING
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT WE
RAISED.
PREVIEW THAT I I WILL TAKE IT I
WILL DENOUNCE TAKE IT'S
PERSONALLY GIVE KIND OF A LITTLE
BOOK BROUGHT ANSWER.
SOME OF THE QUESTIONS ON THE
ISSUES ON BEHALF OF CAL REPORTER
ASSOCIATION --
AND YOU'LL HEAR MORE ABOUT THIS
THE IDEA THAT THERE IS A
SHORTAGE QUOTE UNQUOTE SHORTAGE.
REALLY NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED IN
A NUMBER OF WAYS NUMBER ONE AND
AND I THINK SANDIEGO WAS
BROUGHT UP --
KEEP IN MIND HISTORICALLY WHAT
HAPPENED IN SAN DIEGO THE COURT
REPORTERS AND CIVIL IN FAMILY
LAW WERE FIRED AND LET GO.
SO THERE YOU HAVE A POTENTIAL
WORK FORCE THAT WAS ALREADY
FEELING A LOT OF THE SLOTS IN
FACT THAT RESULTED IN THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT
DECISION.
IT JUST CAME OUT A FEW MONTHS
AGO --
INDICATING THAT LOW INCOME
LITIGANTS ARE THAT THEIR RIGHTS
ARE BEING VIOLATED BECAUSE THEY
DID NOT HAVE ACCESS TO THE SAME
RESOURCES CORP READ COREY PORTER.
AS HE ASKED SOMEONE WHO IS MORE
FLUENT SO WHEN WE START TALKING
ABOUT INDIVIDUAL COUNTIES AND
PULLING BACK THE LAYERS YOU
START SEEING A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT PICTURE OF WHAT THIS
QUOTE UNQUOTE SHORTAGES AND I
KNOW SOME OTHER FOLKS WILL
ADDRESS --
APPLICATIONS IN SAN DIEGO AS FAR
AS THE PIPELINE. FOR COURT
REPORTERS IN THE ADDRESS A
COUPLE OF THINGS ONE IS --
THERE IS A TRANSCRIPT FEE THAT
IS SET BY STATUTE SO THE WAY
THAT QUARTER REPORTERS.
IN ALL COUNTIES ARE SET UP THEY
ARE EMPLOYEES OR WHAT WOULD BE
CONSIDERED THE WORK DAY.
AT NIGHT BY STATUTEIN ON
WEEKENDS WHEN THEY'RE WORKING ON
TRANSCRIPTS INCLUDED TRANSCRIPTS
THAT BY STATUTE THEY'RE REQUIRED
TO DELIVER WITHIN A CERTAIN TIME
PERIOD SPECIALLY FELONY PRELIMS.
AND IF THEY'RE LATE THEY GET
DOCKED 50%.
THAT THEY ARE INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS FOR THAT TIME PERIOD
FOR THE EVENINGS AND WEEKENDS
WHICH THEY WORK REGULARLY.
THEY DO NOT RECEIVE COMPENSATION.
FROM THE COURTS.
INSTEAD THEY RECEIVE THIS FEE.
WHEN THE WHEN THERE ARE
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE COMING INTO
THE CORE PORTING PROFESSION ARE
EXPLAINED AFTER WORK ON THEIR
OWN BY THEIR OWN EQUIPMENT?
PAY THE SELF EMPLOYMENT TAX AND
THEN THERE EXPLAIN --
BY THE WAY THE FEE FOR THAT
TRANSCRIPT WAS SET IN.
NINETEEN NINETY BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND HAS NOT BEEN
INCREASED SINCE THEN.
THAT BECOMES A PROBLEM
RECRUITING INDIVIDUALS IT'S ONE
OF MANY PROBLEMS THE LEGISLATURE
HAS PASSED.
LEGISLATION TO INCREASE.
THAT FEE A FEW TIMES.
I'VE BEEN VETOED A HAS NOT BEEN
SUPPORTED BY JUDICIAL COUNCIL
OFFICIALLY --
THOSE ARE THINGS THAT WE THINK
COULD HELP IF WE WANT TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THESE THESE ISSUES --
THE LASTING ALL ADDRESS BECAUSE
I KNOW SOME OF IS IS WHAT
HAPPENED WITH THE TEN MILLION.
I'M I CAN TELL YOU AND YOU'LL
HEAR MORE SPECIFICALLY WHAT
HAPPENS BECAUSE IN SPECIFIC
COUNTIES.
BUT AT THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
MEETING I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
AND IF I HAVE THIS WRONG I CAN
BE CORRECTED BY THE VIDEO
IRONICALLY --
V. JUDICIAL COUNCIL MADE CLEAR
THAT IF THERE IS A COUNTY.
THAT ALREADY IS PROVIDING FAMILY
LAW COURT REPORTERS OR IF
THEY'RE FULL OR YOU KNOW THEY'RE
FULLY PROVIDING THE SERVICES IN
FAMILY LAW.
THEN THEY COULD STILL GET ACCESS
TO SOME MONEY AND USE THAT MONEY
FOR OTHER PURPOSES SO I WANT TO
BE CLEAR WHEN THEY SAID.
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL WE SAID IT
COULD ONLY BE FOR FOR FOR COURT
REPORTERS THERE WAS A LITTLE BIT
OF A CABBIE ON ASTERISK AND IT
WAS A VERY BIG.
DEBATE I'M AT THE TIME THAT THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL MADE ITS MOTION
IN THERE ARE CHANGES TO THE
MOTION.
BUT THERE WAS A LITTLE BIT OF
LEVERAGE AND BECAUSE OF THAT YOU
WILL HEAR.
IN THEIR INDIVIDUAL COUNTIES.
REPORTER TO BE MOVED FROM ONE
DEPARTMENT NON FAMILY LAW
DEPARTMENTS OVER TO FAMILY LOT
APARTMENTS.
IT FULLY PROVIDE.
POTENTIALLY IN FAMILY LAW.
THEY WER ABLE TO GET THAT MONEY
DO OTHER THINGS WITH IT AND THEN
THEY CREATE A PROBLEM.
IN OTHER CASES NON FAMILY LAW
CASES WHERE THERE WASN'T A COURT
REPORTER AVAILABLE YOU CAN HEAR
MORE ABOUT THAT LET ME JUST
CLOSE ON BEHALFOF ANOTHER
CLIENT BUT ON THIS ISSUE --
THE CALIFORNIA TERMS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE WHICH IS
STATEWIDE ASSOCIATION FROM
DEFENSE LAWYERS.
AND HAVING DISCUSSIONS WITH THEM
THEY'VE AUTHORIZED ME TO SHARE
WITH YOU.
THAT THEY HAVE BEEN SEEN A THE
USE OF ELECTRONIC RECORDING
EQUIPMENT IN MISDEMEANOR CASES
AND GROWING.
AND THEY ARE EXTREMELY I'M
PLEASED WITH IT SO FOR THE BAR
THAT HANDLES THESE CASES THEY DO
NOT THINK OF TRONIC RECORDING
EQUIPMENT IS THE WAY TO GO.
ABSOLUTELY THE WRONG WAY TO GO
AND HAVE A NUMBER OF PROBLEMS
AND THEY HAVE TAKEN SITE --
IN THEIR CASES WITH ON GETTING
ACCURATE LOT OF VOICES TALK OVER
EACH OTHER IN AUDIBLE. SEVEN
ZERO HERE THE JUDGES SO THEY'RE
REALLY NOT HAPPY WITH SEEN IN
SOME COURTROOMS WHERE THEY'RE
INCREASING ELECTRONIC RECORDING
THERE --
BECAUSE A MOVE CORE PART IS THE
FAMILY LAW SO THAT THEY CAN USE
THE MONEY FOR OTHER PURPOSES AS
OPPOSED TO I THINK THE INTENT.
OF THE LEGISLATURE WAS TO
SUPPLEMENT THE COURT REPORTER
WORK FORCE AND I THINK SOME
COURTS OF TAKE COULD BE
SUPPLEMENT.
YOU KNOW JUST MAKE SURE FAMILIES
TAKE CARE OF THEM THEY CAN DO
OTHER THINGS WITH THE MONEY IN
IN PART IS BECAUSE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL GAVE THEM THAT OPENING.
ALL MY COMMENTS BY MAY COME BACK
UP.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S SANDEEP
WALTON I AM THE PRESIDENT FOR S.
CI YOU TEND TO WANNA CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY.
ALSO THE PRESIDENT ELECT FOR C.
C. R. A..
A COUPLE THINGS --
ONE I WANT TO THANK THE FOR
HAVING THE LEGISLATURE ALLOW THE
TEN MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
FAMILY OUR REPORTERS.
MY COUNTY WAS ABLE TO HIRE.
TO AND IN THE SAME BREATH THEY
TURNED AROUND AND BOUGHT ENOUGH
AUDIO RECORDING EQUIPMENT FOR
EVERY SINGLE COURT ROOM IN.
A PONY.
AND TO ADDRESS THE QUOTE UNQUOTE
SHORTAGE IT'S NOT A SHORTAGE AT
CEMEX ALLOCATION OF REPORTERS.
IN CONTRA COSTA WE ALSO FIRED
LAID OFF FOR ATTRITION GOT RID
OF REPORTERS IN CIVIL IN FAMILY
LAW.
AND WE'VE HIRED TO TO REPLACE
ANYONE OF THE LAWN MOTION
CALENDARS OVER THERE THERE'S TEN
COURT REPORTERS LINED UP WITH
MACHINES WAITING TO HEAR ONE
MATTER.
AND THOSE OTHER NINE PEOPLE THAT
ARE THERE COULD BE OUT COVERING
OTHER COURTROOMS OTHER
DEPOSITIONS SO IT'S A MESS
ALLOCATION AND IT'S CREATING A
PERCEIVED SHORTAGE WHERE THERE
IS NOT.
ONE THAT THE COURTS HAVE CREATED
ON THEIR OWN BY GETTING RID OF
FAMILY LAW AND CIVIL REPORTERS.
SO IF YOU WOULD EMPLOY ONE
PERSON IN THERE YOU'D HAVE THAT
MANY MORE. TO COVER OTHER
MATTERS IN THE FIELD
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME --
MADAM CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AND THE HARD WORKING
SUBCOMMITTEE STAFF MY NAME IS
DIANA VAN **** I'M AN OFFICIAL
WITH LA SUPERIOR COURT.
I'M ALSO THE CURRENT PRESIDENT
FOR LOS ANGELES COUNTY COURT
REPORTERS ASSOCIATION MEMBER OF
C. C. R. A. AND I'M A MEMBER OF
SEIU LOCAL.
SEVEN TO ONE I WOULD LIKE TO GO
OUR SCRIPTS AND ACTUALLY ADDRESS
THE TWO OF BIG COMMENTS ARE
REALLY CAUGHT MY EAR AT THIS
MORNING.
FIRST --
MADAM CHAIR --
I WAS INVOLVED IN THE FORMING OF
BOTH THE TEST AND HIRING PROCESS
FOR THE REPORTERS ONCE LA
SUPERIOR COURT WAS ABLE TO START
RETIRING REPORTERS.
THERE WAS A MACHINE TEST
INVOLVED IN THAT SITUATION AND
REPORTERS TRICKLED IN THIS WAS
ON TOP OF ALREADY PASSING ONE OF
THE HARDEST DETESTS TO BE A
CERTIFIED STENOGRAPHER FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THIS WAS ON
TOP OF THAT.
ONCE MANAGEMENT SAW AN
ADMINISTRATION SAW THAT THE
TRICKLE THEY CAME BACK WE SAT
DOWN RE RECONFIGURED THEY TOOK
AWAY THAT MACHINE PORTION.
AND WE SELL A DELUGE TO THE ONCE
IN A ROW WE WERE INTERVIEWING.
FIVE SIX POTENTIAL REPORTERS AND
HAVING TO HAVE A DESIGNATED
HUMAN RESOURCES PERSON TO BRING
THOSE PEOPLE AND GET THEM
FINGERPRINTED AND GET THE MAN.
SO THERE WAS A A HELP IN THAT
REGARD --
HAS A TRICKLE DOWN YES BECAUSE I
WOULD.
BE BACK ON MIGHT THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKER WHEN YOU HAVE A
FREELANCE WORLD THAT IS
COLLIDING WITH THE OFFICIAL
SHIPS AND PUBLI SERVICE.
YOU'RE NOT JUST --
COMBINED IN COSTS IN WHAT WE
MAKE YOUR AFFECTED BY WHAT
HAPPENS LIKE SANDY SAID
PREVIOUSLY. EIGHT SEVEN OR EIGHT
OF THOSE REPORTERS COULD IF
THEY'RE NOT GETTING THE WORK
POTENTIALLY COME IN AND WANT TO
PROVIDE SERVICES AS A PUBLIC
SERVANT AS OFFICIALS IN THE
COURTS SO.
I WOULD SPEAK TO A CHANGE AND
THAT AN ACKNOWLEDGEMENT OF WHAT
THE REQUIREMENTS ARE --
OF EACH INDIVIDUAL COURT WHAT
THEY'RE REQUESTING UP I WILL
REPEAT THE CALIFORNIA C. S. R.
TEST.
AND I'VE BEEN A REPORTER. FOR
TWENTY THREE YEARS NOW IS ONE OF
THE HARDEST CERTIFY TESTS.
I'M PROUD OF IT AND IT'S
IMPORTANT IT'S IMPORTANT WE HAVE
CERTIFICATION BUT IT'S ENOUGH TO
GET THESE REPORTERS POTENTIAL
EMPLOYEES IN THE DOOR AND GET
THEM INTERESTED.
I WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK TO YOU --
MR MALEK TEAR YOUR QUEST AN
UNUSUAL I'M REPORTERS HAVE BEEN
RETIRED FOR MANY YEARS WHEN THEY
WERE BABY REPORTERS THEY WERE
BEING ASKED WHY NOT TAPE IT.
NOW IT'S WHY NOT AUDIO RECORDED
WHY NOT VIDEOTAPE IT IT'S A FAIR
QUESTION.
WHAT WE DON'T LOOK AT AND WHAT
LAY PEOPLE DON'T UNDERSTAND WHEN
THEY ASKED THAT QUESTION IS THE
FEES THAT AND THE TIME THAT ARE
WASTED AT THE BACK END?
I TAKE THE RISK I AM RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE RECORD I GUARD ON THE
GUARDIAN OF THE RECORD.
I'M ALSO THE PERSON RESPONSIBLE
INSERTED FOR CERTIFYING THAT
RECORD IT'S MY LICENSE ON THE
LINE.
SO I AM ONE PERSON IN THE ROOM
GUARDING IT FROM CROSS TALKING
GUARDING IT FROM.
EMOTIONAL PARTICULARLY IN FAMILY
LAW CASES WHERE I THINK WE CAN
ALL IMAGINE IT'S SOME OF THE
MOST EMOTIONAL --
HEARINGS.
AND PROTECTING IT AND MAKING
SURE EVERY SINGLE WORD EVERY
SINGLE SPEAKER WAS PROPERLY
IDENTIFIED AND I SIGN MY NAME TO
THAT WHEN YOU START IMPLEMENTING
VIDEO AND AUDIO.
THOSE PEOPLE MAY NOT BE IN THE
ROOM NUMBER ONE AND NOW YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY SEPARATING TO MAYBE
TWO OR THREE OTHER
SUBCONTRACTORS THAT ARE
COMPLETELY SEPARATE AND NOT
RESPONSIBLE FOR CERTIFYING THAT
RECORD FOR THE PUBLIC.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME I
WELCOME ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE OF ME IN THIS REGARD.
I DON'T CARE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME'S SCOTT.
MCCOURT GATOR IN CONTRA COSTA.
BARTON LOCATIONS FIELD.
RISK POPULATIONS ADULTS WITH
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED ADULTS.
AN ELDERLY.
THESE CONSERVATIVES RELY ON THE
CONSPIRATORS AND THEIR
CAREGIVERS.
UP FOR ALL THEIR BASIC NEEDS.
I'LL BE CODE REQUIRES US TO
VISIT THE CONSERVATIVES EVERY
TWO YEARS.
I'M NOT AWARE OF A COURT.
THAT IS IN COMPLIANCE WITH THE
STATIC.
IN CONTRA COSTA COUNTY WE'VE
CHANGED A LOT OF THINGS TO TRY
TO IMPROVE THIS BUT WE'RE STILL.
OTHER THAN THE VISITS EVERY
THREE TO FOUR YEARS.
LAST YEAR IN CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
WE HAD AN ELDERLY ADULTS.
IN A CARE HOME DRIVE NEGLECT
[inaudible]
WALLACE FULLY STAFFED
INVESTIGATIONS UNIT MAY NOT.
HE THAT THA WOULD NOT HAVE
HAPPENED WHICH CERTAINLY
INCREASE THE CHANCES THAT THE
COLLECTIVE WOULD HAVE BEEN.
DISCOVERED POTENTIALLY IN TIME
TO PREVENT THAT.
I'M REQUESTING THE DATE THE MANY
CONSIDER ALLOCATING FUNDS FOR
COURT INVESTIGATORS AND MURDER
AS THEY HAVE. FOR THE COURT
REPORTER [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIRPERSON
SKINNER IN AND SENATORS I
APPRECIATE THE TIME YOU'VE GIVEN
ME MY NAME IS LESLIE MAYBE I'M
PRESIDENT OF ORANGE COUNTY
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION.
AS WELL AS I'VE BEEN A COURTROOM
CLERK IN ORANGE COUNTY SUPERIOR
COURT FOR TWENTY SEVEN YEARS --
I CAN SAY THAT MOST OF US ERE
IN THE ROOM HAVE HAVE UNDERSTOOD
THE IMPACTS OF THE THE
REDUCTIONS THAT OCCURRED THAT
STARTED IN TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHT IN ORANGE COUNTY
SPECIFICALLY WE LOST A
COURTHOUSE THAT SERVED SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND RESIDENTS.
THOSE RESIDENTS NOW HAVE TO
TRAVEL FURTHER ACCESS TO FOR
THEIR JUSTICE OF THEIR CASES AS
WELL AS LATE AWAIT FOR LONGER
PERIODS OF TIME --
BUT I THINK THAT THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE ALL EXPERIENCING --
WE APPRECIATE THE RECENT
INVESTMENT THAT THE LEGISLATURE
HAS MADE IN THE COURTS.
AND THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE TO
BUILD.
UPON THE COURT'S BETTER BUT
WE'RE ASKING.
AT THIS TIME.
WE NEED MORE.
WE NEED MORE I MEAN THE LAW
FRONTLINE WORKERS THAT'S WHO'S
PROVIDING THAT ACCESS TO THAT
JUSTICE ARE KEEP WE'RE PROVIDING
THAT.
OUR COMMUNITIES TO WORK OUR
FAMILIES ARE OUR NEIGHBORS AND
WITHOUT THAT MANY WE CAN'T GET
STAFFING BACK UP WE CAN'T GET
BACKLOG BACK UP AND WE CAN'T GET
TO ALL THE CASE RESOLUTION.
THAT WE NEED TO DO NESTLE
FRONTLINE WORKERS THAT HAVE BEEN
TOWING THE LINE AND DOING MORE
WITH LESS SO WE ASK YOU PLEASE
AT WE JUST NEED MORE FUNDING I
CAN'T EVEN PUT A NUMBER ON IT.
WE JUST NEED THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR THAT IF NOTHING MORE
JUST TO SERVICE OUR COMMUNITIES.
AND I APPRECIATE THE TIME AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE LATER WE'RE ALWAYS
AVAILABLE TO YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
BROOKE RYAN ON OFFICIAL COURT
REPORTER WITH THE SACRAMENTO
SUPERIOR COURT I'VE BEEN A
REPORTER FOR TWENTY TWO YEARS.
I AM A PAST PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA COURT REPORTERS
ASSOCIATION I'M INVOLVED WITH
THEIR LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE.
I AM A CURRENT MEMBER OF THE
NASH AND THE CURRENT BOARD
MEMBER FOR THE NATIONAL COURT
REPORTERS ASSOCIATION.
AND I AM HERE TODAY TO SPEAK TO
YOU AS THE CHAIR OF UNITED
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES --
LOCAL UNION SO THERE'S A NUMBER
REST IF I MAY I'M I'M GONNA
START WITH THE C. C. R. A.
COMPONENT WHAT I DO FOR C.
SERIES I FACT GATHER.
THAT IS MY JOB AND SO --
I WOULD LIKE TO ADDRESS SAN
DIEGO FIRST WE HAVE A CURRENT
BOARD MEMBER THAT IS EMPLOYED
WITH -- SAN
DIEGO LAST YEAR WHEN SHE APPLIED
SHE WAS RANKED NUMBER TWENTY
SEVEN OUT OF FIFTY SEVEN THEY
HAD FIFTY SEVEN QUALIFIED COURT
REPORTERS THAT APPLY.
I AM SO THEN I TOOK I TOOK THE
TIME TO CALL IN NUMBER THE
PEOPLE THAT DIDN'T TAKE THE JOB
AND WHAT THEY HAD ASKED FOR WAS
THE TOP STEP.
BECAUSE THEY'RE MAKING SO MUCH
MORE MONEY IN THE FREE MARKET
RIGHT SO MR RODDY SAID THEY HAD
SO MANY PEOPLE RETIRING I'M
GONNA ASSUME FOR THE SAKE OF
THIS THAT THEY RETIRED AT THE
TOP STEP.
YOU CAN BRING THEM IN AT THE TOP
STEP AND REPLACE THEM BUT THE
COURT REFUSED SO NUMBER OF THOSE
COURT REPORTERS WERE NOT HIRED
BECAUSE THEY COULDN'T AFFORD.
I'M TWERKED THERE BUT WE DO KNOW --
SOME HAVE BEEN --
HIRED THE OTHER THING IS THE
FACT GATHER IS LIKE DIANE AND
SANDY BOTH ALLUDED.
TO WE HAVE PICTURES OF UP AND
DOWN THIS COURTHOUSE WHEN THE
COURTS GOT RID OF CIVIL COURT
REPORTERS IN FAMILY LAW OF
NUMEROUS COURT REPORTERS IN
THEIR MACHINES LINED UP AGAINST
THE BENCH.
AND THEY RUN UP AND GRAB THEIR
MACHINE TO COVER THE ONE MATTER
AND THEN THEY RUN OUT.
THERE'S THERE THEY ARE RIGHT
THERE WE HAVE COURT REPORTERS WE
KNOW THEY'RE APPLYING FOR
POSITIONS I UNDERSTAND FROM
DIANA THAT --
A LATE HAS BEEN A BACKLOG IN
PROCESSING OVER HUNDRED
APPLICANTS A SACRAMENTO --
WALL.
THEY USED TO ALWAYS GIVE US THE
NUMBERS NOW THERE'S LIKE.
I'M SO NOW I'D LIKE TO TALK
ABOUT --
SACRAMENTO IF I MAY SO AT
SACRAMENTO GOT MONEY FOR FAMILY
LAW COURT REPORTERS AND THEY'VE
HIRED. TWO FOR FAMILY LAW
HOWEVER IN THE MEANTIME THEY
HAVE FROZE NINE OFFICIAL COURT
REPORTER POSITIONS THIS JUST
HAPPENED THEY JUST INSTALLED E.
R..
IN -- THREE
THE DEPARTMENTS SAY THEY TOOK
YOUR MONEY AND THEY BOUGHT.
YOUR MACHINE AND THEN FROZE ALL
THE REST OF OR POSITIONS.
SO -- WE
OBVIOUSLY HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
THAT AS WE TALK ABOUT THE
JUDICIAL POSITIONS IN SACRAMENTO
WE HAVE A VERY SERIOUS PROBLEM
ONE TO SIX JUDGES A DAY ARE
GOING DARK BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
HIRING STAFF. ONE TO SIX A MARCH
NO ON FEBRUARY ELEVENTH IT WAS
THE MONDAY BEFORE THE HOLIDAY
THAT'S THE RIGHT DATE THEY HAD
TO DISMISS OUT WRITER TO
DEFENDANT FELONY TRIAL.
IS DISMISSED.
BECAUSE THEY SAID THEY DON'T
HAVE A COURT NO THEY HAD A COURT
YEAH JUDGES SITTING IN THEIR
CHAMBERS.
NOT WORKING ON THE RECORD
BECAUSE A REFUSING TO HIRE STAFF.
SO DO WE NEED JUDICIAL POSITIONS.
NOT JUST ACTUALLY HAVE TO WORK
THAT'S THE WAY I SEE IT ON FOR
THEM TO WORK THEY ACTUALLY HAVE
TO HIRE STAFF STAFF WE KNOW THIS
OUT THERE.
THEY JUST NEED TO HIRE IF THEY'D
FOR FAMILY LOT THOSE PEOPLE ARE
GOING TO COME IN AND TAKE THOSE
JOBS BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN --
YOU KNOW A EMPLOYED BY LAW FIRMS
TO COME IN AND TAKE THOSE CASES
AND SO WHAT I DO NOW IS MY
FRIENDS OUT THERE THERE ON THE
CIVIL SIDE.
THEY GET A HUNDRED FIFTEEN
HUNDRED DOLLARS A DAY APPEARANCE
BE.
WELL AS AN OFFICIAL IF YOU COME
IN IT THERE'S A USER FEE IN OUR
USER FREEDOM SECOND I WAS LIKE
SIX HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS WHAT'S
LOST IN THIS CONVERSATION TO ME.
IS ACTUAL.
WHAT'S GOING ON TO THE CONSUMER
SO THE CONSUMERS PAIN FIT
UPWARDS OF FIFTEEN HUNDRED AND
MORE A DAY TO GET A COURT
REPORTER IN THERE.
INSTEAD OF THE USER FEE THAT
THING COMES BACK TO THE COURTS
TO PAY FOR US.
AT I LOOK FOR THE ANY QUESTIONS
TO AND THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NUMBERS.
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS BEATRICE NO
NOT MY FAMILY COURT COUNSELOR
WITH CONTRA COSTA SUPERIOR COURT.
AND I'M HERE TO TALK.
ABOUT -- THE
ISSUE OF A COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENTS. ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT --
HELPS TO RETAIN EMPLOYEES IS --
TO ALLOCATE FUNDS FOR COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTMENTS IT IS VERY
DIFFICULT TO CONTINUE TO SERVE
THE PUBLIC --
EFFECTIVELY WHEN WE ARE
CONSTANTLY HAVING TO THINK ABOUT
HOW WE'RE GOING TO MAKE
ADJUSTMENTS TO OUR FINANCES TO
BE ABLE TO CONTINUE TO SURVIVE.
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
CONVERSATION ABOUT RETENTION AND
LOOKING AT THE COURT REPORTERS.
BUT I THINK THAT THIS IS NOT
JUST AN ISSUE THAT --
IS AFFECTING QUICKLY PUT.
THROUGHOUT THE TRIAL COURT.
SO I'M HERE TO ASK THAT THE
COMMITTEE CONSIDER --
ALLOCATING FUNDS FOR COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTMENT FOR COURT
EMPLOYEES THANK YOU.
HI LESLIE HI MY CHILDREN'S LAW
CENTER OF CALIFORNIA WE
REPRESENT ALL THE CHILDREN IN
FOSTER CARE IN LOS ANGELES
SACRAMENTO AND PLASTER COUNTIES.
AND JUST ONE OFFER OUR SUPPORT
BOTH THROUGH THE JUDICIAL ITEM --
WE ARE MANY OF OUR JUDGES AND
THE COUNTIES THAT WE PRACTICE
AND STRUGGLE WITH CRUSHING
CASELOADS AND WITHOUT THOSE
POSITIONS FILLED WE CAN'T MOVE.
ANY OTHER IMPROVEMENTS THAT ARE
MADE DON'T HAVE ANY EFFECT WE
CAN STAFF MORE ATTORNEYS IN THE
COURTROOM BUT IF THERE'S NO
JUDGE OR THE JUDGE IS STILL
TRYING TO GET THROUGH A VERY
HEAVY CALENDAR IT DOESN'T SOLVE
THE WHOLE PROBLEM AND I THINK.
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE THE COURT
REPORTER P. SIMILARLY.
WE CAN'T BREAK UP THE COURT
SYSTEM INTO PIECES OF LAWYERS OR
JUDGES OR COURT REPORTERS OR
DAFT BECAUSE WE ALL HAVE TO WORK
TOGETHER TO MOVE OUR CALENDARS
ALONG.
THE IMPACT ON THAT FOR THE I'M
NOT AN EXPERT ON THE COURT
REPORTER ISSUES ARE THAT THE
DIFFERENCES OF PERSPECTIVE. FOR
SURE BUT I CAN SAY THAT ON A DAY
I WOULD SAY ONCE A WEEK WE HAVE
AT LEAST ONE OR TWO DEPENDENCY
COURT ROOMS IN LA COUNTY THEY
CANNOT DO CASES UNTIL AT LEAST
AFTER LUNCH TIME BECAUSE THERE'S
NO COURT REPORTER.
I'M AND WE HAVE TO WAIT FOR
SOMEONE TO BECOME A WORK AND IT
KEEPS KIDS FROM HAVING THEIR
HEARINGS AND KEEPS FAMILIES FROM
GETTING THE SERVICES THAT THEY
NEED.
THANK YOU.
IT'S STILL MORNING GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR --
MOM MY NAME IS TERRENCE TRACY.
AND I'M WITH ASKED ME TWENTY
SEVEN HUNDRED IN COALITION WITH
AS HE ARE YOU TEN TO ONE WE ARE
REQUESTING.
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR COST OF
LIVING RAISES.
THERE ARE A COUPLE ISSUES THAT
WERE BROUGHT UP THAT I'D LIKE TO
ANSWER --
VERY QUICKLY I AM THE SENIOR
LEAGUE CLERK AND JUVENILE
DIVISION AND CUT ACROSS THE
COUNTY AND I AM WELL AWARE OF
THE REPORTING ISSUE --
ER IS VIRTUALLY IMPOSSIBLE AT
THIS PARTICULAR TIME BECAUSE OF
ITS INCONSISTENCY.
AND WHEN A JUDGE REQUIRES A READ
BACK.
THERE.
ADDITIONAL RESPONSIBILITY PUT ON
COURTROOM CLERKS TO NOW DO THAT
JOB SO THEY'RE DOING AN
ADDITIONAL JOB.
ALSO -- YOU
HAD MENTIONED BEFORE ABOUT THE
INCREASED WORKLOADS PROP FIFTY
SEVEN IN PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR
ADDED AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF
WORKLOAD WITH --
DURING A CRISIS BUDGET CRISIS
WHEN WE WERE LOSING I'M
PARTICULARLY --
EMPLOYEES TO FILL THOSE APPS I'M.
AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST.
OF THE COST OF LIVING IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA AND I KNOW
THAT -- THE
CHAIRPERSON IS AWARE OF THIS IS
GONE UP OVER 25%.
AND WE WORDS AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THE AMOUNT OF MONEY YOU
GAVE US LAST YEAR WE WERE ABLE
TO GET A OVER A COURSE OF TWO
YEARS A 4% RATES.
SO WE'RE STILL BEHIND THE BALL
BY 21%.
AND WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING DISCRETIONARY
FUNDING IF YOU KNOW IF NOTHING
ELSE I'M TO THE COURTS THANK YOU.
HI MAN CHAIR THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME MY NAME IS APRIL HOWEVER ON
I'M A COURT REPORTER.
IN CONTRA COSTA SUPERIOR COURT
IN MARTINEZ I'M ALSO A MEMBER OF
LABOR UNION SEIU LOCAL.
TEN TO ONE I'D LIKE TO ADDRESS
THE BUDGET ON WITH MEDITATION
FOR GORE REPORTER'S TRANSCRIPT
FEES CORE PORTERS HAVE NOT
RECEIVE AN INCREASE.
IN THEIR STATUTORILY SET
TRANSCRIPT RATE IN THIRTY YEARS.
WE URGE WE URGE YOU TO INCREASE
THE TRANSCRIPT FEE PHASES OVER
TIME WITH AN APPROXIMATE. ONE
POINT FIVE TO TWO MILLION DOLLAR
COST IN YOUR ONE AND AN
APPROXIMATE SIX TO SEVEN MILLION
DOLLAR COST IN THE FINAL YEAR.
DOES PROVIDE AN COURT
PROCEEDINGS.
THIS IS A FEMALE DOMINATED
PROFESSION ESPECIALLY DURING
WOMEN'S HISTORY MONTH WE MUST
REMIND OURSELVES THAT WE MUST
CLOSE THE PAY GAP
ITHAS BEEN THIRTY YEARS SINCE
WE RECEIVED AN INCREASE IN THE
TRANSCRIPT RIGHT.
NOW IS THE TIME TO KNOWLEDGE ARE
WORTH AND APPROVE THE TRANSCRIPT.
AGE RATE INCEASE AND I'M SURE I
JUST LIKE TO ADDRESS YOUR
QUESTION.
OF OF WHY.
I BELIEVE IT WAS SOMETHING LONG
LINES OF WHY AREN'T THE STUDENTS.
PASSING THE TEST AS THEY WERE
BEFORE.
OR FOR THAT MATTER WHY AREN'T
MORE PEOPLE APPLYING TO BE TO BE
A COURT ORDER.
YOUR QUESTION WAS A PERFECT
EXAMPLE THE RUMOR THAT WHY ARE
WE REPLACED WHY ARE WHY ARE
ISN'T WHAT WE DO.
SO VALUABLE THAT WE NEED TO BE
REPLACED BY ELECTRONIC RECORDING.
WHEN I START WHEN I WENT TO
SCHOOL IN NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
THAT'S THE FIRST QUESTION I
ASKED BEFORE I WENT TO SCHOOL
FOR SOMETHING OR WE'RE GOING BE
REPLACED?
SO. THIRTY YEARS LATER.
I'M GAINFULLY EMPLOYED.
I CAN DO WHAT NO MACHINE CAN DO.
AND AS FAR AS GETTING AN
ACCURATE RECORD WHICH IS WHAT
EVERYONE WANTED FIGURE IN COURT.
AND YOU'RE HAVING THINGS TAKEN
DOWN -- I
CAN STOP PEOPLE.
PAPERS ARE CRUMBLING AND I CAN'T
HEAR WHAT THEY'RE SAYING WHAT
PEOPLE CALL OFF WHEN THE DOOR
SLAM WHEN I DON'T KNOW WHICH
WORD THEY ARE DID YOU SAY ISSUES
ARE HIS SHOES.
NOT NORMALLY ON THOUGH THERE
TALK TALKING ABOUT SHOES OR
ISSUES.
BUT ONLY A PERSON CAN MAKE THAT.
IN MY OPINION I PLAN ON LOOKING
INTO THIS BECAUSE THIS AFFECTS
MY CAREER.
THE SCHOOLS THE CORPORATE
SCHOOLS RIGHT NOW CHANGE THEIR
THEORY.
THEIR THEORY THAT'S OUR STOMACH.
AND THE NUMBERS WENT DOWN WE HAD
A 19%.
NOW 5%.
SO I PLAN ON LOOKING AT THE
NUMBERS AND THEN WHEN THEY
CHANGE THE THEORY ON WHY WERE
NOT PASSING.
BUT WHY WOULD ANYONE WANT TO GET
INTO A PROFESSION THAT EVERYONE
SAYS WE CAN BE REPLACED.
WE CAN'T BE REPLACED.
AND FROM WHAT I UNDERSTAND THE
ATTORNEYS THE JUDGES THEY DON'T
LIKE THE ARE THEY DON'T HAVE A
SAY ABOUT IT I DON'T LIKE YOUR
THEY WANT A PERSON THEY WON A
COURT ORDER.
THEY WANT THE BEST MOST ACCURATE
TRANSCRIPT THEY CAN HAVE WHICH
IS WHAT EVERYONE WANTS.
SO I JUST WANTED TO SHARE RIGHT
THANK YOU SO MUCH FREE TIME.
MORNING GOOD MORNING I'M SURE
MANY MEMBERS MACHON CAST OF THE
SERVICE EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL
UNION.
SEIU REPRESENTS TRIAL COURT
EMPLOYEES AND THIRTY NINE COUNTY
SO I I JUST KIND OF WANTED TO
SUM UP WHAT OUR OVERALL POSITION
AS AND THEN ANSWER.
THE DRESS A COUPLE ISSUES THAT
CAME UP.
FIRST -- WE
WERE VERY GRATEFUL TO FOR THE
DISCRETIONARY FUNDS WERE
PROVIDED LAST YEAR AS WELL AS
THE ADDITIONAL FORTY SEVEN
MILLION THAT WENT TO THE MOST
UNDER FUNDED TRIAL COURTS.
WHAT THAT DID WAS ALLOW ALL
COURTS TO BENEFIT A MODEST
AMOUNT FROM THE SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION?
AND THEN GIVE THAT EXTRA AMOUNT
TO THE YES TO THAT --
THE EFFORT WAS TO EQUALIZE
FUNDING AMONG THE TRIAL COURTS
WITH A FINITE POT OF MONEY SO
YOU HAD.
DONORS AND RECIPIENTS SO LAST
YEAR WAS THE FIRST TIME THAT
KIND OF ROB PETER TO PAY PAUL
SCENARIO WAS WAS RECTIFIED --
WE HOPE TO SEE SOME FUNDING --
AGAIN THIS YEAR ALLOCATE IN A
SIMILAR MANNER --
FOR THOSE MOST UNDERFUNDED
COURTS EQUALIZER FUNDING BUT
ALSO TO ALLOW OTHER TRIAL COURTS
THAT WERE ALSO UNDER FUNDED TO
CONTINUE TO MAKE PROGRESS.
TOWARDS THINGS THAT WERE
DELINEATED EARLIER RESEARCH RE
HIRING STAFF --
LENGTHENING HOURS OF OPERATIONS
THOSE SORT OF THINGS WE HAVE
SOME MODEST MOMENTUM WOULD LIKE
TO SEE THAT CONTINUE TO GO
FORWARD. ONE THING THAT'S REALLY
MISSING IN THE TRIAL COURT
BUDGET THAT IS UNLIKE ANY OTHER
BUDGETS IS THAT THE TRIAL COURT
BUDGET DOES NOT HAVE A COLA
MECHANISM. FOR COST OF DOING
BUSINESS ADJUSTMENT TO IT.
SO THEIR BUDGET IS HELD FLAT
EACH YEAR UNLESS YOU ALLOCATE
ANY MONEY SO THERE'S NO LIKE I
SAID NO COLA.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS COUNTY PROGRAMS
EVERY OTHER PROGRAM HAS AT TRIAL
COURTS A TRUST FUND DID HAVE
THAT FUND --
AND IT WAS A STRAIGHT
APPROPRIATION LIMIT --
ADJUSTMENT TO IT IT PREVIOUSLY
IT'S TIME TO REINSTATE THAT
MONEY.
I'M SO THE COURTS CAN PREDICT
FROM YEAR TO YEAR WHAT MODEST
GROWTH THEY MAY HAVE IT ALSO
GIVES THEM AN ABILITY TO
COLLECTIVELY BARGAIN WITH THEIR
EMPLOYEES WHICH IS ALSO
DIFFICULT FOR COURTS WHEN
THEY'RE OPERATING AND FIND A POT
OF MONEY --
WITH REGARD TO COURT REPORTERS
SINCE LAST YEAR'S MODEST
ALLOCATION OUR OUR LEGISLATIVE
INTENT TO SPEND TEN MILLION
DOLLARS TO HIRE FAMILY LAW COURT
I'M TWO CASES WERE --
WERE DECIDED SOMEONE MENTIONED
JAMISON --
THE DESTA WHICH ADDRESS INDIGENT
LITIGANTS.
BEING ENTITLED TO THE SAME
RESOURCES AS ANOTHER INTO.
INDIVIDUAL THE OTHER CASE WAS DO
CAN BE COMANCHE HILLS THAT
STATED THAT THE REPORTER SHALL
BE REQUIRED --
PROVIDED FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS --
SO WE WOULD ARGUE THAT THE
DEMAND IN THE REQUIREMENTS IS
THERE IS EVEN GREATER NOW THAN
IT WAS LAST YEAR AND THE COURT
HAS.
COURTS HAVE SPOKEN TO THAT
MATTER -- AS
MENTIONED THE COURT REPORTER
TRANSCRIPT RATE IS THIRTY YEARS
OUTSTANDING AND WE WOULD ALSO
ASK FOR A MODEST INCREASE WITH
THAT -- THE
RESERVES ARE VERY RESTRICTIVE
AND IT'S HARD FOR TRIAL COURTS
OPERATE WITH THAT 1% RESERVE CAP
SO WE'D LIKE TO SEE SOME
ADJUSTMENT TO THAT --
WE ARE SUPPORTED OF FUNDING FOR
DEPENDENTS TO COUNSEL WE THINK
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT --
THE JUDGESHIPS IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THE JUDGE
THAT SHIP AMOUNTS COMES WITH.
FUNDING FOR STAFF BUT IT'S NOT
ALWAYS ALLOCATED IN THAT WAY WE
THINK IT MUST BE USED IN THAT
WAY.
I'M ESPECIALLY WHEN WE HAVE ALL
THIS DEMAND FOR COURT REPORTERS --
THERE WAS A LOT OF TALK ABOUT
SAN DIEGO SO I JUST WANTED TO
ADDRESS THAT ISSUE --
IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY THERE ARE
FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY THREE
LICENSED COURT REPORTERS OVER
SIX THOUSAND LICENSE REPORTERS
IN CALIFORNIA I THINK WE
APPROXIMATELY TWELVE TO FOURTEEN
HUNDRED JUDGES STATEWIDE.
THERE'S A LOT OF COURT REPORTERS
OUT THERE THERE ARE THOSE JOBS I
WOULD SAY PART OF THE PROBLEM IS
NOT NECESSARILY A SHORTAGE
PROBLEM BUT A RECRUITMENT
PROBLEM. FOR EXAMPLE IN SAN
DIEGO COUNTY THE STARTING WAGE
IS EIGHTY THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR AN INDIVIDUAL WHO HAS
PREVIOUSLY NOT SERVED.
AS AN OFFICIAL COURT REPORTER
SOMEONE WHO WORKED IN THE COURT
BUT THEY MAY HAVE BEEN A
FREELANCE COURT REPORTER FOR
TWENTY YEARS.
THE SAME STARTING WAGE FOR THAT
SAME INDIVIDUAL IN RIVERSIDE AND
SAN DIEGO --
RIVERSIDE IN ORANGE COUNTY IS
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED EIGHT
THOUSAND THAT'S MORE DESIRABLE
TO LIVE AND WORK IN RIVERSIDE.
CHEAPER COSTS OF CHEAPER COST OF
LIVING HIGHER WAGE.
THE OTHER THING IN SAN DIEGO AS
SOMEONE MENTIONED IS ALL THE
FAMILY LAW CIVIL REPORTERS WERE
LET GO.
SO WHEN YOU COMBINE THAT WITH A
LOWER WAGE A HISTORY OF
TERMINATING STAFF DOESN'T BECOME
THE MOST DESIRABLE PLACE.
ADDITIONALLY THE REPORT RECORD
REPORTERS REPORT TO ME.
THAT THE CORE IS ONLY PROVIDING
INDIVIDUALS IN MANY OF THESE
PROCEEDINGS UPON REQUEST DESPITE
THE COURT SAYING THE REPORTER
MUST BE PROVIDED.
THE REPORTERS ALSO REPORT THAT
THEY ARE SITTING THERE WAITING
TO BE ASSIGNED TO COURT ROOMS.
AND WE'LL HAVE EIGHT TO TEN OF
THEM SITTING THERE BUT THEY'RE
NOT BEING ASSIGNED AN
INDIVIDUALS ARE NOT GETTING A
RECORD -- SO
AGAIN I WOULD SAY IT'S A A
RECRUITMENT PROBLEMS SOME PLACES
I ALSO WANT TO SAY IN DEFENSE OF
SAN DIEGO AND OTHER COURTS LIKE
DIFFICULTY RECRUITING.
IS IT THOSE COURTS WERE DONOR
COURTS UNDER THE THE MODEL SO
THEY WERE NOT.
ENJOYING THE SAME AMOUNTS OF
INCREASES OTHER COURTS SO THEY
MAY HAVE DIFFICULTY IN HALF IN
BRINGING UP THOSE WAGES TO BE
COMPETITIVE TO RECRUIT PEOPLE.
SO I THINK THAT'S PART OF THE
PART THAT COULD BE PART OF THE
PROBLEM --
MISTER MOORE LIKE ELECTRONIC
RECORDING AND VIDEO REPORTING IS
NOT A VERBATIM RECORD IN
CALIFORNIA ARE STANDARD FOR
TRANSCRIPTS IS A VERBATIM RECORD
FOR NUMBER OF REASONS AND
AUDIBLES --
VOICES GET LOST SOME MACHINES
CAN'T --
PICK UP FEMALE VOICES WHICH
PRIVILEGED CONVERSATIONS BETWEEN
A LAWYER AND A CLIENT --
AND IT'S EXPENSIVE TO TRANSCRIBE --
ACCORDING TO A TRANSCRIPT.
MR RODDY MENTIONED THAT THE
STATE LEGISLATURE DID IT DO A
PILOT OF ELECTRONIC RECORDING.
AND WHAT THAT YIELDED WAS A
STATUTE THAT IS IN PLACE NOW
THAT THE RECORDINGS WERE SO
INCONSISTENT THAT THEY SHOULD
NOT BE USED FOR THE MOST --
IMPORTANT TYPES OF PROCEEDINGS
ADDITIONALLY I'VE FOUND THAT ONE
PERSON THE COURT REPORTER WAS
THEN REPLACED BY FOUR PEOPLE.
BECAUSE WHAT PEOPLE DON'T ALWAYS
REMEMBER IS THAT THE COURT
REPORTER HANDLES ADMINISTRATION.
OF ALL THE TRANSCRIPTS THE
INTERACTION BETWEEN THE CLIENTS
AND THE AND OTHER WERE ON THE
COURT ABOUT.
GIVING TRANSCRIPTS OUT
MAINTAINING TRANSCRIPTS SO YOU
ALSO THEN SO THE COURT REPORTER
WENT AWAY BUT YOU HAD SOMEONE
MONITORING EQUIPMENT THE HOW TO
E. R. MONITOR.
YOUR SUPERVISOR GOT TO BRING IN
ADDITIONAL CLERKS TO MANAGE THE
TRANSCRIPTS --
COLLECTING FEES FROM INDIVIDUALS
AND TRANSCRIPTS BECAUSE THAT'S
ALL DONE BY THE COURT REPORTER
OUTSIDE OF THE PUBLIC'S COST.
SO WE THINK THAT THE COURT
REPORTER IS HIGHLY EFFICIENT FOR
THE PUBLIC YOU'RE CERTAINLY THE
GOLD STANDARD --
AND ENSURES THAT EVERY INDIGENT.
INDIVIDUAL ACTUALLY GETS A
TRANSCRIPT WITH REGARD TO
INDIGENT LEADING.
THEY DON'T GET A TRANSCRIPT THEY
GET A DESK WITH THE RECORDING OF
THE PROCEEDINGS FROM THE ENTIRE
DAY AND THEN THEY HAVE TO GO OUT
INTO THE FREE MARKET AND FIND
SOMEBODY TO TRANSCRIBE THAT FOR
THEM.
THAT'S A VERY VERY EXPENSIVE I
PROBABLY COULD.
SO WE THINK THE COURT REPORTER
IS A GOLD STANDARD BECAUSE IT'S
BEEN PROVEN.
WE'VE SEEN WHAT'S HAPPENED WITH
ELECTRONIC RECORDING NVIDIA
REPORTING AND THEY DON'T WORK.
BUT THE BOTTOM LINE OF THIS ALL
GETS DOWN TO FUNDING I'M SURE OF
MISTER RODDY HAD MORE MONEY HE
COULD PROBABLY HIGHER HAVE A
MORE COMPETITIVE WAGE.
ATTRACT MORE PEOPLE AND I'M SURE
THAT'S WHAT OF COURSE WOULD WANT
BUT IT'S REALLY HARD BECAUSE NO
ONE REALLY WANTS TO ADEQUATELY
FUND THE SYSTEM OR EVEN GIVE
THEM THE APPROPRIATE ADJUSTMENTS
TO THEIR BUDGETS WITH THE COLA.
SO WITH THAT --
AND THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF MANY BY
NELSON ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF STATE COUNTY
MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES I THINK --
MY COLLEAGUES --
AND OUR MEMBERS I HAVE DONE A
PHENOMENAL JOB --
KIND OF DESCRIBING WHAT THE
CHALLENGES ARE --
AMONGST THE WORK FORCE A LIME
WORKERS WHO --
A MINISTER ENSURE ACCESS TO
JUSTICE IN THE STATE --
YOU'VE HEARD A NUMBER OF ISSUES --
AND I'LL BE INCREDIBLY PER BEST
ON BEST DISCRETIONARY FUNDS IN
OUR STATE WE AND IN OUR TRIAL
COURT SYSTEM WE HAVE UNDERSTOOD --
THE GAPS IN ACCESS TO JUSTICE AS
A RESULT OF THE CUTS THAT WE
EVEN TOURED --
OVER THE PAST DECADE A LONGER US
IMPORTANT TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE
CONTINUING --
TO PUT RESOURCES INTO THE WORK
FORCE -- I
WOULD ALSO --
ALIGN MYSELF WITH THE POINTS
THAT ARE MADE UP THAT HAVE BEEN
MADE ABOUT COURT REPORTERS --
IN PARTICULARLY A REFORM IN
REFORMING THE THE POINT I WAS
JUST MADE BY THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKER THAT THIS IS THE GOLD
STANDARD --
AND IN THIS STATE AND WE'VE
TAKEN ON SO MANY.
COMPLEX CHALLENGES ARE I DON'T
THINK THAT THIS IS THE TIME TO
RUSH TO OUTSOURCED WORK THAT'S
BEEN DONE --
BY DEDICATED --
MEMBERS OF OUR COURT COURT WORK
FORCE I THINK THIS PRECISELY THE
TIME TO ENGAGE OUR THE
LEGISLATURE PUT MONEY IN LAST
YEAR SPECIFICALLY FOR THE
PURPOSES WE DISCUSSED.
OF TRYING TO ENSURE THAT --
YOU KNOW WE DO --
OTHERS FEEL VALUE FOLKS TWO I
WANT TO PURSUE THE PROFESSION SO
I THINK THIS IS PRECISELY TOM
ADDRESS.
THE CHALLENGES THAT ARE
PREVENTING.
US FROM --
ENSURING THAT WE HAVE THE COURT
REPORTER WORK FORCE THAT WE NEED --
IN I WOULD ALSO AGREE THAT THIS
IS NOT A A CONVERSATION ABOUT A
SHORTAGE --
WE NEED TO JUST THINK CRITICALLY
ABOUT HOW WE SUPPORT THE WORK
FORCE -- I
WOULD ALSO OUT OF THE SUPPORT
POINTS THAT HAVE BEEN MADE ABOUT
TARGETING A RE INVESTMENTS WE'VE
BEEN DOING THAT FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS AND THIS COMMITTEE WHAT
WE'VE BEEN.
A REINVESTING IN SPECIFIC
PROGRAMS THAT WE KNOW ENSURE
ACCESS TO JUSTICE WE KNOW WE
DON'T HAVE THAT.
KIND OF LINE ITEM CONTROL FROM
THE LEGISLATURE --
OVER A SPECIFIC --
PROGRAMS OR SPECIFIC POSITIONS
THAT NEED --
INVESTMENT IN OUR COURT --
SO I WOULD.
ASK THIS COMMITTEE AS WE WILL BE
THE REQUEST WAS MADE ABOUT COURT
INVESTIGATORS THINK THEY PLAY A
CRITICAL ROLE --
AND DO THINK WE NEED TO TAKE A
LOOK AT OUR POSITIONS LIKE THIS
IN OUR COURT TO HAVE BEEN
GETTING OVERLOOKED --
IN -- GUESS
PAPER OF THE THE GLOBAL CRISIS
THAT HAS BEEN PRESENTED ON THE
COURSE IN FUNDING.
HI ELEMENT AND IN THE FINAL
POINT I'D RACES JUST TO SUPPORT
THE ARGUMENT ABOUT --
WANTING TO INCREASE COST OF
LIVING ARE WANTING TO ENSURE
THAT THIS FUNDING FOR COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTMENTS --
WE'VE HEARD --
MANY TIMES A NOT JUST THIS YEAR --
BUT ALMOST EVERY YEAR ABOUT --
THE FINANCIAL POSITION OF NOT
ONLY THE COURSE BUT ALSO THE
WORKERS AND THE COURT SO I THINK
IT'S CRITICALLY IMPORTANT AS A
STATE IF WE'RE GOING TO INVEST.
IN THE NARRATIVE AROUND ACCESS
TO JUSTICE THAT WE TAKE THE
NECESSARY STEPS AND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE --
CONTINUE TO IS THIS COMMITTEE
HAS -- IN
AND SHARE OUR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE HAVE I'VE DONE A
PHENOMENAL JOB I THINK OF ASKING
THE RIGHT QUESTIONS.
ABOUT -- ONE
INSURE THAT WE'RE ALL SOLUTIONS
THAT IMPROVE ACCESS TO JUSTICE
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AND WITH THAT WE WILL CONCLUDE
THIS ITEM.
AND WE'LL GO TO ITEM THREE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR COMING IN
SHARE AND WE APPRECIATE
ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO TRAVELED
FAR.
A MISTER RODDY.
I'M REALLY APPRECIATE SO WE'RE
GONNA GO TO ITEM THREE WITCHES%
ARE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE B. C.
P..
AND FOR THAT WE HAVE --
AGAIN ARE --
CHIEF FINANCIAL OFFICER BUDGET
SERVICES FOR THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL BUT ALSO --
MY COURTNEY WHO'S THE DIRECTOR
OF FACILITIES SERVICES FOR THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL YES THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU MIKE FOR COMING --
THE BUDGET PROPOSAL ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND AUGMENTATION OF
FORTY MILLION DOLLARS TO ADDRESS
THE MOST VITAL DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE NEEDS IN THE TRIAL
COURTS --
THESE FUNDS WILL SUPPORT FIRE
ALARM SYSTEMS REPAIR AND
REPLACEMENT WE THINK THE AGENDAS
BACKGROUND IN TERMS OF FUNDING
STRUCTURE AD IS A IS A GOOD
REFLECTION OF THE THE PROGRAM.
AND WE'RE HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS ON THAT YOU MAY HAVE
AS A AS RELATES TO THE PROPOSAL.
THIS.
IS A MIKE HORTON.
YES IT IS UNDER DID YOU.
I COURTNEY I'M FORTY AND MY
COURT.
DID YOU WANNA MAKE A
PRESENTATION SIR SURE OF COURSE
WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL FOR ANY
FUNDING REAL RELATED TO DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE.
OUR CURRENT BACKLOG OF DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE ACROSS THE STATE IS
NEARLY TWO POINT EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS --
THERE'S A COUPLE REASONS FOR
THAT FIRST WE HAVE A VERY.
OF FAST PORTFOLIO ACROSS THE
STATE -- OUR
OLDEST COURTHOUSE PULLS BACK TO
EIGHTEEN FIFTY FOUR IN MARIPOSA
COUNTY.
WOOD FRAME BUILDINGS STILL HAS A
WOOD FRAME STOVE IN IT STAY
LANDMARK IT IS IT'S A BEAUTIFUL
BUILDING ACTUALLY --
IN THERE.
OUR NEWEST COURTHOUSE --
SAN DIEGO COUNTY --
FROM LAST YEAR SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND SQUARE FEET.
YOU FOR BUILDING VERY MODERN --
THE AVERAGE AGE FOR PORTFOLIO IS
ABOUT FIFTY YEARS.
SO YOU CAN IMAGINE.
THE CONDUCT THE VARYING
CONDITIONS IN THE BILL
[inaudible]
PERSPECTIVE.
SECONDLY --
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE IS A DIRECT
RESULT OF NOT HAVING A FULLY
FUNDED.
PROGRAM --
WE SEE ABOUT A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR.
CURRENTLY FROM OF THE COURT
SOLELY TRUST ONE FOR MAINTENANCE.
THAT FUNDING HAS BEEN HAS HELD
AT THAT LEVEL SINCE.
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN A WHILE OUR
COSTS UTILITIES ALONE OF
INCREASED MORE THAN 12%.
WE'VE ALSO ADDED MORE THAN TWO
POINT NINE MILLION SQUARE FEET --
IN THE PORTFOLIO FORM FROM NEW
COURTHOUSE CONSTRUCTION AND WITH
NO ADDITIONAL FUNDS FOR
MAINTENANCE.
SO IF YOU IF YOU CAN'T MAINTAIN
YOUR BUILDINGS PROPERLY THEN YOU
OR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE WILL
INCREASE YOU YOU HAVE TO STOP.
MAINTAINING SOMETHING TO LIVE
WITHIN THE BUDGET FUNDS THAT YOU
THAT YOU HAVE.
WE NOW FOR THE MOST PART --
HAVE ADOPTED A RUN TO FAILURE.
MIND SET WITH OUR MAINTENANCE
PROGRAM CERTAIN PIECES OF
EQUIPMENT WE'VE JUST HAD TO STOP
MAINTAINING.
WHEN THEY BREAK THEY GET
REPLACED?
WE HAVE A SEPARATE FUNDING
SOURCE OF ABOUT SIXTY FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR TO DEAL
WITH OUR OWN.
REPAIRS TO BROKEN EQUIPMENT IN
OUR SO.
THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR THIS
CASE.
MAINTENANCE IS --
VERY MUCH APPRECIATED --
AS OF WHAT COKE INDICATED IT'S
FOR FIRE ALARM SYSTEMS.
IS A FOCUSED CURRENTLY ON
RENEWING OR REPLACING THE
SYSTEMS IN OUR HIGH RISE
BUILDINGS.
MOST OF THOSE BUILDINGS DATE
BACK TO THE SIXTIES.
AND SYSTEMS ARE ANTIQUATED.
BREAK CONSTANTLY.
RECENTLY WE HAD A FIRE ALARM
PANEL.
IN A COURTHOUSE IN SOUTHERN.
BELLE WE SPENT NEARLY MILLION
DOLLARS HAVE A FIRE WATCH
[inaudible]
WELL [inaudible]
LACED [inaudible] FOR WE DO HERE.
TO MITIGATE THAT.
IS -- WILL
REALLY HELP US.
YOU ANY COMMENTS FROM DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE --
A I NEED EARLIER THE DEPART --
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE.
AREN'T WE HAVE NO CONCERNS WITH
THE REQUESTED AMOUNT WE DO
RECOMMEND THAT THE LEGISLATURE
ADOPTS SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING
LANGUAGE IN TWO DIFFERENT WAYS.
ON THE FIRST SET OF RECOMMENDED
LANGUAGE WOULD REQUIRE THAT THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH REPORT NO LATER
THAN JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY THREE ON HOW THE
DEFERRED BAT --
BACKLOG HAS CHANGED --
TO THE EXTENT THE BACKLOG ROSE
THE LANGUAGE REQUIRE THEM TO
REPORT ON THE REASONS FOR THAT
GROWTH AND WHAT STEPS ARE BEING
TAKEN TO ADDRESS IT.
AND THIS WILL REALLY HELP THE
LEGISLATURE MONITOR THE ACTUAL
ROUTINE ACTIVITY MAINTENANCE
ACTIVITIES THAT ARE GOING ON
AGAINST ACTUAL NEED.
AND DETERMINE WHAT ACTIONS IF
ANY NEED TO BE MADE ON AN
ONGOING BASIS.
THE SECOND SET OF LANGUAGE WOULD
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE TO REPORT NO LATER THAN
JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY THREE ON THE
ACTUAL PROJECTS THAT ARE
SUPPORTED USING THIS MONEY AND
THIS WILL HELP THE LEGISLATURE
ENSURE THAT THE FUNDS ARE USED
ACCOUNT OF LEE AND CONSISTENT
WITH LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES --
THE REBEL ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS OF WHEN THE
CONSTRUCTION AND MAINTENANCE
FUNDS THAT YOU HAVE.
AND ONE OF THE ONES I WAS
QUESTIONING WAS THOUGH.
THE COURT FACILITIES
CONSTRUCTION FUN WHERE YOU'RE
DRAWING DOWN SO.
FUNDS FOR VARIOUS PROJECTS
[inaudible]
AND IT SAYS THAT THE IT'S GOING
TO CONTINUE AT A CERTAIN LEVEL
FOR A CERTAIN NUMBER OF YEARS
THAT'S GONNA DROP.
AND WHAT IS THE I ALSO.
HOW HOW DO YOU --
THE TERM IN.
ABOUT THAT BUT PLAN TO YOU. ONE
OF THE RESPONSE SO YOU CAN YOU
GIVE ME THE IDEA WHERE THE MONEY
COMES.
IT'S LIKE GOING OVER THE
DIFFERENT FUNDS IN TERMS OF THE
INSTANT CENTER FROM ADDED THE
SCS YOU HAVE TO STATE COURT.
SO THIS CONSTRUCTION FUND --
THAT --
FUNDING THOSE LEVELS WERE
PURSUANT TO A BUDGET CHANGE
PROPOSAL THAT WAS SUBMITTED AND
SO IS A MULTI YEAR ASPECT OF IT
IN TERMS OF THAT FUNDING AND SO
THAT WAS WHAT WAS OR IS THE
BUDGET CHANGE PROPOSAL.
I KNOW I WOULD SAY IS THAT IN
THE PAST WE'VE REQUESTED A
GENERAL FUND RESOURCES TO
SUPPORT OUR PROGRAMS.
BUT GIVEN THE THE FISCAL
CONSTRAINTS OF THE STATE THE THE
APPROVALS WERE OUT OF THESE
FUNDS --
THESE REVENUES BOTH IN THE
MEDIANCRITICAL NEED ACCOUNT AND
THE THE S. S. C. F. ARE A
COMBINATION OF CRIMINAL FEES AND
CIVIL FILING FEES --
AND SO THEY'RE NOT STATE GENERAL
FUND RESOURCES THEY ARE IN
EFFECT TO THOSE WHO ARE ENGAGING
IN THE SYSTEM --
SUPPORTING THESE TWO FUNDS A
YEAH I MEAN BE WILLING OR
UNWILLING.
AS THE CASE MAY BE --
AND SO WE HAVE SPECIFIC
APPROPRIATIONS --
FOR THESE DIFFERENT NEEDS
BECAUSE THERE ARE DIFFERENT --
EXPENDITURES FOR EXAMPLE FROM
THE STATE COURT FACILITIES
CONSTRUCTION FIND SO THERE'S NO
TORY EXPENDED --
GRAHAM DIED IN ITS REFLECT.
THOSE FUNDS --
I BELIEVE I'M GOING TO GET YOU
IN TERMS OF THE AND I CAN HAVE
MY CAT MIKE --
EXPLAINED YOU SORT OF THE THE
GENERAL EXPENDITURES THAT ARE
MADE OUT OF THE FUNDS.
IT DRIED OUT FUNDS FROM
DIFFERENT SOURCES OR RIGHT.
WANT TO SEE HOW THE LORD WITH --
LOOKS LIKE --
THE MADE ITS.
CORD BASINS CONSTRUCTION PHONE.
AS FOR RE PRIMARY USES THAT
SERVICE FOR WHAT WAS KNOWN AS
THE US BE SEVENTEEN THIRTY TWO
GRAHAM CONSTRUCTED NUMBER
COURTHOUSES --
THE FORTY MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
FOR REPAIRS TO BUILDINGS.
AND THEN OUT ALSO FUNDS THE
BASICS ALREADY IN OPERATION OF
THE FACILITIES A DIVISION OF THE
JEWS APARTMENT IN THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL.
AND THE BRANCH.
AND THEN WE ALSO GET FUNDING FOR
BUILDING REPAIRS OUT OF THE
IMMEDIATE CRITICAL NEEDS ACCOUNT.
WHICH IS EXCLUSIVELY USE FOR
THAT SERVICE IN THE US BE
FORTINO SEVEN PROGRAM AND THEN
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR FOR REPAIRS.
OKAY SO --
WHAT OTHER MADE ITS FUNDS TO
HAVE?
DROVE.
ONE THE STAKE CONTRIBUTE.
WHO IS A VERY SMALL AMOUNT OF
GENERAL PHONE?
OF THAT.
GOES INTO THE MAINTENANCE BUDGET.
THINK IT'S LESS THAN EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR.
AND THAT'S A BELIEVE WHAT'S SO
SHE HATED WITH JUDGESHIP
[inaudible]
PREVIOUSLY ON WHAT ARE THE
BOUNCES.
THE COURT FACILITIES TRUST FUND
WE EXPAND THAT'S THE MAIN MAIN
BUDGET.
WE EXPAND TO THE WOMEN ALMOST
EVERY YEAR THIS YEAR WE HAD A
CARRYOVER OF ABOUT FIVE MILLION.
AND THAT'S IN OUR EXPENDITURE
PLAN.
YEAH AND IN TERMS OF THE THE AND
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
EXPENDITURES AN APPROPRIATION
THE THE REVENUES ARE BEING
DEPLETED --
QUITE PRECIPITOUSLY IN THE STATE
COURT FACILITIES CONSTRUCTION
FUN AND THAT AND WHILE WE
CURRENTLY HAVE AN ESTIMATE OF
ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY MILLION
DOLLARS THE FUND BALANCE.
A GIVEN THE DRAWS IN THE REVENUE
IN BALANCE --
WE'RE PROJECTING AN INSOLVENCY
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR AND SO
WE WILL BE --
NEEDING SOME SOLUTIONS AS A
STATE.
FEES OR REVENUES.
WERE EXAMINING THEM IN FOR A NO
AS A THE ISSUE IS ARE IN MANY.
YEAH I MEAN FOR EXAMPLE WHEN YOU
TALK ABOUT THE CRIMINAL FEES
YOU'LL YOU'LL HAVE HEARD
THROUGHOUT THE THE LAST FEW
YEARS THOSE ARE DECLINING WE ARE
NO NO DIFFERENT THE A AND M. AND
FEELING THOSE IMPACTS.
I'M IN SO THEY'LL DEFINITELY
NEED TO BE --
SOLUTION AGAIN GIVEN THE
CRITICALITY OF THE THE REVENUES
MEETING THAT SERVICE AND AND
MAINTAINING AN AND MANAGING THE
FACILITIES THE MEDIAN CRITICAL
NEEDS ACCOUNT --
HAS A CURRENT BALANCE OF SORRY
HOLD EACH. THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS BUT AND THAT AS ALSO
DECLINING REVENUE --
BUT THAT'S NOT ANTICIPATED TO BE --
HAVE A SOLVENCY ISSUE AND FOR
THE NEXT --
BUT ON YOURS.
THE USE OF THAT THESE ARE NOT
THESE OF FOR THE DEBT SERVICE
THOSE ARE ALREADY PROJECTS THAT
HAVE BEEN COMPLETED.
WE WERE VERY GRATEFUL AND
THANKFUL THAT THIS LEGISLATURE
IN ADMINISTRATION.
MOVED --
KNEW OF MECHANISM TO FIND OUR
CAPITAL PROGRAMS IN TERMS OF
COURTHOUSE CONSTRUCTION AND SO
I'M TEN PROJECTS WERE APPROVED
IN THIS MOST RECENT BUDGET --
TO BE FUNDED FROM DEBT SERVICE
FUNDED BY THE GENERAL FUND
[inaudible]
STEADY.
NO FOR THE AND FOR THESE
PROGRAMS OF THEIR OF THEIR
FAIRLY STEADY IT'S THE ISSUE OF
THE AVAILABLE REVENUES IN THE
STRUCTURE THAT WAS CREATED --
TO FUND THESE PROGRAMS AND
THROUGH THE TWO BILLS THAT DID
THAT -- SOME
[inaudible]
OF IF YOU WOULD LIKE MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE BALANCES --
WHERE WOULD YOUR REVENUES VERSUS
EXPENDITURES IS A LITTLE OFF
[inaudible]
THE CLIENT.
RIGHT THAT LOSS EVERY YEAR
CORRECT.
WE CAN WE CAN PROVIDE YOU THE
LONG -- TO
YOU HAVE A TWO POINT EIGHT
BILLION. FOR ME THAT'S YOU TODAY
TELL US.
HOW MUCH MONEY YOU NEED TO KEEP
THEIR FROM GROWING?
TREAD WATER NUMBER I CALLED. FOR
ME YOU KNOW THIS IS A CALL TO
TREAD WATER ANOTHER WORDS.
YOUR YOUR DARKEST SINKING WHICH
ARE NOT.
WHAT IS THAT NUMBER?
RIGHT ANSWERS CENTERS WE HAVE A
WE DO B. C. P. THAT IS.
ADDRESS TODAY THAT IS A HOSE OR
MAINTENANCE FUNDING.
THAT WILL GO A LONG WAY --
TO HELP.
IMPROVE THE LEVEL OF MAINTENANCE
ON A RECORDER.
SO ANYTHING WE CAN DO TO IMPROVE
THAT THAT BE CBS FOR FORTY
MILLION CORRECT. ONE THERE'S ONE
THIRTY TWO PROPOSALS IN THE
BUDGET WHEN IS THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE FOR FORTY MILLION
WHICH WOULD BE A ONE TIME
INCREASE FOR THOSE CRITICAL --
FIRE ALARM SYSTEMS AND
REPLACEMENT HOWEVER THERE'S AN
ONGOING --
PROPOSAL FOR TWENTY POINT ONE
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS THAT WOULD --
HELP US ON OUR MAINTENANCE GOING
FORWARD IS WHAT --
MR COURTNEY'S REFERRING TO SO
THIS TREAD WATER NUMBER.
IT IS YOUR AGENTS THE BACKLOG
GONNA GROW WITHOUT ERRORS.
THE BACKLOG WILL STILL INCREASE
OKAY WHAT'S THE NUMBER --
FOUR BACKLOG.
NOT A CHRISTIAN YOU HAVE AN IDEA --
I'D HAVE TO GET BACK TO YOU OKAY
LISTLESS LOOK IT UP I JUST
WONDER FOR PURPOSES OF THAT
CREATES A CLARITY FOR ME ABOUT.
WHAT'S GOING ON AND I HAVE A
QUESTION FOR THE ILLEGAL.
OF WHAT'S THE REASON THAT --
CAN YOU EXPLAIN THE THE
REPORTING LANGUAGE --
THAT YOU'RE SUGGESTING THAT
TWENTY TWENTY THREE DATE WHAT
WAS THE REASON FOR THE THE
REASON WHY SOME OTHER DATA
EARLIER THIS.
SURE IT PROVIDES A THEY HAVE A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF TIME TO USE
THE DOLLARS TO THE DOLLARS WON'T
NECESSARILY ALL BE EXPENDED IN.
TWENTY NINETEEN AND SO THE DATE
OF TWENTY TWENTY THREE IS NO
LATER IF THEY COMPLETE THE
PROJECTS EARLIER AND THEY WANT
TO SUBMIT A REPORT EARLIER IT'S
A NO LATER THAT DAY.
I I'M I'M TRYING NO.
WELL WHAT I'M TRYING TO DO IS
FIGURE OUT WHAT I NEED IF I CAN.
GET THE MARK WHERE I CAN --
STOP THE BLEEDING IF YOU WANT TO
CALL IT ON THEM THE MAID NEXT.
I DON'T LIKE LOOKING FOR A
NUMBER.
KNOW WHERE I CAN --
I COULD LOOK AT THAT YOU KNOW I
DON'T KNOW IF WE'LL BE ABLE TO
DO ANYTHING ABOUT IT NOW BUT WE
WANT.
TO HELPS ME WHEN I ANALYZE A
BUDGET.
ON MAINTENANCE --
WHAT NUMBER WOULD BE SO I CAN --
ATTACK IT ATTACK THE PROBLEM
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ENTER MORE LUCK THE MANAGER JUST
HAD ONE QUESTION FOR MS LEE AND
THAT IS.
ARE YOUR RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
THESE REPORTS ARE YOU ARE YOU
DOING THIS JUST FOR THIS
INSTANCE REFER ALL DEPARTMENTS.
FOR ALL DEPARTMENTS --
WE ARE TAILORING OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR EACH OF THE
BC PIECE THAT YOU'LL BE HEARING
SO TO GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE.
THE JUDICIAL BRANCH SPECIFICALLY
IDENTIFIED WHAT PROJECTS THEY
WOULD FIND IN THIS REQUEST AND
AND WALKED US THROUGH AND AND
HAND CAN ARTICULATE THEIR
PRIORITIZATION METHODOLOGY FOR
SOME OF THE OTHER DEPARTMENTS.
SOME OF THAT INFORMATION IS
LACKING AND SO WHEN THOSE BCP'S
ARE HEARD THOSE ARE ADDITIONAL
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR EXAMPLE THAT
WOULD BE OFFERED BUT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE ARE
RECOMMENDING CONSISTENT ACROSS
ALL DEPARTMENTS THAT HAVE TO FOR
ME.
YOU THINK YOU MENTION
[inaudible]
CERTAINLY [inaudible]
RIGHT -- GO
AHEAD CENTER.
IF YOU BUILD A NEW BUILDING IS
THAT A THAT THE PROBABLY
WOULDN'T BECAUSE AT STAKE IS
THAT RIGHT RIGHT.
SO YOU'RE REALLY CREATING A
BRAND NEW.
IN CENTER TO THE EXTENT THAT.
YOU COURTHOUSE WOULD PLACE ONE
ARM OLD AGING COURTHOUSES THEN
THAT.
WOULD COME OFF THE BOOKS SO WHEN
YOU CALCULATE THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE.
TRACK THE ARE YOU REDUCE THE
COST BY.
FACT THE FACILITY.
OF THIS FREEDOM MAY NOT.
THAT'S CORRECT WE WOULD TAKE OLD
BUILDING OUT OF THE OUT OF THE
SYSTEM.
FOLLOWING UP ON THAT WHAT YOU
MIGHT BE HELPFUL TO US TO KNOW I
MEAN GIVEN THAT THERE ARE.
I'M SURE THEY'RE ALREADY PLANS
IN SOME JURISDICTIONS.
TO I'M I KNOW IT'S NOT A LOT BUT
TO BUILD NEW COURTHOUSES OR TO
ACQUIRE [inaudible]
I'M.
WE COULD HAVE SOME SENSE OF HOW
THAT WOULD AFFECT THAT BACKLOG
BECAUSE IF WE'RE JUST READING
THIS BACKLOG IS SOMETHING WE
MUST FUND VERSUS SOMETHING THAT.
WOULD BE REDUCED WHEN.
A NEW COURT.
BUILDING WAS --
PROCEEDED WITH WHICH MAY ALREADY
BE PLANNED.
FOR THAT HELPS US IN TERMS OF
CALCULATING THOSE TYPES OF
DECISIONS.
SO I THINK THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL
FOR US TO HAVE ALSO AND PERHAPS
ILIO IN YOUR RECOMMENDATIONS
AROUND.
ON HOW WE WHAT WE ASK THEM TO
IDENTIFY THAT COULD BE INCLUDED.
HIS FACTOR IN DETERMINING THE
COST [inaudible]
I'M.
RIGHT ADDITIONALLY --
CLEARLY THERE ARE LOTS OF
DEMANDS ON OUR FOR ONE TIME ONLY
FUNDS.
BUT GIVEN THAT WE ARE IN A TIME.
OF HIGHER REVENUES.
HI REVENUES THAT WE DON'T
NECESSARILY WANT TO START
[inaudible]
APPROPRIATING.
IN A IN A GUARANTEED ON GOING
TYPE BASIS.
HAS THE ARM JUDICIAL COUNCIL
LOOKED AT ALL --
AROUND IN CENTERING SOME AMOUNT
OF ONE TIME ONLY FUNDS TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE BACKLOG.
OUTSIDE OF THE BUDGET LEVELS OF
REPOSE I THINK AND SENATOR BELLS
QUESTION ABOUT WHAT MIGHT BE A
DIFFERENT SORT OF ARE THERE MORE
OPTIONS AND ALSO WITHIN WHAT
MIGHT BE THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE NEEDS GOING FORWARD
I THINK THERE'S PROBABLY SOME.
MIX OF ADDITIONAL ONE TIME --
AND THEN LESSENING THE ONGOING
NEED.
BUT IN TERMS OF YOUR QUESTION I
JUST WANTED TO RESPOND AS FAR AS
WHETHER NOT NEW CONSTRUCTION
MATTERS ON OUR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE --
PART OF YOUR BUDGET TRAILER
BILLING WHICH IS REQUIRING AN
ASSESSMENT OR REASSESSMENT OF
ALL OF OUR FACILITIES AND IN IN
THE EVALUATION OF THOSE NEW
FACILITY NEEDS WE ARE LOOKING AT
THE IMPACT ON OUR ON OUR MAIN
IT'S NEAT [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
THAT.
WE THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WHEN
YOU GO TO OUR NEXT ITEM --
SO WE'RE NOW --
ON ISSUE [inaudible]
FOR THE COURT [inaudible]
PROCEEDINGS PROPOSAL
[inaudible]
AND THE RIGHT SO WE HAVE JOINED
AT THE TABLE --
DON WILL WHO IS THE MANAGER AT
THE CENTER FOR FAMILIES CHILDREN
IN THE COURTS FOR THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL DID I GET THAT CORRECT.
ALRIGHT SO WHO WOULD LIKE TO
START A DAY IN IN BRIEF --
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THE THE
BUDGET PROPOSES A TWENTY MILLION
DOLLAR INCREASE --
AND ONGOING FOR THIS PART THE
COURT APPOINTED DEPENDENCY
COUNCIL AND WORKLOAD AND THIS IS
ON TOP OF A RECENT --
INCREASES OF THIRTY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS OF WHICH WE ARE
YOU KNOW VERY THANKFUL AND WE
ARE VERY MUCH APPRECIATIVE OF
THE TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS AS
PROPOSED IN THE BUDGET.
AS IT WILL ALLOW US TO MAKE
PROGRESS TOWARDS THE THE TWO AND
SEVEN MILLION DOLLAR DOWN THE
FIGHT NEED --
FOR THIS PROGRAM.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO THE AND
THE BENEFITS THAT IT WILL --
PROVIDE IN TERMS OF REDUCED --
CLIENT -- TO
ATTORNEY RATIOS IN THIS AREA AND
WE ARE HAVE HERE AS YOU SAID AND
DONE WELL TO RESPOND TO THE
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE PROGRAM THAT
YOU MAY HAVE.
BEFORE WE GO TO THAT BUT THE
ITEM ALSO DESCRIBES THAT THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL [inaudible]
I'M.
ITSELF IS DESCRIBED THAT THE
TWENTY MILLION INCREASE
[inaudible]
REPRESENTS. 76% OF THE FUNDING
NEED AS DETERMINED BY THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL CAN YOU TALK A
BIT ABOUT THAT.
SO EITHER THE **** TALK ABOUT
DISCERNING COUNTRY INTRICACIES
OF THE THE THE THE MATH THERE.
A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL --
ESTABLISH THE WORKLOAD BASED.
ON THE MODEL FOR THE PENDENCY
COUNCIL.
WHICH TAKES INTO --
WHICH ASSETS A CASELOAD STANDARD
OF A HUNDRED AND FORTY ONE
DEPENDENCY ATTORNEY SAID SAY --
MEDIAN STATE SALARY AND THEN
USES ECONOMIC ACTORS AND THE
CURRENT CHILD WELFARE CASE
LOADING.
BORN IN THE CURRENT RATE OF
DEPENDENCY FILINGS AND COURTS IN
CALIFORNIA WITH THAT WHAT IS
REQUIRED.
TO YOU HAVE ENOUGH ATTORNEYS TO
SERVE ALL THE KIDS.
WHO NEEDED TOURNEY'S AT A
CASELOAD OF? FORTY ONE HER
ATTORNEY.
AND THAT --
THIS YEAR COMES TO TWO HUNDRED
AND SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
AND THE AMOUNT THAT --
AS YOU SEE THAT WE HAVE.
THE END IS ABOUT --
THE SIX POINT. 76% OF THE TOTAL
FUNDING [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
I'M [inaudible]
COLLEAGUES QUESTION.
WENT TO THE TO THE LEVEL
RECOMMENDED BE ABOUT FIFTY
MILLION OR ABOVE THE THAT'S KIND
OF WHAT THE NUMBER.
IS ABOUT.
FIFTY SO THAT WOULD GIVE US THE
ONE FORTY ONE NOW.
HOW MUCH FLUCTUATIONS IS THE
CASELOAD?
HOW MUCH FLUCTUATION THIS OR
THAT?
YOUR BODY OR IS IT.
THAT IS IT [inaudible]
OF HOWEVER EACH COUNTY IT'S
FAIRLY.
OVER THE LAST DECADE --
GOING UP.
FOR THAT ALANIZ FLUCTUATE BUT
COUNCILS MODEL WITH --
SHIFT ALLOCATIONS OF FOR
COUNTIES CASELOAD ONE COUNTY
GOES UP AND ONE GOES DOWN
[inaudible]
YEAH.
SO IS FIFTY MILLION SHORT
[inaudible]
BASICALLY THE THE TARGET. ONE
BASED ON THAT.
BASED ON A HUNDRED FORTY ONE
CLIENTS PER ATTORNEY
[inaudible]
I'M.
QUESTION I HAVE IS.
YOU KNOW IN OUR PREVIOUS --
ITEMS.
OF WHAT WE UNDERSTAND IS THAT.
WHILE WE MAY ALLOCATE MONEY.
THAT THE PERSONAL OR NOT
NECESSARILY ALWAYS HIRED.
IT'S SO WHAT I'M WONDERING IS.
DO WE CURRENTLY HAVE.
THE ATTORNEYS NEEDED FOR THE
GIVEN ME.
AUGMENTATION OR NOT GIVEN THE
FINES THAT HAVE BEEN
APPROPRIATED YOU OUT FOR THIS
PURPOSE ARE THEY FULLY BEING
UTILIZED. FOR THIS PURPOSE YES.
THEY ARE RESTRICTED.
THE TENNESSEE COUNCIL WHO.
COURT.
AND AND SO YEAH.
WE ARE SPENDING ALL THE MONEY
OKAY AND THERE'S NOT BEEN A
SHORTAGE OF ATTORNEYS OR THERE'S
NOT NOT FACE THAT SORT OF HING
TOO WHEN THE WHEN THE WHEN WE
RECEIVE THE AUGMENTATION.
THE COURTS AND THE ATTORNEY FIRM
A LITTLE WHILE TO CATCH UP AND
RECRUIT NEW RETURN BUT WE DON'T
LITTLE WHILE BEING HOW ABOUT
WHAT. SIX MONTHS YEAH NINE
MONTHS.
THAT'S ABOUT RIGHT SO THE FIRST
YEAR WE WERE.
A LITTLE UNDER TOTAL SPENDNG
AND AFTER THAT THE COURTS CADA
AND THE ATTORNEY FIRM SO THERE
DOESN'T SEEM TO BE.
SUPPLY PROBLEM THAT PERSPECTIVE.
SO IF FOR EXAMPLE WE WERE
ESSENTIALLY DO AUGMENTED BY A
FULL SEVENTY MILLION MORE.
IT WOULD TAKE YOU.
I'M MAKING AN ASSUMPTION HERE
YOU CAN CORRECT ME A LONGER
PERIOD OF TIME THAN TO REALLY.
THE RAMP UP --
I AM NOT SURE BECAUSE MOST OF
THE MONEY.
AND MOST OF THE CASES ARE IN
LARGE URBAN AREAS.
AND I THINK THAT --
AND THERE'S SERVED BY LARGER
STREAM WE COMPETENT FIRMS.
SO I REALLY THINK THAT THE POPE
WOULD BE VERY FAST.
ALL RIGHT BEFORE I ASK FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT ARE THERE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS THAT MEMBERS
WANT TO MAKE ON THIS
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
I'M.
I'M SURE IF I MAY ASK HER YOU
FINANCE --
AMAZON OR DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
I JUST WANT TO STATE THAT --
THE ADMINISTRATION UNDERSTANDS
THE IMPORTANCE OF FUNDING
DEPENDENCY COUNCIL WHICH IS BY
THE BUDGET INCLUDES A TWO ON
GOING TWENTY MILLION INVESTMENT --
IN THE QUARTER POINT IN THESE
ATTORNEYS --
I DO WANT TO KNOW --
YOU KNOW IN DECEMBER WE RECENTLY
FOUND OUT THAT DEPENDENCY
COUNCILS ELIGIBLE FOR TITLE
FORTY FUNDING --
AND SO THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES AS WELL AS THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL HAS BEEN WORKING
TOGETHER. TO MAKE SURE THE STATE
CAN.
I AND YOU KNOW THIS FUNDING CAN
HELP REIMBURSE 50% OF
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS FOR
ATTORNEYS --
AND SO WE'RE HOPING THAT CAN
HELP SUPPLEMENT OUR INVESTMENT
IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET.
WELL WHEN WE MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT THERE MAY BE SOME ISSUES AS
TO WHETHER THAT FEDERAL FUNDING
WOULD BE. TO BRING US UP TO SAY
THE FULL FIFTY MILLION
AUGMENTATION.
SO IN OTHER WORDS THE ADDITIONAL.
TWENTY FROM THE TWENTY MILLION
YOU'RE RECOMMENDING ON GOING.
ON AND SO WHEN WE RIGHT NOW
WE'RE HOLDING THIS ITEM OPEN BUT
WHEN WE REVISIT IT IF THERE
COULD BE A LITTLE MORE --
WE CAN GET MORE INFORMATION
ABOUT THAT A LITTLE MORE
ASSESSMENT AS TO HOW MUCH WE CAN.
A POTENTIALLY RELY ON THAT
[inaudible]
WELL THERE [inaudible]
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT --
PUBLIC COMMENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AGAIN LESLIE
HI MY FROM CHILDREN'S LAW CENTER
OF CALIFORNIA --
AND WE ONE OF START BY
ACKNOWLEDGING AND APPRECIATING
THE TWENTY MILLION THAT WAS PUT
INTO THE JANUARY BUDGET AS WELL
AS THE PREVIOUS.
INCREASES --
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN AND TWENTY
SEVENTEEN BUT ALSO WANT TO
REITERATE AS THE AS MADAME CHAIR
AS YOU NOTED THAT.
IN TODAY AND IS IS NOTED IN
TODAY'S ANALYSIS THAT UNTIL WE
REACH THE TWO HUNDRED AND SEVEN
MILLION THAT WAS RECOMMENDED
BASED ON THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
FORMULA.
WE CONTINUE TO BE SEVERELY
UNDERSTAFFED WITH AND I CARRY
VERY IGH CASELOADS AND WOULD
ALSO NOTE THAT THE HUNDRED AND
FORTY ONE CLIENTS PER ATTORNEY
WE SEE IT AS I'M NOT AS A GOLD
STANDARD OR OR AS THE DESIRED
CASELOAD --
BUT IT'S CONSIDERED TO BE THE
MAXIMUM THAT ONE ATTORNEY CAN
MANAGE WITH --
APPROPRIATE MULTI DISCIPLINARY
SUPPORT STAFF AND IT IS EXAMPLE
TO HELP YOU MAYBE THINK ABOUT
WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE.
WE HAVE A GRANT FUNDED PROJECT
WHERE WE SERVE SOME OF OUR MOST
COMPLEX CLIENTS WHICH YOUR
CHILDREN HAVE ALSO BEEN ARRESTED
AND ARE INVOLVED WITH THE CHURCH
THE DELINQUENCY COURT SYSTEM.
AND WE STAFF THAT PROJECT WITH
SIX TWO ATTORNEYS AND FOR CASE
MANAGERS WHO SERVE BETWEEN THEM
SIXTY CLIENTS AT ANY GIVEN TIME
OBVIOUSLY MUCH SMALLER RATIOS
THAN WHAT OUR STATE FUNDING
COULD EVER ALLOW.
FOR BUT AS A RESULT OF THAT
INTENSITY OF THE INTENSIVE
SERVICES THAT ARE PROVIDED TO
THOSE CHILDREN WE HAVE VIRTUALLY
ELIMINATED THE FOSTER CARE TO
PRISON PIPELINE FOR THOSE SIXTY
CHILDREN WE HAVE ONE CHILD IN
THREE YEARS WHO WENT INTO ADULT.
THE INTO THE ADULT CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM WHICH IS
REMARKABLE WE THINK --
IN ONLY TWO THAT FOUND
THEMSELVES IN CAMPS 86%
COMPLETED HIGH SCHOOL ARE THERE
IN HIGH SCHOOL OR HAVE COMPLETED
HIGH SCHOOL AND ALL OF THE
GRADUATES ARE WORKING OR IN
COLLEGE.
WHICH IS REMARKABLE AS I SAID
FOR YOUTH WHO ARE DEEPLY
INVOLVED WITH BOTH THE CHILD
WELFARE AND THE JUVENILE JUSTICE
SYSTEM.
THERE'S SO MUCH THAT WE LEARNED
IN THE PAST FIVE AND THAT WE ARE
POISED TO IMPLEMENT IN ALL OF
OUR PROGRAMS STATEWIDE --
MANY OF HER PROGRAMS --
BUT WE CAN'T WITHOUT ADDITIONAL
STAFFING AND WITHOUT THE FUNDS
TO NOT ONLY HIRE LAWYERS BUT TO
ALSO HIRED THE MULTI
DISCIPLINARY STAFF THAT GO ALONG
WITH THAT.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO ADDRESS A
COUPLE OF THE POINTS THAT YOU
RAISED DURING THE QUESTIONING --
THE FIRST BEING OVERALL NUMBERS
AND WHILE WE AGREE THAT WE
GENERALLY HOWEVER AT A AT A
STABLE CASELOAD THERE'S RESEARCH
FROM THE CHILDREN'S DATA NETWORK
AT USC --
THAT PROJECTS IN ON A STEADY A
SLOW BUT STEADY INCREASE IN THE
CHILD WELFARE POPULATION.
IN THE COMING YEARS --
AND THAT'S BASED ON VERY COMPLEX
LONGITUDINAL STUDIES AND
ASSESSMENTS OF STATE DATA COUNTY
DATA.
AND SO ON AND IS THE CHILDREN'S
DATA NETWORK IS AT USC AS I SAID
AND IS DEDICATED TO STUDYING
CHILD WELFARE ON AND MAY HAVE
PUSHED PROVIDED SOME RESEARCH ON
THAT.
WITH REGARD TO HIRING WELL WE
DON'T HAVE THE OVERALL SUPPLY
PROBLEM THAT WE HEARD ABOUT
EARLIER THERE ARE SOME POCKETS
NORTHERN AND RURAL COUNTIES
WHERE IT SOME WHERE A SINGLE
POSITION MAY REMAIN.
VACANT FOR A PERIOD OF TIME BUT
WE SOLUTION TO THAT IN TERMS OF
THE BUDGET INCREASE BECAUSE THE
ISSUE IS NOT THAT THE ATTORNEYS
DON'T EXIST BUT THE VAGUE THERE
ARE WAGES ARE NOT COMPETITIVE.
SO THE INCREASE AND THE WORK AND
THE PROSPECT OF TAKING ON AN
OVERWHELMING CASELOAD SCARES
PEOPLE AWAY WROTE REALISTICALLY.
SO WE DO BELIEVE THAT THE
AUGMENTATION --
WILL SOLVE THAT PROBLEM
SIGNIFICANTLY --
WHEN MR WELL SPOKE ABOUT THE
LARGE URBAN AREAS WHERE WE ARE
POISED TO GO I'M PRETTY SURE
HOUZZ MOSTLY TALKING ABOUT MY
ORGANIZATION --
CLC REPRESENTS OVER ALMOST HALF
THE CHILDREN IN THE WHOLE STATE --
AND WE HAVE RIGHT NOW.
200- FULL TIME ATTORNEYS OVER
FOUR HUNDRED AND FORTY STAFF
BETWEEN OUR THREE COUNTIES --
AND WE ARE ABSOLUTELY READY TO
GO AND BECAUSE OF THE INCREASE
IS I WOULD SAY IN THE PAST FEW
YEARS WE LEARNED VERY QUICKLY
WHAT WE NEEDED TO DO WE HIRED --
CLOSE TO FORTY ATTORNEYS --
WITH THE RECENT INCREASES AS
WELL AS SUPPORT STAFF TO GO
ALONG WITH THAT AND WERE ABLE TO
CREATE OUR SPECIALIZED
COLLABORATIVE UNIT.
SO WE HAVE A LOT OF MIDDLE
MANAGERS THAT ARE VERY READY TO
MOVE UP IN A LOT OF SENIOR
ATTORNEYS THAT ARE VERY READY
ALSO TO TAKE ON THOSE ADDITIONAL
RESPONSIBILITIES.
AND AGAIN IF WE CAN ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS HAPPY.
HELLO I AM A IN WITH EAST BAY
FAMILY DEFENDERS THAT WE ARE THE
NEW LEGAL REPRESENTATION
PROVIDER IN ALAMEDA COUNTY FOR
ALL CHILDREN ALL I'M SORRY ALL
PARENTS AND SOME CHILDREN WITH
OPEN CHILD WELFARE CASES.
WE LAUNCHED OUR ORGANIZATION IN
SEPTEMBER OF LAST YEAR AT A
HISTORIC LOW IN STATE FUNDING.
AND WE LAUNCHED IT BECAUSE WE
WERE REALLY INSPIRED --
BY EIGHT EIGHT SUBSTANTIAL AND
GROWING BODY OF RESEARCH THAT
DEMONSTRATES THAT INVESTMENT IN
HIGH QUALITY REPRESENTATION FOR
FAMILIES AND DEPENDENCY COURT
ADVANCES THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEMS GOALS.
OF INSURING CHILD SAFETY --
MEN'S AND WELLBEING
SPECIFICALLY RESEARCH
DEMONSTRATED THAT HIGH QUALITY
REPRESENTATION FOR CHILDREN AND
PARENTS IN THESE PROCEEDINGS
REDUCES SAFELY REDUCES RELIANCE
ON FOSTER CARE.
SHORTENS THE STAYS THE OLDER IN
IN FOSTER CARE PROMOTES SAFER
UNIFICATION TIMELY REUNIFICATION
OF CHILDREN WITH THEIR FAMILIES.
AND OTHER PERMANENT GOALS SUCH
AS GUARDIANSHIP AND ADOPTION.
AND RESULTS IN LONG TERM COST
SAVINGS TO THE STATE BECAUSE OF
THE REDUCED RELIANCE ON POSSIBLY
OUT OF HOME PLACEMENT.
IN ADDITION IT IMPROVES THE
RELIABILITY AND ACCURACY OF
INFORMATION PROVIDED TO JUDGES
WHEN THEY MAKE LIFE CHANGING
DECISIONS ABOUT CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES.
THERE IS REALLY NO OTHER OR VERY
FEW OTHER LEGAL CASE
CIRCUMSTANCES IN WHICH ARE
INADEQUATE LAWYERING CAN.
POTENTIALLY RESULT IN THE
DERAILMENT OF A PERSON'S LIFE IN
WAYS FROM WHICH THEY MAY NEVER
RECOVER.
SO WE ARE PASSIONATE ABOUT THE
OPPORTUNITY PRESENTED BY THE
RESEARCH THAT DEMONSTRATES WHAT
WE COULD DO WE WE CANNOT DO IT A
CURRENT FUNDING LEVELS.
AND SO WE IMPLORE THE STATE TO
REACH THIS FOR THIS MINIMAL
SUFFICIENT FLOOR OF A HUNDRED
AND FORTY ONE CASES PER YEAR.
HER ATTORNEY IS HERE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU MY NAME IS --
ERIN HYMAN AND I'M A MENTOR
PARENT WITH DACK --
DEPENDENCY FC CENTER AND I'M IN
SUPPORT OF ADDITIONAL FUNDING OF
SEVENTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR
DEPENDENCY.
TURN ATTORNEY SORRY I STARTED
USING DRUGS AT EIGHT YEARS OLD
AND COULD NOT STOP EVEN AFTER
BEING CARS RATED FOR OVER TEN
YEARS.
IN PRISON I STILL WENT BACK THE
ONLY LIFE IN SIXTEEN MY SON WAS
REMOVED.
BECAUSE MY ADDICTION AND MY
SURROUNDING UNSAFE.
I COULD NOT GET SOBER ON MY OWN
I DIDN'T EVEN KNOW WHERE TO
START.
I DON'T LIKE SO MANY OTHERS I
WAS GIVEN THE CHANCE TO BE A
PART OF A TEAM FOCUSED ON FIXING.
THE UNDERLINING BECAUSE MY
PROBLEM MY ADDICTION.
I WORK CLOSELY WITH MY DEPEND TO
LAWYER MEETING WEEKLY YOU GO
OVER MY BARRIERS AS WELL AS A
TEAM AND DEPENDENCY WELLNESS
CORE.
I WAS INFORMED OF TREATMENT AND
PROGRAM THE DID NOT KNOW EXISTED
IT WOULD HELP ME ACHIEVE LONG
TERM SOBRIETY.
WITHOUT THE WRITTEN THERE
WITHOUT TE SUPPORT I RECEIVED
FROM MY MENTOR PARENT WHO WORKS
WITH MY LAWYER.
I WOULD NOT BE HERE TODAY --
I NEED.
I NEEDED I WAS THAT I'M SORRY I
WAS ABLE TO REUNIFY WITH MY SON
MAINTAIN LONG TERM SOBRIETY
MAINTAIN GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT AND
CARE FOR MY YOUNGEST SON.
WHO WAS BORN DISABLED AND I WORK
FOR THE SAME LAWYERS WHO HELPED
ME?
AND I GET THE CHANCE TO HELP
OTHERS I ASK THAT YOU PLEASE
SUPPORT ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
DEPENDS THE ATTORNEYS.
THEY HELPED CHANGE MY LIFE AND
THE LIFE.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS JOHN
MACK ATTORNEY I AM FROM THE BAR
ASSOCIATION OF SAN FRANCISCO WE
MANAGE THE COURT APPOINTED
DEPENDENCY PANEL REPRESENTING
ALL CHILDREN.
AND ALL PARENTS IN SAN FRANCISCO --
AND WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
BEING IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
THIS YEAR FOR THE FIRST TIME AND
WE APPRECIATE THE TWENTY MILLION
DOLLAR AUGMENTATION THAT'S ON
THE TABLE.
WE DO.
I'M ALSO NEED TO RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR THAT ADDITIONAL FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS THIS YEAR --
I THE PROVIDERS YOU KNOW WE WE
ALL TALK WITH ONE ANOTHER VERY
REGULARLY I CAN ASSURE.
THE SENATORS AND THE MADAM CHAIR
THAT WE ABSOLUTELY CAN SPEND THE
MONEY -- WE
HAVE BEEN IN A HOLE.
FOR DECADES AND THAT MONEY WE
ARE POISED AND READY TO GO IN
SAN FRANCISCO WE HAVEN'T BEEN
ABLE -- TO
GIVE OUR ATTORNEYS A RAISE AN
ELEVEN HERE.
SO THIS IS AN URGENT NEED AGAIN
THE ONE FORTY ONE CASE LOAD
STANDARD IS A MINIMUM STANDARD
I'M SORRY THE MAXIMUM STANDARD
THAT THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL HAS
TARGETED.
WITH IF --
ONCE WE DO FIND OUT WHAT THE
FORTY DOLLARS LOOK LIKE IN TERMS
OF A MATCH THAT WOULD GO A LOT
FARTHER IN TERMS OF REACHING THE
IDEAL STANDARD.
I OUTLINED BY THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL --
I'M.
SEVENTY SEVEN I DO WANT TO JUST
TAKE A MOMENT TO REFLECT ON WHAT
ARE THE PRIOR SPEAKERS
EXPERIENCE WAS IN THE JUVENILE
DEPENDENCY SYSTEM AND MAKE SURE
THAT.
THIS COMMITTEE UNDERSTANDS THAT.
THE WORK THAT WAS INVOLVED IN
NOT SUCCESS STORY IS ABOUT
ATTORNEY TIME INVESTING THAT
ATTORNEY TIME FOR ONE PARTICULAR
CLIENT.
I RIGHT NOW WITH THE CURRENT
STANDARDS WE HAVE TO PICK AND
CHOOSE WHICH CLIENTS WE CAN GIVE
THAT LEVEL OF TIME AND ATTENTION.
TO IN ORDER TO MAKE THAT KIND OF
OUTCOME POSSIBLE FOR THAT FAMILY
AND FOR ALL OF THE SUCCESS
STORIES THAT WE'VE JUST HEARD
ABOUT.
THERE ARE MANY MORE THAT DON'T
GET THAT TIME AND ATTENTION AND
THOSE CHILDREN CAN WIND UP BEING
A BURDEN FINANCIALLY AND
SOCIALLY ON THE STATE. FOR THE
REST OF THEIR LIVES SO IT'S NOT
JUST ABOUT DOING MORALLY WHAT IT
THE RIGHT THING IS IT'S ABOUT.
UNDERSTANDING THE COST BENEFITS
SAID NOT SUPPLYING FULL FUNDING
FOR THESE LAWYERS MEANS.
JUST SPENDING THAT MONEY
ELSEWHERE --
IN TERMS OF SUPPORTING NOT
FOSTER CARE PAYMENT PLANS.
FOR UP TO TWENTY ONE YEARS AND
THEN NOT HOT BE ABLE FOR THAT.
PERSON TO YOU KNOW ECONOMICALLY
SUPPORT THEMSELVES FOR THE REST
OF THEIR LIVES.
SO THANK YOU I APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M ELIZABETH ESPINOSA
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
DEPENDENCY ADVOCACY CENTER IN
SAN JOSE --
DISORGANIZATION YOU'VE JUST
HEARD A SUCCESS STORY FROM ONE
OF THE PARENTS TO RECEIVE --
COMPASSIONATE AND AND THOUGHTFUL
REPRESENTATION FROM THE CENTER
IN THE LAST TEN YEARS --
THE CENTER HAS PROVIDED COURT
APPOINTED REPRESENTATION FOR
OVER SEVENTY FIVE HUNDRED AT
PARENTS AND CHILDREN WO ARE
BEING SERVED IN THE DEPENDENCY
SYSTEM IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY --
THE THE DEPENDENCY ADVOCACY
CENTER IS PART OF A VERY
COLLABORATIVE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM IN THE COUNTY OF SANTA
CLARA THEY ARE VERY COMMITTED --
TO THE OUTCOMES THAT YOU'VE
HEARD ABOUT TODAY --
AND CERTAINLY JOIN IN THE
COALITION EFFORT TO SEEK THIS
IDENTIFIED GAP OF SEVENTY
MILLION WITH GREAT GRATITUDE FOR
THE GOVERNOR'S COMMITMENT OF OF
TWENTY MILLION TO GET US PART
WAY THERE --
BUT THE FULL FUNDING WOULD WHAT
AS YOU HAVE HEARD BRING US TO A
MORE MANAGEABLE WORKLOAD OF ONE
FORTY ONE THE DEPENDENCY
ADVOCACY CENTER --
PROVIDES COMPASSIONATE
REPRESENTATION UNDER VERY
DIFFICULT CIRCUMSTANCES AND
CERTAINLY RECOGNIZES OF THE
BENEFITS THAT WE'VE HEARD ABOUT.
THE RESEARCH WOULD DEMONSTRATE
MUCH BETTER OUTCOMES WITH THIS
ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
I'M FINALLY I ALSO WANT TO
MENTION FOR A DIFFERENT GROUP OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN THE
COUNTY OF SANTA CLARA IS ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR DEPENDENCY COUNCILS.
FOR THE REASONS THAT YOU'VE
ALREADY HEARD ABOUT THANK YOU
FOR THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT SIR HAVING.
NO OTHER PUBLIC COMMENT.
WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU WHO --
CAME TODAY IN X..
GAVE US --
INFORMATION AND EXPRESSED VIEWS
AND I WANNA THANK YOU BOTH.
FOR THE INFORMATION PROVIDED AND
WE'RE NOW GOING TO MOVE ON TO
ISSUE.
FIVE WHICH IS OUR PRE TRIAL.
PRE.
DECISION MAKING PILOT.
I WAS JUST THINKING AS I SPOKE
OUT SOMEBODY WAS.
TRANSLATING ELECTRONICALLY WHAT
I SAY PROBABLY COME OUT PRETTY
GARBLED AT TIMES ANYWAY
ESPECIALLY --
WHATEVER --
THE SO OUR SPEAKERS FOR THAT
FREE TRIAL DECISION MAKING I LET.
OUR LUCY FOGARTY THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF BUDGET SERVICES AT
JUDICIAL COUNCIL AND SHELLY
CURRENT THE DIRECTOR OF CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SERVICES THAT THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL.
SO [inaudible]
BEGIN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
I'M THE END OF YOUR DAUGHTER
TODAY IS RELATED TO A SEVEN TWO
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR ALLOCATION
OVER TWO YEARS. TO FUND THE
IMPLEMENTATION OPERATION OR
EVALUATION OF PROGRAMS OR IF
IT'S AN EIGHT TO TEN CHORDS
RELATED TO PRE TRIAL DECISION
MAKING.
AND AS YOU QUICKLY INDICATED I
HAVE SURELY HEAD TO ASSIST WITH
ANY QUESTIONS.
SURE IF YOU WANT TO ADD
ADDITIONAL.
GOOD GOOD AFTERNOON --
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M THE ONLY THING
THAT I WOULD ADD IS THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY --
TO CONTINUE THE GOOD WORK THAT
HAS HAPPENED --
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AS IT RELATES
TO PRE TRIAL DECISION MAKING AND
ALSO TO RECOGNIZE THAT --
PRE TRIAL DECISION MAKING IS CHE
LEE --
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY WHETHER
IT'S THROUGH LEGISLATION THAT IS
PASSED OR LAWSUITS --
THAT ARE OCCURRING RIGHT NOW --
AND INNOVATIVE PRACTICES THAT
ARE HAPPENING AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
SO I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE.
OR YOU MAY HAVE SOME COMMENTS
BUT ON ACID FEW QUESTIONS FIRST
YOU DON'T MIND I'M.
SO IN THE IN OUR MATERIALS WERE
DISCUSSES PROPOSE BILL LANGUAGE
IT INDICATES THAT 10% OF THIS
REQUEST WOULD BE USED BY THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL. FOR COSTS OF
EVALUATING IMPLEMENTING AND
EVALUATING THE PROGRAMS BUT THIS
IS ALSO IN EFFECT.
A TWO YEAR PILOT.
SO.
WHAT I'M WONDERING IS HOW HOW
EFFECTIVELY ONE CAN EVALUATE?
SOMETHING THAT.
ASSUMING SAY IT THIS IS FUNDED.
WOULD NOT EVEN HAVE THE FUNDING
AVAILABLE TO JULY ONE OF THIS
YEAR WHICH THAT MEANS YOU HAVE
TO GET GOING.
AND SO --
YOU COULD PROBABLY NUMBER MONTHS
BEFORE IT'S REALLY GOTTEN GOING
IN SO HOW DO YOU EVALUATE.
ITS EFFECTIVENESS ON SO IF YOU
COULD TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THAT YOUR THANK YOU --
THAT IS A GOOD QUESTION IN
ANTICIPATION OF THE POSSIBILITY
THAT THE THOSE DOLLARS WILL BE
INCLUDED IN THE FINAL BUT THEN
AGAIN UNDERSTANDING THAT THAT IT
IS NOT DONE UNTIL IT UNTIL THE
GOVERNOR SIGNS AT NIGHT AFTER
THE LEGISLATURE HAS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO WEIGH AND THE
CHIEF JUSTICE IN.
JANUARY --
APPOINTED A REFORM OPERATIONS
WORK GROUP AND THAT GROUP ONE OF
ITS CHARGES IS LOOKING AT THAT
THE PROPOSED PILOT AND COMING UP
WITH A SET OF RECOMMENDATIONS.
FOR CONSIDERATION BY THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL AT ITS JULY
MEETING HOPEFULLY --
IN ORDER TO GET THOSE PILOTS UP
AND RUNNING AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE AND SO THAT GROUP RIGHT
NOW IS --
COMING UP WITH A LIST OF
CRITERIA --
BASED UPON WHAT'S CURRENTLY IN
THE BUDGET THE LANGUAGE --
AND WHAT IS --
THE THE RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE
PRE TRIAL DETENTION REFORMS
WORKGROUP THE CHIEF JUSTICE'S
LAST GROUP THAT LOOKED AT THIS --
AND LESSONS THAT I'VE BEEN
LEARNED FROM RECIDIVISM
REDUCTION FUND I'M LOOKING AT
THAT AND COMING UP WITH AN
APPLICATION PROCESS IN ORDER.
TO SEND THAT OUT TO THE COURTS
IN ANTICIPATION WITH THE HOPE
THAT ON THE COUNCIL WILL MAKE
THOSE DECISIONS AT ITS JANUARY
MEETING RECOGNIZING THAT TWO
YEARS IS A VERY QUICK TIME FRAME.
ADDITIONALLY WITH THE DOLLARS
THAT -- ARE
COMING TO THE JUDGE ANSEL MONEY
THAT --
THOSE THOSE FUNDS WILL GO
TOWARDS IS COMING UP WITH THE IT
INFRASTRUCTURE IN ORDER TO
COLLECT THE DATA FROM THE COURTS
SO THAT WE CAN TURN AROUND AND
EVALUATE THAT PROGRAM --
AS THE DATA IS COMING IN AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
GIVEN OUT WE HAVE ALREADY. FORTY
SIX OUT OF OUR FIFTY EIGHT BY
OUR COUNTIES.
BY YOUR ESTIMATION JUDICIAL
COUNCILS ESTIMATION THAT ALREADY
DOES SOME LEVEL OF PRE TRIAL
ASSESSMENT RISK ASSESSMENT.
AND MY UNDERSTANDING IS THESE
RISK ASSESSMENT TOOLS AREN'T
NECESSARILY UNIFORM --
COUNTY X. RECORD EXCUSES THIS.
ONE COURT WHY USES THAT
[inaudible]
ONE I'M.
WHY WOULDN'T WE START TO
EVALUATE?
ONES THAT ARE ALREADY IN PLACE
WHY WOULD WE BE USING THIS MONEY
RATHER THAN I MEAN IN FACT WE
HAVE PILOTS.
RIGHT WE GOT PILOTS GOING ON
ENOUGH FORTY SIX COUNTIES.
NOW THEY'RE NOT UNIFORM.
BUT MY UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT'S
BEING PROPOSED HERE IS IT
WOULDN'T NECESSARILY BE UNIFORM
EITHER [inaudible]
SO.
IF IF PART OF OUR OBJECTIVE IN
THIS IS PART OF MY QUESTION IS
WHAT IS THE OBJECTIVE THIS PART
OF OUR OBJECTIVE IS.
TO BEGIN TO LAND ON THE MOST
EFFECTIVE.
PRE TRIAL RISK ASSESSMENT --
SO THAT IN THE YOU KNOW WE KNOW.
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL ITSELF
ALREADY ACKNOWLEDGED AS EARLY AS
I THINK WAS TWENTY SEVENTEEN
MIGHT'VE BEEN EARLIER.
THAT -- OUR
CURRENT SYSTEM OF OF BAIL WAS
DISCRIMINATORY ON THOSE WHO ARE
LOW INCOME AND SO AND IT DOESN'T
NECESSARILY.
THAT ARE IF WE THINK ABOUT WHAT
IS OUR PURPOSE OUR PURPOSE IS
PUBLIC SAFETY.
WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE SURE THOSE --
PEOPLE HAT ARE CHARGED WITH
SOMETHING THAT ARE AT THAT WOULD
MEAN MOST LIKELY.
CONTINUE TO OFFEND OR BE A
THREAT TO PUBLIC SAFETY.
OURS ARE THAT WERE PROTECTED
FROM THAT AND OTHERWISE THE
ASSUMPTION IS YOU ARE INNOCENT
UNTIL PROVEN GUILTY.
SO IT SEEMS TO ME GIVEN THAT THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL AS YOU KNOW
ALREADY HAS BEEN THINKING ABOUT
THIS AND CLEARLY LOTS OF OUR
COURTS HAVE.
WHY WOULD WE BE NOW TRYING
[inaudible]
TO YOU ARE.
IDENTIFY A I DON'T KNOW SOME
NUMBER OF THESE COUNTIES OR
ALREADY ENGAGED IN SOME LEVEL OF
THIS ACTIVITY.
AND THEN BE EVALUATING THEM SO
THAT WE COULD.
YEAH SO YES THANK YOU THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I'M THE CHIEF
DESCRIBE THE THE CURRENT SYSTEM
IS SIMILAR TO THE WAY THAT YOU
DID SHE SAID THAT IT WAS UNSAFE
AND UNFAIR RIGHT SO IT'S AND IT
DOESN'T WORK IN TERMS OF ALL IS
NOT AS EFFECTIVE AS COULD BE.
IN TERMS OF PUBLIC SAFETY AND
IT'S UP POTENTIALLY COULD
PENALIZED FOR PEOPLE FOR BEING
POOR -- SO
IN TERMS OF STUDYING THIS --
WE ARE CURRENTLY DOING WELL
FUNDED THE RECIDIVISM REDUCTION
FUND SEVERAL YEARS AGO NOW AND
BY THIS FALL WE ARE GOING TO BE
PROVIDING A REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE.
THAT LOOKS AT THOSE PROGRAMS
THAT WERE FROM --
FUNDED BOTH FOR COLLABORATIVE
WORDS AND FOR PRE TRIAL WE'VE
ELEVEN PRE TRIAL PROGRAMS --
WE ARE IN THE PROCESS RIGHT NOW
OF DOING A MUCH DEEPER DIVE INTO --
SIX OF TOSE PRE TRIAL PROGRAMS
AND WHEN I SAY A DEEPER DIVE I
MEAN WE ARE COLLECTING DATA FROM
LOCAL JAILS WE ARE COLLECTING
DATA FROM THE CAL DOJ AND WE'RE
COLLECTING ADDITIONAL DATA FROM
THE COURTS IN ORDER TO LOOK AT
THOSE PROGRAMS --
AND PROGRAM PARTICIPANTS VERSUS
PEOPLE WHO DID NOT PARTICIPATE
IN THOSE PROGRAMS AND REALLY
MEASURE BOTH PUBLIC SAFETY --
AND RETURN TO COURT I THINK WHAT
IS DIFFERENT ABOUT THOSE
PROGRAMS AND THE OTHER --
FORTY SIX PROGRAMS THAT ARE OUT
THERE VERSUS WHAT IS BEING
PROPOSED RIGHT NOW IS PART OF
THE BUDGET IS THIS IS A MUCH
DEEPER DIVE --
WE ANTICIPATE WHAT --
GOING INTO THIS COUNTY IS FAR
MORE COMPREHENSIVE SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR EIGHT TO TEN
PLACES IS IS A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF MONEY AND AND WE THINK
BECAUSE OF THAT.
WE ENVISION PROGRAMS WHERE --
ASSESS YOU KNOW P. ELIGIBLE FOR
WILL BE WILL BE ASSESSED --
IT WILL PROVIDE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO DO -- A
DEEPER DIVE ABOUT VALIDATION OF
THOSE TOOLS YOU MENTION THE
FORTY SIX FORTY SIX PROGRAMS
THAT ARE OUT THERE RIGHT NOW
WHERE WHERE TOOLS ARE BEING USED.
I'M IN VERY FW HAVE THE TOOLS
ACTUALLY BEEN VALIDATED ON THEIR
LOCAL POPULATIONS AND SO PART OF
THIS PROGRAM WILL ALSO BE
VALIDATING THOSE TOOLS --
ANOTHER BIG ISSUE THAT WE HAVE
RUN INTO --
WITH WITH THAT WHAT I CAN THE
BIG ISSUE THAT WE HAVE RUN INTO
BUT ISSUE THAT OUR RECIDIVISM
REDUCTION FUN COURTS HAVE
IDENTIFIED IS.
THE IMPORTANCE OF COLLABORATION
AND DATA EXCHANGE SO THIS
PROGRAM IS ALSO GOING TO PROVIDE
FOR A COLLABORATION AND HAVE
OPERATION AMONG LOCAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM PARTNERS.
THROUGH DATA EXCHANGES AND WE
ANTICIPATE THE DOLLARS WILL GO
TO THE COURTS SO THAT PROVISION
IN THE JAILS IN THE COURTS CAN
CAN TALK TO EACH OTHER.
HOW THAT INFORMATION SHARED AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL SO THE DECISIONS
CAN BE MADE MORE QUICKLY AND
THEN THAT WILL ALSO ENABLE US AT
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL LEVEL TO GO
IN AND PULL THAT DATA AND DO A
DEEPER ANALYSIS AND WERE ABLE TO
DO RIGHT NOW AS IT RELATES TO
ISSUES?
THAT I THINK ARE I KNOW ARE OF
GREAT IMPORTANCE TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND ALSO THE CHIEF
JUSTICE AND AND THE
ADMINISTRATION AROUND POTENTIAL
BIAS IN THE TOOLS.
BUT IF YOU DESCRIBE THAT YOU'RE
GONNA BE DOING THIS DEEPER DIVE
AND THIS IS YOU KNOW THIS THE
GRANT PROGRAM [inaudible]
ARE YOU.
ARE YOU GOING TO BE JUST
ASSESSING [inaudible]
THOSE TOOLS.
THAT RISK ASSESSMENT THAT
WHATEVER COUNTIES ARE AWARDED
ARE ALREADY USING.
OR DO YOU HAVE A OR YOUR IS
THERE GOING TO BE RECOMMENDED AT
A CERTAIN PART OF THE QUESTION
IS.
WE HAVEN'T REALLY VALUE WITH
THESE TOOLS.
AND MAYBE THERE HAS MAYBE THERE
IS A BEST PRACTICE SOMEWHERE
WOULD WE BE ASKING CERTAIN
COURTS THAT WE FUNDED. TO
UTILIZE TOOL EXOR TOOL WHY SO
THAT WE COULD THEN COMPARE THE
EFFECTIVENESS.
OF TOOL EXOR TOOL WHY ME WHAT IS
IT'S NOT CLEAR FROM THE FROM
LATE YES SO SO A VARIETY OF
COURTS --
WILL BE WILL BE ONE OF THE SO
WITH SIMILAR TO ARE THERE WHEN
YOU SAVE RIGHT OF COURT SO
MEANING WHAT THEY'RE ALREADY
USING.
I I MEAN A COUPLE DIFFERENT
THINGS ONE IS IN PART DIFFERENCE
CASE MANAGEMENT SYSTEMS RIGHT SO
DIFFERENT COURT CASE MANAGEMENT
SYSTEM SO THAT ANYTHING THAT WE
LEARN AND ANY --
IN PLACE FOR A MAJOR COURT CASE
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM WE CAN
REPLICATE THROUGHOUT THE STATE
THAT'S ONE ANOTHER IS QUART SIZE
RECOGNIZING THAT THERE ARE SOME
COURTS THAT ARE REALLY REALLY
LARGE AND OTHER COURTS THAT ARE
YOU KNOW TWO TO FIVE JUDGES IN
THE STATE AND SO MAKING SURE
THAT.
WE HAVE A DIVERSITY OF THOSE
COURTS LOOKING AT NORTHERN
STATES.
FAITH NORTHERN CHORDS SOUTHERN
COURTS A COASTAL AND AND RURAL
ALSO SO LOOKING AT A VARIETY OF
YOU DON'T EVEN KNOW IF THAT I
ONLY SEE GOD SAY'S IT SO YES.
WE HAVE GEOGRAPHIC DIFFERENCES
BUT DO WE ARE THOSE.
ARE THE GEOGRAPHIC LOCATION OF
THE COURTS AN INDICATOR OF
WHETHER THEY'RE USING A
DIFFERENT RISK ASSESSMENT FREE
TRIAL RISK ASSESSMENT TOOL OR
NOT OR SO I GUESS WHAT I'M
REALLY TRYING TO GET AT YOU
HAVEN'T MENTIONED YET IS.
PART OF THIS PILOT IS.
TO GIVE US BETTER INFORMATION
ABOUT OUR PRE TRIAL RISK
ASSESSMENT TOOLS SO ARE WE GOING
TO BE.
MEAN OR GONNA BE COMPARING.
APPLE'S INCOME QUOTES AND
PINEAPPLES OR SO ARE WE IS PART
OF THE CRITERIA THAT.
ALL OF THE PILOT.
ALL USING DIFFERENT ASSESSMENT
TOOL SO WE CAN FIGURE OUT WHICH
MIGHT BE.
THE MOST USEFUL OR ARE WE GOING
TO BE RECOMMENDING CERTAIN
ASSESSMENT TOOLS SO THAT THEN
WERE EVALUATING WHETHER.
IDENTIFIED ASSESSMENT TOOLS.
IN YOU CELLS WERE SOMETHING YOU
KNOW WHETHER THEY ARE THE BEST
PRACTICE OR NOT.
YES SO LIGHT I UNDERSTAND --
I SHOULD SAY THAT --
THIS PRE TRIAL OF REFORM
OPERATIONS WORKGROUP PROWESS OR
CALLING IT IS IS THE GROUP THAT
REALLY IS DEVELOPING.
THE APPLICATION AND THE AND THE
CRITERIA BASED UPON THE THINGS
THAT I MENTIONED BEFORE THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT HAVE HAPPENED
TO DATE.
HAVE HAVE DISCUSSED THE BENEFIT
OF LOOKING AT A VARIETY OF TOOLS --
THROUGHOUT THE THROUGHOUT THE
PROGRAM I SHOULD SAY THE ANOTHER
PRIORITY OF THIS GROUP ANOTHER
CHARGE OF THE GROUP FROM THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL THE CHIEF.
IS LOOKING AT I'VE INTO THESE
TOOLS AS YOU MENTIONED THERE ARE
MANY TOOLS THAT ARE BEING OUT
THERE NOT ONLY ARE THERE
DIFFERENT TOOLS WITH THE TOOLS
ARE ARE BEING MODIFIED IN
DIFFERENT COUNTIES BECAUSE OF
DIFFERENT COUNTY CULTURES.
AND SO WHAT THAT GROUP IS DOING
SIMULTANEOUSLY TO THE WORK THAT
IT'S DOING AROUND THE SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION IS LOOKING AT THOSE
TOOLS AND COMING UP I ANTICIPATE
THAT THEY'LL BE COMING UP WITH
THE SET OF RECOMMENDATIONS. FOR
TRIAL COURTS TO CONSIDER WHEN
THEY'RE ADOPTING THESE COOL
TOOLS AND SO WHAT --
THAT THEY WERE BEING ASKED --
TO OKAY FUNNY BEFORE THAT'S
BEFORE YOU REALLY WORKED THAT
OUT BUT IT JUST COMMENT.
I'M.
I NOTE YOUR COMMENT ABOUT A
DIFFERENT.
NOT SURE IF YOU SAID.
OR CULTURES ARE COUNTY CULTURES
VERB.
CLEARLY THERE IS --
OBVIOUSLY VARIATIONS IN THE IN
THE DEFENDANTS THAT ARE COMING
FORWARD AND SAY REGION X. OR Y.
THOUGH IF OUR OBJECTIVE.
OUR PURPOSE FOR THIS.
IS TO HELP US [inaudible]
BETTER.
UNDERSTAND EFFECTIVE TOOLS FOR
THE PUBLIC SAFETY OBJECTIVE OF
OF SO MINIMIZING.
MINIMIZING EITHER HOLDING PEOPLE
ARE CHARGING THEM BAIL IF
THEY'RE NOT.
A PUBLIC SAFETY RISK.
AND YES THERE'S OBVIOUSLY SOME
FACTORS THAT ARE --
NO MY TWO VAX VERY
GEOGRAPHICALLY.
IT'S HARD FOR ME TO SEE THAT
THERE'S HUGE AMOUNT.
OF FACTORS THAT ARE GONNA VERY
GEOGRAPHICALLY THAT WHEN WE'RE
GETTING RIGHT DO WHEN WE GET
DOWN TO THE BASIS OF OUR PRIMARY
OBJECTIVE IS THAT ACHIEVING THE
PUBLIC SAFETY.
SO I GUESS WHERE I'M GOING IS
WHAT YOU KNOW ARE WE IF I FIND A
PILOT I WANT TO KNOW THAT WE ARE
MORE CLEAR ABOUT WHAT IT IS THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO YOU BOTH WHAT
THE CRITERIA IS OF WHAT WE WE
HOW YOU VALUE IT HAD A FUNDED.
WHAT'S OUR OBJECT WHAT ARE WE
TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH.
I I WOULD SAY THAT THE
OBJECTIVES ARE THREEFOLD ONE IS --
TO BE MORE SUCCESSFUL IN TERMS-OF PUBLIC SAFETY WHEN IT COMES
TO PRE TRIAL RELEASE RIGHTS WILL
BE AS SUCCESSFUL AS POSSIBLE AND
MEASURING THAT.
A SECOND IS RETURNED TO COURT
AND TO HAVING SUCCESSFUL --
IN TERMS OF RETURN TO COURT THAT
THE DEFENDANTS COME TO COURT
WHEN THE DEFENDANTS ARE REQUIRED.
TO MITIGATING BIAS IS ANOTHER
OBJECTIVE OF THIS PROGRAM IN SO
DOING THAT LOOK AND SEEING IF
THERE IS BIAS IN THE SYSTEM
WHERE THERE IS BIAS IN THE
SYSTEM AND HOW IT IS THAT THAT
WE CAN WORK.
TO REDUCE THAT BIAS ANOTHER
ANOTHER YOU CAN FIND OUT WHAT
WORKS AND WHAT DOESN'T WORK AND
THEN ONCE WE LEARN WHAT WORKS WE
CAN SHARE THAT INFORMATION AND
SHARE THOSE BEST PRACTICES AMONG
THE COURTS.
AND INFORM --
THE POLICY MAKERS.
SO PART OF MY QUESTION THEN IS
THAT NOTION OF WHAT WORKS AND
WHAT DOESN'T WORK.
I'M NOT TRYING TO PRESUPPOSE
THAT WE KNOW WHAT WORKS.
BUT CERTAINLY.
AND I ALSO DON'T KNOW WHETHER
HOW MUCH UNIFORMITY THERE MIGHT
BE.
IN THESE FORTY EIGHT BACK HER
JURISDICTIONS THAT ARE USING THE
DIFFERENT FORMS OF RISK
ASSESSMENT IN PRE TRIAL
[inaudible]
I'M -- BUT
IT SEEMS THERE'S GOT TO BE SOME
STUDIES.
THAT [inaudible] FOR SOME.
AS THEIR FAVORITE TURNED OUT
EVIDENCE BASED.
INDICATORS OF WHAT'S.
WHAT MAKES SOME REMOTE MAKES
THIS KIND OF ACTIVITY MORE
EFFECTIVE SO WOULDN'T WE WANT TO
BE?
ENSURING THAT ANY PILOTS WE ARE
FINDING ARE HELPING US OF THAT
HAVE BEEN PUT FORWARD. TO DATE
AS BEING THE MOST EFFECTIVE SO
THAT WE CAN THEN.
HAVE THE EVIDENCE THAT IN FACT
THEY ARE FOR US.
YES AND AND THE LANGUAGE EXPERT
TALKS ABOUT VALIDATED TOOLS AND
IT TALKS ABOUT --
QUICK DECISION MAKING RIGHT SO
SO STUDIES HAVE COME OUT THAT
SHOW THE IMPACT WHEN SOMEONE IS
DETAINED PRE TRIAL AND AND
LITERALLY BY THE DAYS THE IMPACT
THAT HAS ON THEIR FAMILIES ON
THEIR JOBS OF SOMEONE'S CAR IS
TOTALED THINGS LIKE THAT THAT
THAT.
PEOPLE DON'T NECESSARILY THINK
OF IMMEDIATELY WHAT THE IMPACT
IS AND SELL PART ANOTHER
OBJECTIVE OF THIS PROGRAM THAT'S
INCLUDED IN THE BUDGET BILL
LANGUAGE --
RIGHT NOW IS QUICKER DECISIONS
BY JUDICIAL OFFICERS IN SO DOING
WHAT WE CAN AGAIN A LOT OF IT IS
THROUGH I. T. MAKING SURE THAT
RISK ASSESSMENT IS DONE.
MOST OF ALL OF THE REQUEST YOUR
BY THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL WERE ALL
I. T. SO I'M HOPING THAT THIS
PILOT IS NOT PRIMARILY REQUESTS
FOR IT.
I I JUST IN TERMS OF THE MONTH
THE DOLLARS THAT ARE GOING TO BE
GOING TO THE COUNCIL TO ENSURE
THAT WE CAN HELP THE COURTS.
GET THAT IN INFORMATION EXCHANGE
AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE SO THAT
IT CAN COME TO A JUDICIAL
OFFICER SO JUDICIAL OFFICER CAN
MAKE THAT DECISION.
IN ORDER TO ENHANCE PUBLIC
SAFETY RETURN TO COURT AND
MAKING SURE THAT THAT WHEN
SOMEONE IS SAFE TO BE TO BE
RELEASED PRE TRIAL --
THAT THEY ARE SAFE TO BE
RELEASED AND THEY DON'T THEY
DON'T HAVE --
TO LIVE WITH AND AND DEAL WITH
THE VERY EXPENSIVE COSTS OF OF
COMMERCIAL BAIL BONDS IF THERE'S
A WAY TO GET PEOPLE OUT SOONER.
I AM SURE MY COLLEAGUES HAVE
QUESTIONS APOLOGIES --
DOMINATING THIS BUTTON PERHAPS.
SOME OF THE QUESTIONS THAT I
RACED WERE ONES THAT IN OUR
MATERIALS EVEN LA ALWAYS RAISE
BUT LA YOU IF YOU WANT.
TO ADD RIGHT NOW.
HAPPY BEFORE.
EIGHT AS MY COLLEAGUES AS SOME
OTHER QUESTIONS.
ABSOLUTELY --
SO WE ARE RECOMMENDING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE DRUGS BUT THE
ADMINISTRATION AND JUDICIAL CUT
COUNCILS THE MIDDLE MOORE WELL
DEVELOPED --
PROPOSAL BY APRIL FIFTEENTH WE
CAN CONSIDER IT AS PART OF YOUR
SPRING DELIBERATIONS --
AND WE RECOMMENDED THIS BECAUSE
WE THOUGHT THAT THE PROGRAM
COULD BE WORTHWHILE THERE IS
POSSIBILITY BUT REALLY THE FAULT
OF THE LEGISLATURE DIDN'T HAVE
ENOUGH INFORMATION. TO EVALUATE
IT AND WEIGHED AGAINST OTHER
GENERAL SPECIFICALLY THE KEY
INFORMATION THAT WE THOUGHT
NEEDED TO BE ANSWERED SOME OF
WHICH HAS BEEN ALREADY RAISED BY
MADAM CHAIR.
IS YOU KNOW WHAT ARE THE PRIMARY
GOALS OF THE PROGRAM WHAT ARE
THE ACTIVITIES THAT WOULD BE
FUNDED AND HOW ARE THEY ALIGN
WITH THOSE GOALS HOW IS THE
FUNDING TO BE ALLOCATED.
AND THEN FINALLY HOW WE ENSURE
THAT THE FUNDED PROGRAMS AND
ACTIVITIES ARE GONNA BE A VALUED
IN A WAY THAT INFORMS STATEWIDE
DECISION MAKING.
WAS WITHOUT THIS INFORMATION WE
FOUND THAT IT WAS A LITTLE BIT
DIFFICULT FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO
EFFECTIVELY EVALUATE WHETHER IT
WAS STRUCTURED OPERATED AND
FUNDED IN A MANNER THAT WOULD
REFLECT.
LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES AND MEET
LEGISLATIVE EXPECTATIONS.
SO -- WE DO
WITH HOLD RECOMMENDATION PENDING
THAT ADDITIONAL INFORMATION TO
THE EXTENT THAT ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION IS NOT PROVIDED WE
DO RECOMMEND REJECTING THE
PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU SENATOR MARLA.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR --
THE PRIVILEGE OF WORKING WITH US
SENATOR BATES FOR EIGHT YEARS.
AS A FELLOW SUPERVISOR.
AND SHE KEPT USING THE TERM.
THIS IS THIS ITEM ON THE AGENDA
IS NOT COOKED IN.
I THINK THAT CAME FROM HER
EXPERIENCE AT THE LEGISLATURE IN
THE LEGISLATURE.
AND IS IT SEEMS LIKE I'M HEARING
A LOT MORE HERE ARE IN
SACRAMENTO THE CAPITAL NOT
COOKED IN A MY CART AND SO I
SORT OF AGREE WITH WHERE THE
CHURCH GOING AND I AGREE WITH
THE LA OWES.
COMMENTS THAT --
MAYBE WE OUGHTA.
WAIT A YEAR ARE WITHOUT ALL
THESE OTHER.
PRESSING NEEDS HAVE BEEN BROUGHT
TO US.
TODAY -- AND
WITH THIS BE TEN WHICH I WAS THE
ONLY REPUBLICAN VOTER FORCE.
AND I'VE.
BEEN GETTING MY SPEED BAD ABOUT
THAT BUT SINCE IT'S GOING TO BE
ON THE BALLOT IN NOVEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY WITH EVERYTHING SORT OF
ON HOLD ANYWAY [inaudible]
SO I'M.
I'M SORT OF LEANING TOWARDS
[inaudible]
DAILYKOS POSITION.
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT'S GONNA BE
A QUESTION --
I'M JUST JUST KIND OF MAKING AN
OBSERVATION.
SO IF YOU WANT TO RESPOND.
HAPPY.
YOU MAY OKAY.
WE ARE WE ARE OPEN TO WORKING
WITH WITH THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE OF
COURSE ON ENHANCING AND BEING
CLEAR ON WHAT THE GOALS ARE WHAT
DIRECTIVES ARE --
THE TYPES OF THINGS THAT ARE
GOING TO BE FUNDED.
AND THEN ALSO THE EVALUATION I
MEAN THAT'S SOMETHING THAT THAT
WE HAVE --
ALREADY BEEN THINKING ABOUT
ESPECIALLY IN TERMS OF YOU KNOW
HOW IT IS THAT WE'RE GONNA
STRUCTURED SO THAT WE CAN GET
THE DATA THAT IS NEEDED.
TO MEASURE WHETHER OR NOT IT
WORKING INTERNAL RETURN IN TERMS
OF RETURN TO WORK PUBLIC SAFETY --
AND THEN AND THEN ALSO POTENTIAL
BIAS WE ARE HAPPY CAN YOU WORK
WITH -- WORK
WITH THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
PART THAT'S ON THOSE CONCERNS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
BERMAN FINANCE AND YOU WANT TO
COMMENT --
YOU KNOW I THINK THE THE PRE
TRIAL LANDSCAPE IN CALIFORNIA IS
EVER CHANGING --
AND I THINK THIS INVESTMENT THAT
WE'VE MADE WILL HELP US BE READY
FOR WHEN AND IF THAT ACTUALLY
HAPPENS --
AND DOES THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
MENTIONED YOU KNOW WE'RE HAPPY
TO CONTINUE PRIDE IN PROVIDING
MORE INFORMATION THE CHIEF PUT
TOGETHER THE WORK GROUP AND
THEY'RE WORKING ON MORE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR HOW TO
IMPLEMENT HAPPY TO CONTINUE
PROVIDING INFORMATION TO STAFF
AND THE LEO.
COMMENT I WOULD MAKE ABOUT THAT
AND I'M SURE SENATOR BILL HAS
SOME IS THAT [inaudible]
WHILE.
WELL WE DON'T KNOW.
WHAT -- WILL
HAPPEN NEXT EITHER LEGISLATIVELY
OR BY VOTERS.
IT IS CERTAINLY.
I'M INDEPENDENT OF ANY OF THAT.
HOW A ANY PARTICULAR JUDGE OR
COURT?
DETERMINES WHETHER BILLS
NECESSARY AND WHAT LEVEL OF IT
IS IS WITHIN [inaudible]
OUR DISCRETION [inaudible]
AND SO.
I THINK WHAT REGARDLESS AGAIN OF
ANY OF THESE OTHER.
THINGS THAT ARE IN THE EITHER
[inaudible]
I'M.
IF WE FIND SUCH A PILOT WE ARE
GOING.
ART AGAIN OUR OBJECTIVE.
OUR OBJECTIVE.
FOR WHAT WE'VE ESTABLISHED SO
FAR.
AMBER WHAT WE'RE PRACTICING SO
FAR WAS ON IT THREE OF
PROTECTING THE PUBLIC.
AND AND SO WHAT WE'D WANT TO DO
IS MAKE SURE.
THAT AND STEP BACK IN WE FACE WE
HAVE OVER TIME.
I APPRECIATED THAT.
IN THE DESIGN OF THAT SYSTEM OR
THE PRACTICE OF THAT SYSTEM
THERE IS BEEN BIAS.
AND IT IS DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECTED LOW INCOME PEOPLE AND
IT IS ALSO INCREASED OUR COSTS
BECAUSE WE'VE PERHAPS HELP
PEOPLE.
INCARCERATED PEOPLE ARE HELP
FOR THAT WE DIDN'T NEED TO OR
FOR LONGER THAN WE NEEDED TO AND
OF COURSE THAT'S A COST --
AND SO HOW DO WE IMPROVE THAT
AND CLEARLY THE RISK ASSESSMENT
PROCESS IS PART OF AFFECTED RISK
ASSESSMENT PROCESS IS PART OF
THAT IMPROVING SO IT IS WITH IT
IS.
TOTALLY IN OUR INTEREST TO
IMPROVE THAT PROCESS REGARDLESS
OF ANYTHING ELSE.
AND SO WHEN I THINK ABOUT
FINDING A PILOT I WANT TO HELP I
WANT.
TO WE CAN NEVER BE ASSURED BUT I
TO FEEL THAT IT'S DESIGNED
APPROPRIATELY TO GIVE US SOME
OUTCOMES WE CAN LAND ON THAT
HELP GUIDE US IN THE NEXT.
DIRECTIONS AROUND OUR PRACTICES.
WELCOME TO COMMENT IF YOU LIKE.
WE LIVE WE AGREE.
ABSOLUTELY MAKING SURE THAT THAT
THE OBJECTIVE OF PUBLIC SAFETY
AND ALSO --
QUICK DECISION MAKING --
ARE AND RETURN TO COURT R. I.
AND AND ALL THE WHILE REDUCING
BIAS IS IS INTEGRAL TO THE
SYSTEM AND IT'S BEEN SOMETHING
THAT THAT.
THE CHIEF JUSTICE HAS BEEN
TALKING ABOUT RIGHT.
YES.
YEAH AND AND I THINK LIKE THE LA --
WHEN I READ THE ITEM TO AT LEAST
TO DATE?
NAME -- USED.
US SENATOR BREAUX.
I HAVE A DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE
THAN.
BUT TWO YEARS AGO I INTRODUCED A
BILL -- SP
EIGHT THE VERSION OF THE DEALT
WITH --
INDIVIDUALS WITH MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES -- I
DISCOVERED BY LOOKING AT COUNTY
JAIL RECORDS SO --
WITH --
MENTAL ILLNESS. FOR THE SAME
CRIME.
GENERALLY WERE IN JAIL LONGER.
JUDGES SHAKING HIS HEAD --
I NOTE FOR THE RECORD --
LONGER THAN SOMEBODY.
IN JAIL FOR THE SAME CRIME --
IF YOU HAVE A MILLION US YOU'RE
IN JAIL FOR LONGER PERIODS OF
TIME.
THEREBY THERE BY HAVING A BIAS --
OR DISCRIMINATION IF YOU WANT TO
SEE IT THAT WAY FOR SOMEBODY.
THAT HAS A BILL ILLNESS IN JAIL
BECAUSE OF THE DETERMINATION OF
PAPARAZZI AND HOW TO HANDLE --
AND SO FOR SO.
AS A RESULT OF THAT --
BECAUSE I THOUGHT THAT.
IN ADDITION.
TO BE ADVISED AGAINST SOMEBODY
WITH MENTAL ILLNESS --
BEEN IN.
JAIL OR PRISON LONGER.
SAME THING APPLIES --
TO PRISON BY THE WAY THERE.
IN THERE LONGER FOR THE SAME
CRIME BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
TREATED IN THE JAILS PRISONS
ADEQUATELY SO THEY DON'T BEHAVE
EXACTLY.
NORMAL WAY AND THEREFORE THERE.
THE SYSTEM IS DESIGNED TO PUNISH
PEOPLE THAT.
DON'T BEHAVE CORRECT
[inaudible]
AND THE TURNING THEIR COMPETENCY
FOR TRIAL IN.
THAT LEGAL PROCESS TAKES TIME --
HAVING SPECIALIZED EVALUATIONS
TAKES TIME.
OF ALL THOSE KINDS OF THINGS
LEAD.
TO WHAT I CONSIDERED THIS TO BE
A VIOLATION OF THEIR CIVIL
RIGHTS IN THE SENSE OF THE
AMERICAN DISABILITIES ACT WHICH
IS STERILE.
EQUAL TREATMENT OKAY.
SO I INTRODUCES THE BILL.
SB EIGHT THERE WITH STARSHIP PRE
TRIAL DIVERSION PROGRAM. FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH MENTAL ILLNESS
AND BE ABLE --
TO A TRIAL HAVE CONFERENCES IN
THE JUDGE'S CHAMBERS
[inaudible]
WE HAVE.
PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN DETERMINED
TO HAVE SERIOUS MENTAL ILLNESS.
AND HAVE CONFERENCES TO DIVERT
THEM. TO TREATMENT PROGRAMS.
IN A CONDITIONAL WAY WHEREBY
THEY WOULD --
BE ABLE --
TO GO TO THE TREATMENT PROGRAMS.
AND HAVE AN ABILITY --
TO RECEIVE THE TREATMENT AND AND
IF THE JUDGE WAS SO INCLINED
AFTER SEEING SATISFACTORY
PROGRESS REPORTS.
THEN HAVE AN ABILITY.
TO A RACE ANY RECORDS OR EXPUNGE
ANY RECORDS OF THE PERSONS --
CRIME THAT THEY WERE CHARGED
WITH ORIGINALLY CHARGED WITH --
TALKED ABOUT SO.
THAT BILL --
IT WENT THROUGH THE PROCESS AND
TWENTY SEVENTEEN IT WAS A LOT OF
WORK WE DO A LOT OF WORK ON IT.
IT DIED IN THE ASSEMBLY --
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE RIGHT
IN.
AND THEN WE RE INTRODUCED IT --
TO IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN AS SP.
TWO FIFTEEN S. S. B. --
TWO FIFTEEN HAD A VERSION THAT
WENT THROUGH WE MADE IT WE WE
WORKED OUT SO.
SOME ISSUES WITH THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S IT WENT THROUGH THE
PROCESS IT HAD BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT I DON'T.
HE WAS UNOPPOSED I BELIEVE ON A
POST.
AND THEN JUST TO CONTINUE THE
STORY.
ALSO WE HAD A PRE TRIAL A GROUP
OF PROGRAMS EVERYBODY AGREED ON
AND ABOUT MAY OF LAST YEAR.
THEN THE GOVERNOR PROPOSES
BUDGET HE PUT.
IN HIS BUDGET TRAILER BILL AB.
EIGHTEEN TEN A PRE TRIAL
DIVERSION PROGRAM THE SAME AS SP
TWO FIFTEEN EXCEPT CLUE THE
MURDER RAPE AND SEX CRIMES
REMEMBER THIS [inaudible]
AND SO --
THAT TRAILER BILL.
WAS APPROVED IN THE BUDGET
PROCESS THIS KIND OF DONE
WITHOUT GOING TO OUR COMMITTEE
OR ANYTHING IT JUST KIND OF I
DON'T REMEMBER THIS THIS.
EVERYBODY REMEMBERS IT NOW I WAS
QUITE WITH SO WE HAD TO SPEND A
LOT TIME.
CLEANING THAT UP SO I I ACTUALLY
AMENDED SP. TWO FIFTEEN TO DO A
CLEAN UP OF THE GOVERNOR'S.
TRAILER BILL ALL.
AND THE TRAILER BUT AN SP TWO
FIFTEEN EVENTUALLY WAS ADOPTED
AND THE LAW --
REMOVING [inaudible]
OF MANSLAUGHTER MURDER RAPE AND
SEX CRIMES FROM THE ELIGIBILITY
FOR THE DIVERSION PROGRAM.
AND REQUIRES COURTS TO CONDUCT
HEARINGS.
UNREST IF ANY RESTITUTION WAS --
THAT WE WANTED TO HAVE THE
RESTITUTION.
YOU KNOW PROCESS IS PART OF IT
BECAUSE THAT'S A GOOD PROCESS TO
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE [inaudible]
APPROACH.
SO WHEN I HEAR ABOUT.
NOW DOING A HI THE ON PRE TRIAL.
AFTER HAVING SPENT TWO YEARS
WORKING ON THIS BILL HEALTH
THING MY QUESTION IS ARE YOU
IMPLEMENTING THE MILL HEALTH
THING.
IS THIS BEEN IMPLEMENTED BY THE
COURTS AND WHY DO WE NEED A PRE
TRIAL.
PILOT PROGRAM [inaudible]
AT ALL.
OF WE CAN JUST EXPAND WHAT WE
ALREADY HAVE.
IN PRE TRIAL THE COURTS
EVERYBODY AGREED TO THE CONCEPT
THAT WE DEVELOPED.
THROUGH THAT WHY CAN'T WE JUST
EXPAND WHEN WE NEED A SIR LIKE.
FOR JU THE I I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
WANT TO DO A PILOT I DON'T WANT
TO DO A PILOT I WANT TO JUST
STICKS.
TO EXPAND THE THE PROGRAMS THAT
WE ALREADY IS ESTABLISHED WITH
THIS WITH THE BUDGET TRAILER
BILL IN THE STATUTE.
THAT WAS SIGNED INTO LAW LAST
YEAR AND THERE WERE SOME OTHER
STATUTES.
ON FREE TRIAL.
PROGRAM SO WHY CAN'T WE JUST.
MOVE TO MOVE THIS ALONG ---I DON'T MIND YOU STUDYING OR
ANALYSING ROLE RATHER THE COST
MONEY US BUT SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS TO DO A PILOT
PROGRAM.
NO I DON'T THINK SO I WANT --
TO I I WANT --
TO THE LAW THAT WE ESTABLISHED --
IF YOU WANTED TO SUIT INSTITUTED
MORE FULLY --
ESTABLISH SHOULD BE IN A
STRONGER WAY THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
THAT WOULD BE A GOOD IDEA --
LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
IS NOW.
GOING TO A THEY DECIDE NOT TO
BUILD ANOTHER PRISON.
AND THEY WANT TO HAVE.
PROGRAMS [inaudible]
FOR PSYCHIATRIC FACILITIES.
THAT WILL TAKE PLACE --
WE VOTERS APPROVED PROPOSITION.
TWO NO PLACE LIKE HOME BONDS.
THOSE WILL PROVIDE SOME SORT OF
HOUSING ANALYST.
PROPOSITION ONE WHICH HE I WAS
ABOVE THE THAT WAS.
THE BOND.
THAT WILL PROVIDE SOME SORT OF
HOUSING.
FINDS A PROGRAM.
SO IT SEEMS LIKE IT SEEMS LIKE.
NOW THAT WE IN THE GOVERNOR'S
PUT MONEY IN THE BUDGET FOR
HOUSING.
I TAKE A CHECK WHY DON'T WE JUST.
THIS.
VERSION PROGRAM.
THAT WE CAN START TO HAVE
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE.
IN TWO OF THE SUPPORT OF HOUSING
AND HAVE.
THE PRE TRIAL DIVERSION PROGRAM
IT. FOR FULL WEIGHT NOW THAT THE
WHAT.
WORKS SO HARD TO GET ALL THAT
HOUSING LINED UP BECAUSE THAT
WAS THE BOTTOM RIGHT.
NOT NOT HAVING A PLACE FOR THE
PERSON -- TO
GET TREATMENT.
WAS THE BOTTLENECK AND BY THE
WAY.
IF WE HAVE THESE TREATMENT
PROGRAMS HAVE TO MONEY COMES AT
A KELSO.
SO IT'S A IT'S A BARGAIN AS
OPPOSED TO PUTTING UP.
AFTER SPENDING TWO YEARS ON THIS.
WHAT'S THE PROBLEM WITH THIS
IMPLEMENTING WHAT WE ALREADY DID
AND TIED IT INTO THOSE
THAT WE'RE ALREADY DOING I THINK
WE'RE WE THE VOTERS HAVE SPOKEN
WE WANT THESE PROGRAMS.
YOU KNOW WE WE WE HAD
PROPOSITION. THIRTY SIX FORTY
SEVEN SEVEN THE PLACE LIKE HOME
PROPOSITION --
ONE YOU KNOW LET'S LET'S GET
GOING YOU'RE THE VOTERS
EXPRESSES TO MOVE FAST.
ANYWAY THAT'S MY OR ENTER BOTH
YOU KNOW MY BEFORE.
YOU ANSWER RESPOND I THINK YOUR
ARM IS BETTER BOWLER ARE VERY.
LEGITIMATE B. M..
AND CERTAINLY PRE TRIAL
DIVERSION PROGRAMS AS YOU
DESCRIBE AND THAT IS YOU IN CAPS
LATED NSP FIFTEEN AND OTHERS.
ARE POTENTIALLY PART OF THIS.
BUT THIS THE ITEM WE'RE LOOKING
AT IN THIS PILOT I THINK WHAT WE
MIGHT WANT TO HEAR FROM THEM
IT'S IT'S DESCRIBED.
WELL THERE IS LANGUAGE AROUND.
THE BEST IS IN.
IN.
IN GENERAL.
THERE'S ALSO VERY SPEECH.
LANGUAGE.
VERSION IS CLEARLY.
NOT ONLY BUT IS BEING APPLIED
AND WE HAVE MANY --
PROGRAMS LIKE FIFTEEN ARE BEING
APPLIED WHERE WE'VE YOUR THAT.
WE MAY OPT TO NOT EVEN TO BRING
THE PERSON HOLY.
BREIL ANOTHER WORDS IT'S NOT
JUST A PRE TRIAL DIVERSION IT'S
ACTUALLY POTENTIALLY TRYING TO
AVOID THE PERSON EVEN BEING
DEALT WITH WITHIN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE THIS.
AND THE OTHER ASPECTS OF THIS
BRIEF FILED ITS DECISION MAKING
PILOTS ARE MORE AROUND THOSE.
INDIVIDUALS WHO WHO WE'RE GOING
TO ASSUME ARE GOING TO GO TO
TRIAL.
BUT HOW DO WE HANDLE.
YEAH IN TERMS OF BEFORE.
THEY GO TO TRIAL WE HOLD THEM.
OR DO WE RELEASE THEM AND HOW DO
WE ASSURE PUBLIC SAFETY IN THAT
AND SO -- I
WANTED JUST TO MAKE THAT
DISTINCTION AS I THINK IT IS
YOUR POINT IS LEGITIMATE THAT
IT'S NOT.
CLEAR IN THE PILOT.
HOW MUCH DO WE WOULD BE ASKED
BEING OR VALUE WAITING THINGS
THAT ARE ARE OUT [inaudible]
THAT.
VISION MAKING PROCESS THOSE WERE
OUR YES YOU MEAN ARE GONNA GO.
ONLY TO TRIAL.
VERSES.
TYPE OF DIVERSION PROGRAMS THAT
WE HAVE MADE IT VERY CLEAR ARE
VERY IMPORTANT.
IS ELECTED --
KIND OF LIKE [inaudible]
BETTER.
SHOW ME HOW YOU'RE IN
[inaudible]
FAST.
I WRITE WHAT I WRITE.
AND I WILL.
AN ERA AND I I PERSONALLY THINK
THAT.
WE NEED TO EXPAND THE LAW TO
COVER OTHER AREAS.
WELL HEALTH IS LOCAL.
THAT'S A BIG BIG PART OF IT.
EVERYBODY.
I WILL LET OUR FOLKS ANSWER THAT
BUT I ALSO IN TALKING TO OUR
STATS MIGHT.
I THOUGHT THAT WE MIGHT WANT TO
HAVE A ITEM WHERE WE JUST TALK
ABOUT IT.
PROGRAMS AS THE IT ISN'T.
YOU KNOW WE MAY WANT TO GET INTO
THIS -- I'M
STAFF AND I JUST.
NOTICED THAT IT WILL BE IN ONE
OF OUR BUT I DO WANT YOU TO
ANSWER BUT WE MAY.
BUT LET'S NOT DO A PILOT.
I I I WOULD SAY --
CENTRE BELL.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
I'M.
MAYBE EIGHTEEN TEN THE ABILITY
REFERENCE I CAN SAY A COUPLE OF
THINGS THAT THE THE PORTS NOW
ARE IN THE PROCESS OF OFMANY A
BEATING AND WE AT THE DISTRICT
COUNCIL HAVE HAD A COUPLE OF
WEBINARS ASSIST THE PORTS TO
MOVE FORWARD ON THAT.
WE ALSO ARE HAVING TO IN PERSON
WELL HERE IN SACRAMENTO AND ONE
IN MAY DOWN AND STAND FOR AND
YOU KNOW IN ORDER TO BRING THE
LOCAL JUSTICE SYSTEM PARTNERS --
WHO ARE WHO ARE MOST --
THE THE BIGGEST USERS OF THE
STATE HOSPITALS TOGETHER ABOUT
BEST PRACTICES IN WAYS THAT WE
CAN EFFECTIVELY AND HE FELT.
THAT WE ARE IN AGREEMENT VIEW OF
THE IMPORTANCE OF THAT IS DUE IN
RECOGNIZING THAT MANY PEOPLE.
OUR JUSTICE INVOLVED --
ARE ARE ALSO SUFFER FROM THEM OR
HAVE HAVE MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
THAT THAT WE COULD BE.
ADDRESSING MOR EFFECTIVELY AND
WE ARE RIGHT WE ARE MOVING
FORWARD WITH THAT.
I THINK THIS PROGRAM IS A CENTER
AS THE CHAIR --
MENTIONED IS A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT IN THAT IT'S GOING TO
ADDRESS ALL THE TRIAL MATTER --
AND IT'S AND IT'S A MUCH OF IT
MUCH OF THE OLD IS THAT WE'RE
GONNA BE TALKING AT THE TIME OF
ARREST.
UP UNTIL PRE ARRANGEMENT RIGHT
AND AND AND WHEN THEY GET TENS
OF PEOPLE BEING DETAINED --
BEFORE RAIMENT THAT ARE THERE
ARE THERE WAYS.
WHAT YOU'RE DOING AND SEND IT?
ALRIGHT HONEY IS THAT A MODEL
THROUGHOUT THE STATE IS THAT THE
RESOURCES WHERE THEY ARE HAPPEN
THAT IT.
AND DECISIONS ARE BEING MADE THE
WHOLE IDEA OF THIS PROJECT IS TO
GO DEEPER RECOGNIZING ANIMAL
LIKE IMPLEMENTING THIS WEEK AND
AND THAT.
IS ON BUT OTHER THINGS ARE
HAPPENING.
RE TILE RIGHT NOW JUST LAST WEEK
WE HAD TWO SIGNIFICANT ACTIONS
THAT HAPPENED BOTH IN THE IN THE
STATE COURT --
AND IN THE FEDERAL COURT AS IT
RELATES TO THE TRIAL IN
CALIFORNIA.
THINGS ARE REALLY SHIPPING AS AS
B. O. F. MENTIONED ON A DAY TO
DAY BASIS --
AND WHAT THIS IS DOING IS THIS
IS GONNA ALLOW US TO REALLY
CONTINUE TO BUILD THE FOUNDATION.
TO A DEEP DIVE AND SELL IF AND
WHEN THE TRIAL HAPPENS BECAUSE
LIKE MOST PEOPLE AGREE THAT THE
TRIAL IS NOT GONNA LOOK THE WAY
IT DOES NOW.
WE DON'T KNOW DEFINITIVELY WHAT
IT'S GONNA LOOK LIKE BUT THIS IS
ALLOWING US TO PLANT THE SEEDS --
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE PRACTICES
THAT ARE TESTED AND THAT WORK IN
ME YEAH.
BUT WHAT I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
DRESSES I I UNDERSTAND.
SENATOR BILL'S CONCERN IS THAT
ARE YOU LOOKING AT A PILOT TO
TEST.
PRE DIVERSION PROGRAMS WE'VE
ALREADY AUTHORIZED AND I AND SO
THAT IS ONE OF THESE CONFUSIONS
ABOUT THE DESCRIPTION OF THIS.
AND SO.
I AGREE WITH SENATOR BELL I
DON'T.
I'M NOT READY TO GO AND SPEND
MONEY ON TESTING SOMETHING THAT
THE LEGISLATURE HAS ALREADY.
TEAM THAT WE'RE GOING TO PROCEED
WITH.
HOWEVER I THINK IT IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO TEST A FOR ANOTHER
SET OF THINGS THAT YOU'RE
DESCRIBING RIGHT.
AND SO SOME CLARITY WHEN WE
DISCUSS THIS AGAIN WOULD BE
HELPFUL BECAUSE I KNOW HOW MUCH
MORE APPRECIATE.
WHY SENATOR BILL BROUGHT RAISED
HIS CONCERN [inaudible]
I THINK [inaudible]
LAST.
I THINK THAT [inaudible]
RIGHT --
THAT'S WHY [inaudible]
SURE [inaudible]
WELL.
THANK YOU HEARD SOME OF THE YEAH.
ALL I WOULD SAY IS THAT WE WILL
WE WE RAISE UP.
EXTENSIVE ENOUGH NOT.
WE WILL WE WILL GO BACK AND WORK
WITH OUR THE NEW THE CHEATS NEW
WORKGROUP --
WORK WITH THEM.
WORK WITH A FINANCE AND AND YOUR
STAFF I'M I'M UP WITH LANGUAGE
THAT WILL PROVIDE SOME.
OUR OBJECTIVES ARE ARE THE SAME.
RETURN TO WORK MINIMIZING BIAS
THAT'S I POPULATION [inaudible]
OUT BACK.
AND WE WILL ALSO I'M. ONE OF
YOUR OF EMPLOYMENT.
EIGHT YEAH WE WE ARE RIGHT NOW.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS DANIEL SANCHEZ ON BEHALF
OF THE CHIEF PROBATION OFFICERS
pAPPRECIATE.
BEING ABLE TO BE HERE TODAY AND
AND FOR THE COMMENTS --
FROM YOU --
MADAM CHAIR AND THE MEMBERS.
WE SEE THIS IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT --
I AREA FOR THE STAY AND AS WAS
DISCUSSED HERE WE KNOW THAT
THEIR CURRENT.
CURRENTLY IS CASE LAW IN THIS
AREA AND SO IMPACTS TO THE
SYSTEM ARE ALREADY HAPPENING
CHANGES ARE ALREADY HAPPENING --
AND WE THINK.
THAT IT'S IMPERATIVE REALLY THAT
WE COLLECTIVELY ACT ON THIS TO
MAKE SURE THAT ALL OF THE THINGS
THAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT REALLY
ARE ADDRESSED.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO SEE PARK WHEN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ON A PRE
TRIAL THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
DEVELOPING PROGRAMS BOTH THAT
ARE.
RESPONSIVE TO LOCAL NEEDS BUT
THAT ARE ALSO REFLECTIVE OF ALL
OF THE VALUES THAT YOU MENTIONED
AND THAT --
BRINGS A DEGREE OF UNIFORMITY --
TO THE FAIR ADMINISTRATION OF
JUSTICE AND SAID THOSE ARE
VALUES AND THINGS THAT ARE
REALLY IMPORTANT. TO PROBATION
AND I KNOW I KNOW OUR SYSTEM
PARTNERS AS WELL --
TOWARD THAT END I SEE PARKING
DID -- JUST
RECENTLY PUT TOGETHER --
I'LL BE TRIAL TOOL KIT ON THAT
WE WORKED VERY VERY CLOSELY WITH
IN CONJUNCTION WITH THE PRE
TRIAL JUSTICE INSTITUTE WHICH IS
A NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED EXPERT
IN THIS AREA.
REALLY TO HELP GUIDE BEST
PRACTICES AND TO GIVE KIND OF ON
A ROAD MAP --
TO COUNTIES AGAIN IN OUR OUR
WHARTON COUNTY IT SHOULD BE AND
MOVING FORWARD WITH THIS.
I THINK ALL UNDER THE HEADER OF
THE VERY THINGS THAT THIS
COMMITTEE HAS TALKED ABOUT ON
WANTED TO MAKE SURE.
THAT IT IS STRUCTURED IN A WAY
AGAIN THAT THERE IS --
REFLECTIVE OF WHAT WE WANT IT TO
BE -- AND
ALSO --
AGAIN LOOKING AT BEST PRACTICES
AND AND THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
OF JUSTICE --
PROBATION MANY OF THE THINGS
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE --
ARE CURRENTLY --
DUTIES AND THINGS THAT FALL
WITHIN OUR MISSION --
FROM FROM WORKING ON ASSESSMENTS
I'M DOING SOME OF THE MONITORING
AND SUPERVISION AND SO --
WITH PROBATION KIND OF BEING
THIS THIS LYNCH PEN BETWEEN --
OUR COURT PARTNERS ARE COUNTY
PARTNERS STATE AND LOCAL --
AND AND THE DIFFERENT PARTS OF
THE SYSTEM DONE A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF WORK AND AND SO AS
THIS COMMITTEE IN THE
LEGISLATURE ON THIS BOARD ALONG
WITH THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL AND
THE ADMINISTRATION WE CERTAINLY
HOPE TO BE A PART OF THESE
CONVERSATIONS WE THINK AGAIN
THIS IS A VERY.
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE I THINK
THERE ARE SOME GREAT THINGS THAT
WE CAN DO THERE AGAIN TO MAKE
SURE THAT WORK ON PROVIDING THE
RIGHT TYPES OF SERVICES TO THE
COMMUNITY MAKING THE RIGHT TYPES
OF RISK BASED DECISIONS.
I'M GOING FORWARD SO WE
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COME AND LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU.
ADAM TURNED MEMBERS ELIZABETH
HAS BEEN --
SEE HERE UP THIS AFTERNOON ON
BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT
OF THE SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS THAT WOULD GO TOWARD THE
PRETRIAL SERVICES RIGHT LET'S.
JUST FOR A BIT OF BACKGROUND
TONY IS ENGAGED IN A VERY LARGE
SCALE REVIEW.
OF ITS LCAL CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM RESPONSIBILITIES BUT YOU
ARE ALL AWARE HAVE CHANGED
SUBSTANTIALLY IN THE LAST DECADE.
AND OUR REFINING THEIR RESPONSES
HOW THEY'RE MANAGING.
THE POPULATION LOCALLY THE BOARD
IS VERY MUCH ALIGNED WITH THE
VALUES THAT YOU'VE TALKED ABOUT
HERE I'M INTERESTED IN ENSURING
THAT.
ARE RELEASED DECISIONS ARE
INFORMED BY THE BEST SCIENCE SO
THAT THOSE WHO WE EAT IN CUSTODY
ARE THOSE WHERE OUR GREATEST
RISK TO BE.
OR TO RE OFFEND IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OBVIOUSLY THAT MANS
THERE REMAINS A VERY LARGE
POPULATION THAT COULD BE MANAGED
FREE TRIAL SYSTEM.
ONLY HAS ALREADY BEGUN
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE WORD
ABOUT IT.
EATING IN THE PILOT PROJECT.
I WHICH FANTASTIC DEVELOPMENT OF
COURSE WE KNEW FOR AND HOW MANY
RESPONSIBILITIES IN RSPONDING.
TO THE PRE TRIAL.
SERVICES SYSTEM AS WELL BY HAND
IN GLOVE EFFORT.
AND WOULD ENCOURAGE OF THIS BODY
AND THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL TO US
CERTAINLY CONSIDER COUNTIES
CONTRIBUTIONS.
AND ENTHUSIASM AND PARTICIPATING
I'M CONVERSATIONS AND AND WHAT
ASPECT.
THAT WHEN YOU CONSIDER RESOURCES
YOU ALSO CONSIDERI LET.
I'M SO IN SUPPORT OF A SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION FOR THE SERVICES
AND WANTED TO THANK SENATOR
BELPER RACING --
AS WELL THE ISSUES OF AB
EIGHTEEN AN IMPLEMENTATION.
COUNTY IS EXTREMELY IT'S VERY
INTERESTING YOUR CONVERSATIONS
HELLO THE CONVERSATION HAPPENING
LOCALLY.
I'M A COUNTY IS VERY INTERESTED
IN DISCUSSING HOW TO BUILD OUT
BOTH LOCAL.
CASSIDY --
TO HAVE A PLACE FOR FOLKS WERE
DIVERTED TO GO AND RECEIVE.
IT SUPPORTS AND SERVICES AND OUT
OF THE SYSTEM --
WE'RE INTERESTED IN CONTINUE
THAT CONVERSATION AND THE
SPECIFIC YOU WANT.
I PUT THAT ON YOU WRITE WITH A
C. R. U. CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
OF THE SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR PROPOSAL I'M DEFINITELY
LOOK FORWARD TO ALL THE DETAILS
THAT ARE GOING TO BE FLUSHED OUT
HERE SOON AND LOOK FORWARD TO
THE FUTURE HEARING WERE
DIVERSION IS GONNA BE DISCUSS.
SPECIFICALLY AND REALLY
APPRECIATE THE ROBUST.
I NEED MY OWN BUT THE ELEVATOR.
AND WE ARE IN.
I BELIEVE THAT WHERE.
I LIVE.
AND WE KNOW THAT THERE IS STILL
SOME LEVEL OF REFINEMENT OF BAT.
BUT WE DO BELIEVE THAT
[inaudible]
DEFINITELY NOT.
AT WORK.
IN THOSE MOST IMPACTED
[inaudible]
LIKE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OUT BEING OTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
BURN FINANCED KNOWN ALRIGHT SO
WE WILL.
INCLUDE TODAY'S HEARING.
AND I THANKS ALL PARTICIPATING
THANK YOU ALL